Apache spark is a popularly used
analytics engine for big data processing
hi everyone welcome to this live session
on spark full course in this session you
will learn the critical Concepts in
spark starting from Basics to Advanced
for handling data efficiently
you will learn the important components
of spark with Hands-On demonstrations
our experienced instructor Ajay will
take us through this live session
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so we will start by understanding the
basics of Apache spark and look at how
to install spark on Windows and Ubuntu
moving further you will understand the
spark architecture in detail next you
will see the different components of
spark starting with spark streaming then
you will learn how to query data using
spark SQL and perform machine learning
operations with the help of spark
machine learning library
you will also focus on how to use spice
Park to analyze Walmart stock data
welcome to this tutorial on Apache spark
one of the most in-demand Technologies
and processing Frameworks in the Big
Data world and here we will learn on
Apache spark history of spark what is
spark Hadoop which is a framework again
West spark components of Apache spark
that is spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of Apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at UC Berkeley amp
Labs by mate zaheria in 2010 it was open
source under the BST license in 2013
spark became an Apache top level project
and in 2014 used by data bricks to
sort large scale data sets and it set a
new world record so that's how Apache
spark started and today it is one of the
most in-demand processing framework or I
would say in memory Computing framework
which is used across the Big Data
industry so what is Apache spark let's
learn about this Apache spark is a open
source in memory Computing framework or
you could say data processing engine
which is used to process data in batch
and also in real time across various
cluster computers and it has a very
simple programming language behind the
scenes that is Scala which is used
although if users would want to work on
spark they can work with python they can
work with Scala they can work with Java
and so on even R for that matter so it
supports all these programming languages
and that's one of the reasons that it is
called polyglot wherein you have good
set of libraries and support from all
the programming languages and developers
and data scientists incorporate spark
into their applications or build spark
based applications to process analyze
query and transform data at a very large
scale so these are key features of
Apache spark now if you compare Hadoop
West spark we know that Hadoop is a
framework and it basically has mapreduce
which comes with Hadoop for processing
data however processing data using
mapreduce in Hadoop is quite slow
because it is a batch oriented operation
and it is time consuming if you if you
talk about spark spark can process the
same data 100 times faster than
mapreduce as it is a in-memory Computing
framework well there can always be
conflicting ideas saying what if my
spark application is not really
efficiently coded and my mapreduce
application has been very efficiently
coded well then it's a different case
however normally if you talk about code
which is efficiently written format
reduce or for spark based processing
spark will win the battle by doing
almost 100 times faster than mapreduce
so as I mentioned Hadoop performs batch
processing and that is one of the
paradigms of mapreduce programming model
which involves mapping and reducing and
that's quite rigid so it performs batch
processing the intermittent data is
written to sdfs and written right back
from sdfs and that makes hadoops
mapreduce processing slower in case of
spark it can perform both batch and
real-time processing however a lot of
use cases are based on real time
processing take an example of Macy's
take an example of retail giant such as
Walmart and there are many use cases who
would prefer to do real time processing
what I would say near real time
processing so when we say real time or
near real time it is about processing
the data as it comes in or you're
talking about streaming kind of data now
Hadoop or hadoop's map reduce obviously
was started to be written in Java now
you could also write it in Scala or in
Python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in Java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
Driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in Scala and Scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and object
oriented language and in case of Scala
whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now Hadoop supports
Kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms Kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of cabalose so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data set
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we learn more about rdds later
so spark contains rdds which saves huge
time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
Hadoop when we say in memory Computing
here I would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in-memory Computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit
further queries however when we say in
memory Computing we are talking about
lazy evaluation we are talking about
data being loaded into memory only and
only when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in Ram so here
we can say Ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that Ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as I already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in Java Scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say a execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded and the data
will be loaded into rdds only when
execution is happening so these can be
fault tolerant as these rdds are
distributed across multiple nodes so
failure of one worker node in the
cluster will really not affect the rdds
because that portion can be recomputed
so it ensures loss of data it ensures
that there is no data loss and it is
absolutely fault tolerant it is for
better analytics so sparked has Rich set
of SQL queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various spark components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which I'm talking
about spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
SQL so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structurized would want to prefer
using spark SQL and Spark SQL internally
has components or features like data
frames and data sets which can be used
to process your structured data in a
much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have Sparks ml lib now this
is basically a set of libraries which
allows developers or data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do Predictive Analytics
or prescriptive descriptive preemptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have Graphics so
think about organizations like LinkedIn
or say Twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when I talk
about graphs I'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but I'm talking
about Network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about Facebook think about LinkedIn
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called Graphics which allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
Apache spark spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics so
to learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with is spark core which has rdds
as the building blocks of your spark so
it is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling Distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here I would like to
make a key point that Spar by itself
does not have its own storage it relies
on storage now that storage could be
your sdfs that is Hadoop system it could
be a database like nosql database such
as hbase or it could be any other
database say rdbms from where you could
connect your spark and then fetch the
data extract the data process it analyze
it so let's learn a little bit about
your rdds resilient distributed data
sets now spark core which is the base
engine or the core engine is embedded
with the building blocks of spark which
is nothing but your resilient
distributed data set so as the name says
it is resilient so it is existing for a
shorter period of time distributed so it
is distributed across nodes and it is a
data set where the data will be loaded
or where the data will be existing for
processing so it is immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects so that is what your rdd is and
there are mainly two operations which
can be performed on an rdd now to take
an example of this say I want to process
a particular file now here I could write
a simple code in Scala and that would
basically mean something like this so if
I say well which is to declare the
variable I would say well X and then I
could use what we call as spark context
which is basically the most important
entry point of your application so then
I could use a method of spark context
for example that is text file and then I
could point it to a particular file so
this is just a method of your spark
context and Spark context is the entry
point of your application now here I
could just give a path in this method so
what does this step do it does not do
any evaluation so when I say Val X I am
creating a immutable variable and to
that variable I'm assigning a file now
what this step does is it actually
creates a rdd resilient distributed data
set so we can imagine this as a simple
execution logic AMT data set which is
created in memory of your node so if I
would say I have multiple nodes in which
my data is split and stored I'm
imagining that your yarn your spark is
working with Hadoop so I have Hadoop
which is using say two nodes and this is
my distributed file system sdfs which
basically means my file is written to
hdfs and it also means that the file
related blocks are stored in the
underlying disk of these machines so
when I say Val x equals SC dot text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallelize and so on
this step will create an rdt so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and I can say first
step in what we call as a tag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later I could do further processing on
this I could say well Y and then I could
do something on X so I could say x dot
map and I would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and I could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created it which
depends on the first RTD so my first RTD
becomes the base rdd or parent rdd and
the resultant rdd becomes the child rdd
then we can go further and we could say
well Z and I would say okay now I would
want to do some filter on y so this
filter which I am doing here and then I
could give a logic might be I'm
searching for a word I am searching for
some pattern so I could say well Z
equals y dot filter which again creates
one more rdd a resilient distributed
data set in memory and a you can say
this is nothing but one more step in the
dag so this is my tag which is a series
of steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data gets when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
and like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your Transformations so the
operations such as map filter join Union
and many others will only create rdds
which basically means it is only
creating execution Logic No data is
evaluated no operation is happening
right now only and only when you invoke
an action that is might be you want to
print some result might be you want to
take some elements and see that might be
you want to do a count so those are
actions which will actually trigger the
execution of this dag right from the
beginning so if I hear say Z dot count
where I would want to just count the
number of words which I am filtering
this is an action which is invoked and
this will trigger the execution of dag
right from the beginning so this is what
happens in a spark now if I do a z dot
count again it will start the whole
execution of dag again right from the
beginning so my Z dot count second time
in action is invoked again the data will
be loaded in the first RTD then you will
have map then you will have filter and
finally you will have result so this is
the core concept of your rdds and this
is how RTD works so mainly in spark
there are two kind of operations one is
your Transformations and one is your
actions Transformations are using a
method of spark context will always and
always create an RTD or you could say a
step in the tag actions are something
which will invoke the execution which
will invoke the execution from the first
rdd till the last rdd where you can get
your result so this is how your rdds
work now when we talk about components
of spark let's learn a little bit about
spark SQL so spark SQL is a component
type processing framework which is used
for structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
particular delimiters and has a pattern
and if one wants to process the
structured data if one wants to use
spark to do in memory processing and
work on the structured data they would
prefer to use spark SQL so you can work
on different data formats say CSV Json
you can even work on smarter formats
like Avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark SQL it has a data
Source API which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now spark SQL has something called as
data frame API so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame API allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some Transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frames or when you want to use spark SQL
you would use
Sparks context which is SQL context or
Hive context or spark which allows you
to work with data frames so like in my
earlier example we were saying Val x
equals SC dot text file now in case of
data frames instead of SC you would be
using say spark dot something so spark
context is available for your data
frames API to be used in older versions
like spark 1.6 and so on we were using
Hive context or SQL context so if you
were working with spark 1.6 you would be
saying well x equals SQL context dot
here we would be using spark dot so data
frame API basically allows you to create
data frames out of your structured data
which also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
Sparks backend dag scheduler right so
when I say about dag I talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of what are the different steps
involved in your application so your
data frame API basically allows you to
create data frames out of your data and
data frames when I say I'm talking about
rows and columns with some headings and
then you have your data frame DSL
language or you can use spark SQL or
Hive query language any of these options
can be used to work with your data
frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like Macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
lot of customers walking in the store
and they are searching for particular
product or particular item so there
could be cameras placed in the store and
this is being already done there are
cameras placed in the store which will
keep monitoring in which corner of the
store there are more customers now once
camera captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will will see which product
or which series of product customers
might be interested in and if this
algorithm in real time can process based
on the number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even a
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real-time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
Behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be seeing the
essence of real-time processing only in
a fixed or in a particular duration of
time and this also means that you should
have something which can process the
data as it comes in so spark streaming
is a lightweight API that allows
developers to perform batch processing
and also real-time streaming and
processing of data so it provides secure
reliable fast processing of live data
streams so what happens here in spark
streaming in brief so you have a input
data stream now that data stream could
be a file which is constantly getting
appended it could be some kind of
metrics it could be some kind of events
based on the clicks which customers are
doing or based on the products which
they are choosing in a store this input
data stream is then pushed in through a
spark streaming application now spark
streaming application will broke break
this content into smaller streams what
we call as discreticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh options like when I say windows
I mean a window of past three events
window of past three events each event
being of five seconds so your batches of
smaller data is processed by Spark
engine and this process data can then be
stored or can be used for further
processing so that's what spark
streaming does when you talk about mlib
it's a low level machine learning
library that is simple to use scalable
and compatible with various programming
languages now Hadoop also has some
libraries like you have Apache mahaut
which can be used for machine learning
algorithms however in terms of spark we
are talking about machine learning
algorithms which can be built using
mlibs libraries and then spark can be
used for processing so mlib eases the
deployment and development of scalable
machine learning algorithms I mean think
about your clustering techniques so
think about your classification where
you want to classify the data where you
would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
Sparks ml lip Graphics is Spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
Facebook think about LinkedIn where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data has some kind of network
connections or you could say it is well
networked I could say x is connected to
y y is connected to z z is connected to
a so x y z a all of these are in terms
of graph terminologies we call as
vertices or vertex which are basically
being connected and the connection
between the
are called edges so I could say a is
friend to B so A and B are vertices and
friend a relation between them is The
Edge now if I have my data which can be
represented in the form of graphs if I
would want to do a processing in such
way this could be not only for social
media it could be for your network
devices it could be a cloud platform it
could be about different applications
which are connected in a particular
environment so if you have data which
can be represented in the form of graph
then Graphics can be used to do ETL that
is extraction transformation load to do
your data analysis and also do
interactive graph computation so graph x
is quite powerful now when you talk
about spark your spark can work with
your different clustering Technologies
so it can work with Apache mesos that's
how Spar came in where it was initially
to prove The credibility of Apache mesos
spark can work with yarn which is
usually you will see in different
working environments Spa can also work
as Standalone that means without Hadoop
spark can have its own setup with master
and worker processes so usually or you
can say technically spark uses a Master
Slave architecture now that consists of
a driver program that can run on a
master node it can also run on a client
node it depends on how you have
configured or what your application is
and then you have multiple executors
which can run on worker nodes so your
master node has a driver program and
this driver program internally has the
spark context so your spark Every Spark
application will have a driver program
and that's driver program has a inbuilt
or internally used spark context which
is basically your entry point of
application for any spark functionality
so your driver or your driver program
interacts with your cluster manager now
when I say interacts with clustered
manager so you have your spark context
which is the entry point that takes your
application request to the cluster
manager now as I said your cluster
manager could be say Apache mesos it
could be yarn it could be spark
Standalone Master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
set of tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and Spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to Cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be on and in terms of when
I say cluster manager for yarn would be
resource manager so at high level we can
say a job is split into multiple tasks
and those tasks will be distributed over
the slave nodes or worker nodes so
whenever you do some kind of
transformation or you use a method of
spark context and rdd is created and
this rdd is distributed across multiple
nodes as I explained earlier worker
nodes are the slaves that run different
tasks so this is how a spark
architecture looks like now we can learn
more about spark architecture and its
interaction with yarn so usually what
happens when your spark context
interacts with the cluster manager so in
terms of yarn I could say resource
manager now we already know about yarn
so you would have say node managers
running on multiple machines and each
machine has some RAM and CPU cores
allocated for your node manager on the
same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the Hadoop related data so whenever
a application wants to process the data
your application via spark contacts
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager makes a
request so resource manager makes
requests to the node manager of the
machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can I have a container of 1GB
RAM and one CPU core can I have a
container of 1GB RAM and one CPU core
and your node manager based on the kind
of processing it is doing will approve
or deny it so node manager would say
fine I can give you the container and
once this container is allocated or
approved by node manager resource
manager will basically start an extra
piece of code called App Master so App
Master is responsible for execution of
your application locations whether those
are spark applications or mapreduce so
your application Master which is a piece
of code will run in one of the
containers that is it will use the RAM
and CPU core and then it will use the
other containers which were allocated by
node manager to run the tasks so it is
within this container which can take
care of execution so what is a container
a combination of RAM and CPU core so it
is within this container we will have a
executed process which would run and
this executed process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark Works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about the
spark cluster managers as I said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without Hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark Standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark stand in loan class cluster which
basically means you could have multiple
nodes on one of the nodes you would have
the master process running and on the
other nodes you would have the spark
worker processes running so here we
would not have any distributed file
system because spark is Standalone and
it will rely on an external storage to
get the data or probably the file system
of the nodes where the data is stored
and processing will happen across the
nodes where your worker processes are
running you could have spark working
with Apache mesos now as I said Apache
mesos is a open source project to manage
your computer clusters and can also run
Hadoop applications Apache mesos was
introduced earlier and Spark came in and
as existence to prove The credibility of
Apache mesos you can have spark working
with hadoop's yarn this is something
which widely you will see in different
working environments so yarn which takes
care of your processing and can take
care of different processing Frameworks
also supports spark you could have
kubernetes now that is something which
is making a lot of news in today's world
it is an open source system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
so where you could have multiple Docker
based images which can be connecting to
each other so spark also works with
kubernetes now let's look at some
applications of spark so JPMorgan Chase
and company uses Spark to detect
fraudulent transactions analyze the
business pens of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and in
memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
Alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
looking at the browsing history in the
form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so Alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have IQ via now this is a
leading Healthcare company that uses
Spark to analyze patients data identify
possible health issues and diagnose it
based on their medical history so there
is a lot of work happening in healthcare
industry where real-time processing is
finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so healthcare industry and iqvi
is also using spark you have Netflix
which is known and you have Riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like Netflix and write games use Apache
spark to Showcase relevant
advertisements to their users based on
the videos that they have watched shared
or liked so these are few domains which
find use cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce Healthcare entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day-to-day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the Spark's use
case and let's talk about con Viva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about YouTube
which has data you could always read
about it so YouTube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so that is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this videos are
streamed in or can be watched by users
so video streaming is a challenge and
especially with increasing demand for
high quality streaming experiences
conviva collects data about video
streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it Apache spark again using
Apache spark convert delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about Network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic coming in from
4 billion video feeds every month to
ensure maximum retention Now using
Apache spark conver has created an auto
diagnostics alert it automatically
detects anomalies along the video
streaming Pipeline and diagnosis the
root cause of the issue now this really
makes it one of the leading video your
streaming companies based on auto
diagnostic alerts it reduces waiting
time before the video starts it avoids
buffering and recovers the video from a
technical error and the whole goal is to
maximize the viewer engagement so this
is Spark's use case where conviva is
using spark in different ways to stay
ahead in video streaming related
deliveries so let's have a quick demo on
setting up spark on Windows and trying
out the Spark's interactive way of
working for this first thing is you will
have to download spark now you can just
go to Google and type spark download and
once you click on this link it shows you
a spark release a package type which
says pre-built so we will have to get a
pre-built Apache Hadoop related spark so
here I will choose say spark 2.4.3 and I
will choose pre-built for Apache 2.6 and
then I can just click and download on
the spark
2.4.3 bin Hadoop 2.6 star file once you
click on this link takes you to the
mirror site and you can just click on
this link and download spark
2.4.3 once this is done which I have
already downloaded here I can go to my
downloads and it shows that I have a tar
file now we will have to untar it or
unzip it so I can click on this link and
I already have WinZip which allows me to
unzip spark 2.4.3 I can choose a
location so I can say unzip click on
unzip choose local and then I can choose
one of my folders so I have already
unzipped it here and that's how my spark
2.4.4 directory exists here 2.4.3 I'm
sorry now let's go and look into this
directory and what it contains so so I
can click on C drive and then spark
2.4.3 and this has the folders which are
required for us to use spark if you look
in bin we have different applications
and commands which we can use and if you
also see I would have added one of the
utilities here either we can have the
win utils because spark will need Hadoop
and we are planning to use spark on
windows so what we need is this so I
have in my desktop a Hadoop directory
which has a bin folder and here I have
downloaded a win utils executable file
which you can always search on internet
and you can say download when
utils.exe for spark 64-bit and then you
can find the link from where you can
download this for example we can click
on this and here we can search for when
utils so here we have the link I can
open this link in a different Tab and
this basically shows me when utils for
Hadoop 2.7.1 similarly you can search
for Hadoop 2.6 and you can download
however 2.7 will also work fine now I
have downloaded win
utils.exe and that's in this Hadoop
folder within bin I have this so we need
two things here one is spark which is
untied and in a particular location and
then your Hadoop which has been and this
has been utils now once you have these
things you can set your environment
variables by just type in envir go to
your edit system environment variables
click on environment variables and here
if you see I have added two variables so
you can just click on new and then you
can give your variable name as Hadoop
underscore home and then you can give
the path where you have your Hadoop
directory that contains bin and that
contains win
util.exe I also have added spark home
which points to my spark directory now
once you have this you are ready to use
your spark on Windows in local mode once
this is done I can open up my command
prompt and here I need to go to my spark
directory I can just say CD Spar 2.4.3
and then I can do a dir slash P which
shows me the folders where we have been
so to execute spark we can look into
what our bin has and it has different
programs such as you have spark shell to
work with Scala and in an interactive
way of working with spark you can also
use Pi spark which allows you to use
Python to work with spark and you also
have spark submit if you have packaged
your application in a jar file to submit
it on a cluster so in this case we would
be use using spark in a local mode so
let's use spark shell and test it so I
can just say spark shell in this way to
start my spark in an interactive way now
based on the path which you have set for
your win utils.exe and Spark shell you
should be able to use spark so it says
welcome to spark version 2.4.3 it also
shows that spark context which is the
entry point of your application is
available as SC wherein it is connecting
to master as local and it has an
application ID it also shows you a spark
UI which you can look at and it says
spark session is available as spark so
if you are interested in working with
spark core that is with rdds we would be
using spark context and if you are
interested in working with spark SQL
that is data frames and data sets then
we can be using spark session so let's
try it out so we can declare a variable
that is a mutable variable and now I
will use spark context with a method of
spark context so I can just do a tab to
see what are the available options
within your spark context and here we
can use one of them to read a file so I
will use SC dot text file and then I
need to point to a file so I already
know that in my spark directory I have a
file called
readme.rd and this is the method of
spark context if I enter it will create
a rdd now as I've explained about rdds
these are resilient distributed data
sets there is no evaluation happening
right now so even if this file does not
exist I would still have an rdd created
now I can go further and do some more
Transformations on this so I could say
Val Y and then I could say take X I
would like to do a map transformation on
it and I would use two upper case now
this is a inbuilt function where I would
want to convert the content of this file
into uppercase when I hit on enter it
again creates an rdd and this rdd is
basically a child rdd of the parent rdd
created by text file remember here we
don't have any evaluation happening or
any execution happening it is just
Transformations which will lead to
creation of further rdds now we can
invoke an action to see the result and
whenever you invoke an action it will
trigger the execution of your dag
starting from your first rdd till the
last transformation you did before
invoking an action so I could just say
count to see how many lines it has and
once I do this it says input path does
not exist it is not able to find a file
in this location so this clearly
explains that there was no valuation
happening when we did this when we tried
to read a file and neither when we did a
map transformation only and only when we
invoked an action it tried to search for
file in this location so let's quit this
and check if the file exists to quit you
can just do a Ctrl D or you could do a
colon quit now here if you see some
messages like this which says unable to
delete temporary file so that's a known
issue we can fix that but my spark is
working fine now let's go and check if
the file exists so I will go in here and
then I will look in my spark directory
to see if the file exists so this is the
file
readme.md however I had done readme.rd
so let's do it again and let's test if
our spark shell works fine so we can go
into the spark directory by just doing
this and then either I could be going
into bin directory and then start spark
shell or Some people prefer to do it
this way wherein you can say bin spark
shell and that should start your spark
shell but there was a error in the in
the slash so let's do it this way and
this will start your spark shell an
interactive way of working with your
spark and using spark context or spark
now once we have done this I can again
say Val X and I can say SC which is Spar
context which is already initialized
when you start your spark shell I can
say text file and I would want to read a
file which is
readme.md now we know that this file
exists however the checking of the file
existing or not that means an evaluation
does not happen when you do a
transformation or when you use a method
of spark context it just creates an rdd
click on this and this has created an
rdd of string now we can do further
other transformation on X by saying map
and then I can say I would want to
convert the content into uppercase and
that's also done now finally let's
invoke an action which will trigger the
execution of my tag which contains these
rdds so I could just say Y and I could
say take 10 and I could say for each
print Ln and this should be able to
invoke an action and it shows me the
result from the file which is converted
into uppercase remember if I do a y dot
count which is another action it will
trigger the execution of dag right from
the beginning where the first RTD was
created the transformation will be done
and then it will show me the count of
lines which exist as a result of this so
we can do this and this says me that
there are 105 lines this is a simple
example of using Spark shell and using
Spar in an interactive way on your
Windows machine now to quit we can
always do a colon quit or we could do a
control D and that basically takes you
out of your spark shell similarly we can
work on Pi Spark by just saying dot
slash bin slash Pi spark and that's
Python's way of working with spark which
brings your python shell it starts the
spark context which is available as SC
and if you are interested in working on
data frames or data sets using spark SQL
then we would be using spark now here I
can just declare a variable X and I can
just do SC dot text file like what we
did using Scala we can be referring to
the same file
readme.md and this has created an rdd
you can just type in X and that shows
the rdd which was created you can then
further do some transformation on it
using x dot map and then I could say I
would want to convert this to uppercase
now in case of python you would normally
use Lambda if you would want to do any
kind of transformation so I would say
Lambda X and then I would want to
convert this to uppercase so here we can
check if my rdd was correctly created
and as I was saying we can then do some
transformation on it so I can say again
y equals and then I would want to do
some transformation on X I would say x
dot map so in case of python as I
explained whenever we want to use
anonymous function or we want to do some
transformation then we can pass in the
function to the transformation so here I
can say Lambda and then I can just say
line or I could say X or a whatever that
is and I could say line I would use a
inbuilt function that is upper which
should convert the content of x to
uppercase now remember we are just doing
some Transformations here so if I click
on y again and enter sorry if I enter y
it will show me that that has created an
rdd to see the content I can just say y
dot collect and that should show me the
content of first few lines which is
converted in uppercase so this clearly
shows that we can even use Python to
work with Spark by using pi spark now
with this we can just say quit and that
should take you out of your Pi spark
shell so this is how you work on spark
shell or Pi spark on your Windows
machine so this has a local spark setup
or basically spark running in a local
mode and you could be using the
attractive way of working with spark now
if we have packaged our application in a
jar file then I could be using spark
submit to submit my application how do
we do that for this we can basically
bring up one of our Ides so in my case
I'm using eclipse and I can get into my
Eclipse now there are two options here
one we can be writing code in your IDE
that is Eclipse we can be compiling the
code based on the spark related jars and
then we can run our application from IDE
which would interact with your spark
that's one way the second way is we can
use packaging tools like SBT to package
our application as jar and then push the
jar to your local spark or a Hadoop base
spark and then run it using spark submit
now this is a simple sample application
for which I have set up certain things
here the first thing is when you have
downloaded eclipse for all the people
who are new they might have to add the
Scala plugin now if you see here in my
Eclipse it shows up Java perspective and
it shows Scala perspective now how did I
get this you can click on help and you
can say install new software and here
you can say add you can say Scala IDE
and then you will have to give a link
from where you can get the Scala IDE how
do I get that so I can go to my browser
and I can say Scala IDE dot org and once
you go to this link just scroll down
click on stable and that shows you
different releases for your different
Ides now for Eclipse although this shows
for oxygen and I have Eclipse neon but
that works fine you can just copy this
link and here once you have copied the
link give the location here and you can
say okay now once you do that it shows
you different options from where you can
choose color ID for Eclipse now in my
case it is already installed so these
options don't show up however if you do
not have this option for example let's
choose something else say I will say
Scala search and once I do this next
gets activated so scholar ID is already
installed in my case so I can click on
next and this should basically get
scholar search plugin also which can be
added to my Eclipse now once this is
done you will be prompted to restart
your eclipse and then you should have
your Scala perspective so for now I'll
just cancel this because I already have
my Scala ID dot Eclipse so this is done
I'll just do a cancel here now once you
have your Scala ID or Scala plugin added
to your IDE you can always click on this
icon here and here you can just click
double click on Scala that will open up
Scala perspective so that's the first
thing then you can always click on file
new and create a Scala project for
example I could say my test apps and
then I can just say finish so it has
added a project now what we need to do
is we need to make sure that our setup
is fine so first thing I would suggest
is click on this go to your build path
and here click on configure build path
so where it says call a compiler it
would be good to choose for your project
settings instead of 2.12 go for 2.11 so
sometimes you might have problems with
Scala 2.12 which might not be able to
compile for your Scala 2.11 so use
latest 2.11 bundle and then you can say
apply it says compiler settings have
changed a full rebuild is required for
changes to take effect shall all
projects be clean now we can and say
okay and we can say Okay so this will
build your workspace to use Scala 2.11
bundle now once that is done second
thing what we need is we would want to
write our code and we would want our
code to compile for that as I said if we
want to write our code using an IDE and
then run it from our IDE rather than
using a build tool like Maven or SVT I
can just add the spark related jars to
my build path so I can right click here
I can say build path and I can click on
configure build path and here where it
says libraries I can say add external
charts now this needs my spark related
jars now where do I find it so remember
we have downloaded spark so you can even
find it there so you can click on
wherever your spark is and then you can
click for jars which shows you all spark
related jars you can just do a control a
and just add it to your build path say
apply and then just say Okay so once
this is done you have already added the
spark related jars which might be good
enough for you to write an application
once this is done we need to basically
go ahead and write our code now how do I
do that I can just click on source and I
can say new and then I can say package
and here you can say main dot Scala
click on finish and that has created
main dot Scala so that would be Source
slash main slash Scala in the folders we
can always check that so I can go to C
drive I can look in users win 10 and
then look in my workspace for my project
and if you see in Source we have Main
and we have Scala now this is where we
will be writing our code so for this
then I can just right click and I can
say new and I can just create an object
and I can give it a name so we can say
test app and then we can say finish so
in case of Scala and Spark we need to
create an object and then we need to
Define main class here once that is done
we also need to import some packages and
we need to initialize the spark context
now for that you can take an example
here so I have already written the code
and I can look in Source main Scala and
I have created an app called first
app.scala now here we have the package
name we are importing some packages
which are required for us to initialize
spark context and Spark configuration so
it is spark context spark conf and here
is my object and for a particular
project at least one of your object or
one of your application needs to be the
main so we Define the main here by
saying def Main arbs and array or string
then we need to basically Define our
spark context so I'm creating a
configuration object here and then I say
new spark conf I am setting my
application name to hello spark and then
this is very important if you intend to
run your spark application either using
spark submit or from your IDE you need
to specify your master as local now that
could be given with one thread or
multiple threads so this is my
configuration and then I initialize my
spark context pointing to my
configuration so this is the most
important part here now if you see this
is something which I showed you in the
command line so I'm doing a Val X and
I'm pointing it to a file in my project
directory which is abc1 dot text so this
is just to make sure that you are giving
a Windows path and you are giving the
right Escape characters now if it would
be if you intend to run this application
on a Hadoop based cluster then you will
have to give the path of the file
accordingly which we can see later so
here I have Val X I am pointing it to a
file which I have created here and this
just contains three lines this is my
sample file which I want to test this is
a new file now here I have created a
variable called X further I would say
Val Y and I would use spark context
method text file like what we did in
interactive way and I'm pointing it to X
I'm also using some extra features like
caching so that I can cache the rdd
which gets created further I create a
variable called counts and then I do it
flat map transformation on Y where I
would split the content based on space I
would do a map transformation where I
would get every word from the file and
map it with number one and finally I do
a Reduce by key operation once this is
done I do a saves as text file now I
could do a collect I could do a take I
could do a count and I could also do a
save as text file where I would want my
output to be saved in this location plus
I am using a Java utility to append a
random number to my output directory
finally I do a spark context top so this
is my application and if you see here my
application completely compiles because
I've already added the relevant jar
files in the build path now once this
application is done we need to run this
but before doing that we need to look
into our run configurations so you can
click on run configurations and here I'm
giving my project name I am specifying
my main class which is first app then
you can straight away go to environment
and here I have added two variables one
is spark underscore local and underscore
IP which points to this machine's
localhost and then I have said Hadoop
underscore home because spark even when
you're running locally would want if
Hadoop is existing so we can just set
Hadoop underscore home and I am pointing
it to my desktop Hadoop directory which
contains bin folder and that bin folder
contains a win
utils.exe once this is done we are fine
and then I can test my application by
just clicking on run now this should
trigger my application on my Windows
machine using my IDE I didn't have to
package this as jar and here my
application is completed which should
have created one additional directory
here so I can click on this I can right
click and I can try doing a refresh and
here you see a new output is created we
can look into this it has a part file
which shows my word count so this is a
simple example of setting up your IDE
and running your applications from IDE
on a local spark now what you also see
is a build file here what is that for so
in case you would want to create a
project and you would want to package
the application as a jar file and then
run it on the cluster using spark submit
now in that case we can avoid adding the
jars to my build path but what I would
need is I would need build dot SBT file
within my project folder remember if you
intend to package your application as a
jar and then run it on a cluster or on a
local setup you would not need the build
related charts however if the build
related charts which are already here
will not cause any harm let them be
there now we have a bill.sbt file also
which is existing in my project folder
now just for this run I can in fact
delete this target directory it will be
anyways recreated and if you would want
we can also clean up these just to avoid
the confusion I will delete these now I
just have my project folder and I have
the libraries I have ABC one dot text
and I have a build dot SVT file what
does that contain so this basically has
a name I'm giving a version which will
be appended to my jar I'm saying the
Scala version which I'm using which is
2.11.8 and I'm saying spark version
which is
2.2.0 you can replace these with the
version which you intend to use other
than that we are pointing to the
different spark components and the
relevant dependency related jars which
your SBT can get for you so I have given
spark core spark SQL ml Libs spark
streaming and Spark Hive which will be
then fetched from the repository so this
is my build.sb T file which exists in my
project folder we have our code written
we have our build dot SBT file which is
already existing in my project folder my
code is already fine now we need to use
SBT to package my applications into jar
for which you will have to download SBT
so you can just say download SBT windows
and that should take you to the
installing SVT on Windows page now here
you can just download the MSI installer
and run through the installer which will
basically install SBT on your machine
now I have already done that so my build
file is ready my code is ready all I
need to do is now use SBT so what I can
do is from my command line I can just
say CD and I will go into users I'll go
into win10 and I'll go into my workspace
now here here I can see for my projects
and I can go into my spark apps now once
I'm in my project folder we can double
check that it has a build.s BT which is
fine SBT is already installed on this
machine and I can just say SVT if you
would want to check you can always do
SBT version to check if you have SVT and
this command is also done once you
install SBT for the first type you can
always do aspt version and before
displaying it was displaying sbt's
version it will try to fix all your
dependencies it will try to get all the
relevant dependencies so this is just to
check that SBD is installed on my
machine as I said my code is already
ready I have a build.sbd file and I can
just say SBT package which then will
refer to build.sbt will look for your
code in Source main Scala and then if
everything is fine it will will package
it as jar and it will create folders
within your project folder we can click
on this we can try doing a refresh to
see now if you see here the project was
again created a Target folder is created
within scalar 2.11 I will have my jarg
created so we can see that my SBT was
fine it has packaged the code and it has
created a jar file as simple project
2.11 minus 1 which can be used to run on
the cluster or in a local mode let's
check in Eclipse I'll click on this and
I'll just do a refresh and I see my jar
is already existing which basically
means then we can do a spark submit so
this is where we see that I am already
running a spark submit command now this
might show up some error messages but we
can see how we did this so if you see
here once my packaging was son I went
into my spark folder I did a bin slash
spark submit I mentioned my jar file and
then I said my class main dot Scala DOT
first step so this is my app and this is
how I'm using spark submit to submit an
application which is running in local
mode so we can see further if it starts
processing so here it says created local
directory then it starts an Executor on
localhost it goes for execution and then
if we see further we could also see it
will add our jar to the class path and
then finally it should be doing the
execution now if there is any error
message that might be related to your
file not being deleted or if there is
any problem with executor so we can
basically come back and check here if
there was any specific error so it the
error was that it tries to delete a temp
directory but it does not have the
permission so we have not done that but
as per my application it should be
creating a output in this folder as
spark out so let's click on this and see
I'll do a refresh right and if you see a
new spark output has been created so in
previous sessions we have seen how we
can set up spark on Windows or setup our
spark related IDE so that we can run our
applications on Windows now here we have
a quick demo on setting up spark as a
standalone cluster on Ubuntu machines
and then trying out spark way of working
for which we need at least two machines
and here I have Ubuntu machines set up
um1 and um2 just to give insights on how
my machines look so if I look in my Etc
host I have the IP address of multiple
machines so I can ping one machine to
other Machine by just doing a ping um2
and that should work fine similarly I
have also set up SSH access for these
machines both of the machines have hdu
as the user and I can just do a SSH
um2 and that locks me into the second
machine without a password similarly I
can check the same thing from my second
Machine by doing a SSH um1 and that
works fine too so we need two machines
which can ping each other firewall
disabled able to SSH each other so that
we can set up a standalone cluster of
spark how do we do it so first thing is
we will have to download the spark
related tar file now I can just go to
Google and I can type in spark
2.2.1 download now that's what I'm
interested in and this takes you to
spark release 2.2 point 0.1 however here
it shows you the latest release is 2.4
and then
2.4.2 so what we can do is we can go to
archives so I can basically look at
existing versions now here I can click
on download and this shows me a spark
release and also pre-built for Apache
Hadoop now what we can also do is we can
go to release archives for an older
stable version I click on this and here
I have spark 2.2.1 now I can click on
this and we can either install something
which is not already built or we can
download this one which is spark 2.2.1
bin Hadoop 2.6 Point t g z so you click
on this link and then save this file
which I have already done and here if
you see in my machine I have home sdu
downloads which has my different pack
pictures which I have downloaded also if
you notice I have downloaded jdk8 so you
can check on my machines so apart from
machines being able to Ping each other
and being able to do a as my user local
location if you see here this is the
directory which is created but you also
see that there is a spark link which is
pointing to spark now that is because if
you would want to work on a newer
version of spark you could just do the
same thing for newer version and then
make your link pointing to the newer
version of spark how do you create a
link you can just say sudo Ln minus s
you can give your spark directory and
then you can create a link so I've
already created a link and my spark path
will then become this now what do we do
with this once we have done this once we
have created a link we can go into the
bash file of my user and if you
carefully see here I have given my Java
path so that I can execute Java related
commands and I have also added my spark
related path here which says user local
spark so in case you would be changing
your spark version to a latest one you
will not have to change things in your
bash file only thing you will have to do
is unlink the existing spark link and
create a new link to your newer version
so this is done on this machine and now
I can basically be using spark now
before doing that we can go into user
local spark and this has different
directories so if you look in pin these
has a binaries programs like your Pi
spark your spark shell spark SQL and
Spark submit which we will see how we
can use here if you look in s bin it has
other startup scripts to start your
history server or to start your master
or worker processes if you look in conf
this has your config directories now
here by default world you might see
spark minus default dot conf dot
template I have renamed that to dot conf
slaves template has been renamed to
Slaves so let's look into this so I can
go into conf and then I will look in
spark default conf now here based on our
setup now here we intend to set up a
spark Standalone cluster that is without
Hadoop but I would want to have a spark
Standalone distributed cluster so I have
uncommented this property which says
spark dot master and I say spark and I
also mentioned that my masters will run
on this machine which is um1 spark event
log dot enabled is true because we would
want to track the events I have
mentioned a directory so this is a local
directory in user local spark and we
will have to create it it talks about
the default serializer it talks about
the driver memory which was by default 5
gigabyte I have reduced it to 2K
gigabyte based on my machine regulation
you have Java options and then if you
intend to run a history server so that
whenever your spark application is
complete you will have your application
stored in history server I have given
the log directory which is user local
spark and then application history and
this also needs to be created we have
spark history provider for the class
which takes care of History server and
the update interval of looking for your
applications so this is what we have in
our spark default and if you look in
slaves I have given the machines where I
would want my worker processes to run so
that is um1 and um2 now once you have
made your changes in your spark default
conf and slaves file what you can simply
do is SCP assuming that whatever was
done on this machine that is untiring
your spark directory creating a link
updating your bash RC and rename aiming
your config files same steps need to be
done on the second machine and your
second machine would also be prepared to
be used for your spark cluster so once
you have both the machines which can
ping each other which can SSH each other
both of the machines have Java both of
the machines have the same spark version
downloaded and the basic setup done I
can just easily copy the spark related
config from here into my other machine
that is sdu
um2 and then I can give a path which is
user local spark conf and in this way I
don't need to edit my config files again
and similarly I can even copy the slaves
file this is all we need to basically
have our spark Standalone cluster now
since we have updated our bash RC we can
give our spark command from anywhere we
have set up our config files so I can
just do a start minus all dot sh and
that based on my config files based on
the directories which are mentioned it
will start my master process and my
worker process on both the machines so
here we have a spark Standalone cluster
which has two workers and one master now
we can always go to the browser
interface and we can check for the spark
UI which should be available by typing
in HTTP slash slash my master and then
the port is eight zero eight zero so
this shows that I have a spark Master
running I have two worker processes
right now there are no applications
which are running but my spark UI is
already available when we start using
spark either by spark shell or Pi spark
or even spark submit we will see our
applications getting populated here
additionally we can also start the start
history server by just saying start
history server dot sh and that will
start my history server once this is
done we have a history server also
running and we can go back and then we
can again pull out the history server
user interface by giving in the port
which is default one eight zero eight
zero so I have a spark Standalone
cluster with one master two workers and
also a history server which is running
once we have this we can try working
with spark either with spark shell or Pi
spark or if you have packaged your
application as a jar using SBT or Maven
you could also use spark submit
Additionally you could also use spark
SQL so to work with spark I would just
say spark shell on one of my machines
both my machines which have worker
processes running we can start a spark
shell on any of these machines remember
here our spark will rely on the storage
of these machines that is the file
system because it does not have any
Hadoop or distributed file system we
have started are spark shell and that
shows spark context which is available
as SC spark session is available as
spark so to work with spark core and
rdds we would be using spark context and
if you intend to work with spark SQL
that is data frames and data sets you
can be using spark let's try a quick
simple example so I'll say Val X SC dot
text file and now I would want to point
it to a file so I will say the complete
path remember I am giving the spark
command from my home directory so I will
have to say user local spark and then I
can point to a file which is existing
here and this is what I would want to
use to do some processing we are using
the first step here wherein we are using
a method of spark context which will not
relate in any evaluation and it will
just create an rdt now we are using the
scholars way so let's create one more
variable and then we can do some
transformation on it by saying two upper
case I would just want to convert the
content into uppercase and this is again
a transformation so that will just
create an rdt once this is done we can
invoke an action to basically see some
results so I could just simply do a
collect which is an action and this
action will trigger the execution of dag
which starts from the farthest RTD that
is the first step where your file is
loaded into rdd now once we do this we
should be able to see our result and
that basically is execution of DAC so
from the time we have used a text file
which is a method of spark context two
we did a transformation and till we
invoked an action becomes my one job now
if I would do y dot count which is again
a different action this will trigger the
execution of tag right from the
beginning that is SC dot text file where
the data will again be loaded in rdd a
map transformation will happen and then
you will have a count now we can always
see this in the spark UI by just going
in here and just doing a refresh so that
will show me that there is an
application which is running via spark
shell it has utilized three cores it has
utilized memory per executor one
gigabyte and we can click on this
application which shows that it used
both the workers One Core and 1GB on
this worker and two cores and memory on
this worker I can click on application
detail UI wherein I can see what are the
actions I invoked we also see the number
of tasks which are run and that is
because every rdt which is created by
default is having two partitions and for
each partition you will have one task
well we can change the partitions and
many more things can be done but that
you can learn in later sessions here we
have two jobs one ended with collect and
one ended with count now I can click on
collect and I can see the tag
visualization which tells me we started
the text file we did a map and finally
we did a collect it shows that
everything was done in state 0 that is
just one stage I can click on count and
that again shows me the diag
visualization which is a different stage
a different job ID which started with
text file map and then we did account if
you would want to see more details you
can always use these tabs to look at
different stages within your application
if you were doing some caching looking
at environment variables and also to see
how many executors were used including
the one for the driver on which nodes
these executors and how many cores how
many tasks were run was there any
shuffling involved and so on so this is
how I have used spark shell that is an
interactive way of running my
application and since we have a spark UI
we can always look at applications when
they have run and we can always drill
down and no more details now since my
application is completed I can do a
Refresh on History server but that does
not show anything because when we
started a spark shell it started an
application and that application is
still in running status if you see here
under running applications so this is
how we use spark shell on a standalone
spark cluster now we can just do a colon
quit and that takes me out of spark
shell similarly if I would want to work
on Pi spark that is Python's way of
working with spark I can just type in pi
spark which should bring my python shell
and then I can continue working with
spark and again go back and look at my
UI while my Pi spark comes up I can go
here since I quit my spark shell I can
just do a refresh to see if my
application is yet coming up in history
server it might take some time and you
can always go back and look at
incomplete applications or wait till
your application is populated in history
server now if I do a refresh here on
spark UI it says this application was
completed it says finished and then now
we have started by spark so it has
started a new application by spark shell
and that is in running status we can
come back here and now we have our
python switch so I can do the same thing
which I did in Scala using SC dot text
file I will point it to a file which
exists in user local spark
readme.md so that's the file which I'm
interested in now this would have
created an rdt which we can confirm by
just typing in X now I can create a
different variable and I can say I would
want to do a transformation of map now
in case of python when you use anonymous
functions or when you want to apply some
functions to your Transformations you
use Lambda functions so we say Lambda
line and then I would say what I want to
do to the line I will say I will use a
inbuilt uppercase upper function which
should convert my content into uppercase
but as of now this is a transformation
so it only creates an RDP to see the
result I can do a y dot collect and that
should bring up my result now in case if
it says the file does not exist that is
because there was a typo here and we can
repeat this step so let's bring up here
again X and I can give the right name of
the file I can do a transformation and
finally I can see the result so this is
using pi spark on a standalone spark
cluster which is working without Hadoop
which has two worker nodes and one
master node we can always come and do a
refresh here to look at more details so
we have our application we can click on
this again similarly like we did for
Scala application detail UI I see my
application under that column select it
ran two tasks and I can look at my DAC
so this is how we can use spark shell or
Pi spark let's spend some time in
understanding the Sparks architecture
now when you talk about spark
architecture it is based on two
important abstractions you have rdds
which are the building blocks that is
resilient distributed data sets which
are the fundamental units of data which
are lazily in nature or you can say
implicitly lazy in nature and these are
created as I explained earlier whenever
you use a method of smart context or
whenever you do a transformation on an
existing rdd or a data set by default
every rdd has two partitions which can
then be customized while creating rdds
so I could specify if I know that my rdd
would be based on a bigger file I could
break my rdd into several partitions and
how does that help the more number of
partitions you have better will be your
parallel processing so your rdds are
automatically split into partitions and
then these can be executed upon on
different nodes by different tasks in
parallel in memory you have the concept
of dag which I explained earlier that is
directed a cyclic graph so basically
spark has a DAC scheduler in the back
end which is tracking the
Transformations or steps which you have
as a part of your application so dag is
basically a scheduling layer of spark
architecture it implements stage
oriented scheduling and eliminates
hadoops map reduce multi-stage kind of
execution model the summary of this is
that if you are processing data using
spark applications in a spark platform
whether that is Standalone or Hadoop
cluster for every step you do as a part
of your application it creates an rdd
which becomes a part of your deck now
DAC scheduler is already aware of what
are the steps involved in dag and it
comes up with an execution plan to
execute the dag to execute all the steps
within attack if and only if an action
is invoked so Every Spark application
has a driver program now spark also
works in Master Slave architecture it
basically can have a master process and
worker processes running across multiple
machines your spark could be interacting
with the cluster manager such as Apache
mesos or yarn where you would not have
Sparks master or worker processes
running however spark would depend on
the cluster manager the Clusters master
and cluster save for data processing
every application has a driver program
now that's a mandate and every driver
program has the entry point of your
application that is your spark context
so so spark context is the one which
takes your application request to the
cluster manager and then cluster manager
takes it from there so cluster manager
so in case if your spark is working with
yarn in that case cluster manager would
be resource manager which would be
negotiating resources to the node
managers node managers which are running
on the slave machines wherever your data
nodes are running will approve or reject
the resource request from The Source
manager if approved your node managers
would be granting in containers and what
is a container a combination of RAM and
CPU cores so once containers are
allocated by your worker nodes or your
node managers your cluster manager that
is resource manager starts application
master that will run in one of the
containers and use other containers to
run the executed process which will take
care of different tasks on different
partitions within a particular cluster
if we look further this is how it looks
so executor is a jvm process it runs
within the container it is responsible
for execution of tasks or I could say
working upon tasks on a partition of rdd
that exists respectively on that
particular note when we look further in
spark architecture your worker nodes are
the ones which are executing the tasks
assigned by cluster manager and return
the result back to spark context so
always remember your executor which is
responsible for execution of tasks runs
within the container that is within a
specific amount of RAM and CPU core and
we could have any number of executors
running on a particular node in any
number of containers however if a user
runs an application asking for executor
with specific amount of memory specific
amount of CPU cores that is possible
however the request should not seed the
container size finally if we have
understood and learned about your spark
components your spark architecture we
can also see running a spark application
now a spark application can run in a
standalone mode that is you could set up
your IDE such as Eclipse with a Scala
plugin and then you could have your
coded application which is written in
Eclipse to be run in local mode now here
I have an example of application which
can be run in a local mode or on a
cluster so this application is importing
some packages that is spark context
spark conf I have created an object
which is first app it is the main class
of your project and other classes can
just be extending app rather than having
main here we declare a variable called X
which is pointing to a file in my
project directory it looks for a file
which is abc1 dot text and this file
basically has some content what are we
doing in the application so we create a
variable where we assign the file then
we Define or initialize our spark
context so remember whenever you work
with IDE you don't have spark context or
spark available implicitly that has to
be defined so here we create a
configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
Windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark Standalone cluster if I
would be running it on yarn then I would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
rdd that is what is happening in line 13
Val Y and then finally I can create a
variable where I would want to do a flat
map transformation on Y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally Reduce by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done I can decide to
display the result on the screen or I
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
Eclipse refer to other sessions where I
have explained how you can set up Ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
I would want to run this application on
a cluster then I will have to give a
particular path so here in this case I
can say let's do this and I will say my
file is abc1.txt let's save it and I'll
also say my output will be getting
stored in a default location as I intend
to run it I intend to run this
application on a cluster now in that
case the cluster would usually be set up
on Linux machines would have a Hadoop
cluster where you can run this
application so if I would want to run
this application on a cluster but not
locally on the machine I can just delete
this part I can keep my application now
if you see my application already
compiles and does not show any error
message and that is because in my
Project's build path I have added all
the spark related jars all the spark
related jars you can get from your spark
directory or you can be getting in
manually all the dependencies some
people would prefer to use Maven or say
SBT for packaging your application as
jar and that can also be done so here my
code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what I can do is since I have
my code already written I know that I
have SBT install installed on this
machine because I would want to package
this code AS jar and run it on a cluster
so for that we can look in our Command
Prompt and here I can go into workspace
I can go into myscala project and if you
see here we have your build dot SBT file
you have your binaries and you have your
source so you might not have these spark
related directories now these exist in
my case because I have been using spark
and I've done some previous runs now
this is what we have within my spark
apps so to build my package I need a
build dot SBT file we can see what does
that contain so your build.sbt contains
your name version of your package or
Scala version spark version and then
repository which spark will refer to
when it wants to have the dependencies
for all of your components such as bar
core spark SQL ml lab and so on so this
is my build.spd file which exists in the
project folder and if you are intending
to use SBT to package your code AS jar
and then run it on the cluster in that
case I can even skip adding spark
related charge to the build path so that
is only done to make sure that your code
compiles now once I have my code written
I have SBT installed I have made the
file path changes I can just go to the
command line within my project folder
and I can say SBT package now this will
basically resolve all the dependencies
based on whatever you have given in the
code it will create a jar file and place
it in a particular location and then we
can use the same jar file to run on a
particular cluster so SVD package is
busy in creating the jar now meanwhile
what I can do is I can open up a lab
content and what I can do is is I can
just say for example simply learn and
here I already have a lab set up so you
could have your own spark Standalone
cluster where you could also run this
jar file you could have spark with
Hadoop which is what I have here and I
will use that to submit an application
on the yarn cluster and let's go to the
web console let me copy my link I'll
close this I'll say launch lab and then
I can log in here I can just do paste my
password and I'm logged in so I can just
say spark to Shell now that's how it has
been configured here to work with your
spark version 2. so this is an
interactive way of bringing you your
spark shell and running your application
but what we are interested in is running
the application as a jar file so let's
go and see here where we have our code
and let's see if SBT has done the
packaging yes it has done and it has
created a jar file file in this location
so what I can do is I need to get this
jar file from this location onto my
cluster so what I can do is I can come
in here I can do a FTP so this basically
allows me to push whatever jars I have
on my web console so I'll go in here
I'll say connect now I'll search if
there is already existing jar file which
might create a conflict so I have
something here so I can for now just
delete it it's done I will say upload
file and I am interested in getting the
jar file so here we can click on users
win 10 I have my workspace project I can
get into Target Scala 2.11 and take my
jar file and say open so this will
upload my jar file on the web console or
The Terminal wherein I can connect to my
cluster now let's go in here let's quit
from spark shell as we want to run an
application on the cluster how do I do
it so I can search if I have my jar file
existing it's here so I'll say spark to
submit and then I will point to my jar
file and then I can simply say class and
I know my code has a package and a class
name so this is package and this is my
object or class name so I can say main
dot Scala DOT first app now it will be
good if we check if the file exists
which are code points to so I'll just
for now comment it out I will check in
my sdfs LS in my default user directory
this is where it will search for a file
and here we can search if I have a file
called ABC so I don't don't see anything
here so let's do this what I can do is I
can again go to FTP and basically I can
do a upload file like what we did
earlier and this time I'll pick up this
existing ABC one file which I showed you
and upload it once this is done I can
put it on my cluster by just saying hdfs
DFS put let's take the abc1 file and
let's put it in my directory so this
will be my input so I'm putting in a
file there and now I can do a spark
submit to submit the application on the
cluster so if you see here it has
basically started the application it
contacts the resource manager it gets an
application ID and now it is doing the
processing of my file where I would want
to get once this is done it will be
completed and the temporary directory
will be deleted so this is how I run is
spark application on a cluster now once
this is done I can also go to Sparks
history server by saying this is the
path for my spark history server it
shows an application which was run today
which was doing a word count you can
click on the application it says it
ended with save as text file you can
click on this and then it shows you the
dag visualization it says we started
with text file we did a flat map we did
a map and then there was some shuffling
because we wanted to do Reduce by key so
as I said every rdd by default has two
partitions and if you want to do some
aggregate or wider Transformations like
Reduce by key sort by key Group by key
count by key and so on in that case
similar key related data has to be
shuffled and brought into one partition
that's where we see shuffling happening
here and it also tells what are the
number of tasks which I have run per
partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your SBT so SBT created the jar file and
then basically we brought our jar file
onto the cluster and then submitted it
using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as I said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes and they can
run on a cluster across the nodes so we
just saw how we can run a spark
application on a cluster now we can
always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark UI your spark
application as I mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the cluster you can
always specify where would you want your
driver program to run so in our case
when we and our spark application here
we basically just did a simple spark
submit and we gave our jar and the class
name I could also say master and then I
could specify if I would want my
application to run in a local mode or I
could say yarn but that is default or if
it was a spark Standalone cluster then I
could be giving something like this your
host name and then your Port so you
could do all of these options by
specifying minus minus master I could
also specify how many executors I need
how much memory per executor how much
cores per executor I need and I could
also say deploy mode as client which
basically means my driver will run on
this machine however my execution of
application will happen on cluster nodes
I can also say deploy mode as cluster
which basically means my driver will run
on one of the nodes of the cluster you
could submit your application and then
based on whatever arguments you have
given your application will be submitted
on the cluster and it will run so you
can have your application running so as
I said you have an application which has
a driver and it also has either spark
session or spark context which takes
your application request to the resource
manager now if your application is
completed you can always come back and
look into the spark history server or
spark UI if I choose this as my
application which I have run I can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was one for your driver now that was
running on this particular node which is
my client node then I have my executors
on my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
word count which uses Reduce by key so
when you run your application education
your yarn or your cluster manager such
as resource manager negotiates the
resources to the slave processes your
worker node basically will have the
resources available for any kind of
execution now as I said your resource
manager will request for containers your
worker nodes will approve those
containers and then within those
containers you will have the executor
which will run which will take care of
the task to process the data so what is
a task it is a unit of work for the data
set which has to be worked upon so your
rdds which get created have partitions
and for every partition you have a task
which is taken care by the executor so
the data is loaded into the rdd when the
action is invoked and then your task is
worked upon by the executor so what does
it do it basically gets the data into
the partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application run whenever you run a
particular application you can always go
to your web console and scroll or look
into the logs for more information so
here our application was run and we can
see right from the beginning here when
we talk about spark submit which is done
here it says running spark question 2.2
it basically then will see that there
will be a driver which will be started
you can further see that it does some
memory calculations it then starts as
spark UI and here we can see that
requesting a new application from
cluster with four node managers verify
our application has not requested more
than maximum memory capability of the
cluster so the container sizing at the
cluster level is 3 GB per container and
your application should not be
requesting for a container bigger than
that it starts a application Master
container with specific amount of memory
and then finally your execution starts
if we scroll down and look into the logs
we will see where my driver runs it will
also see show you how much memory was
utilized and it will talk about tax
scheduler which is taking care of
execution of your tag that is series of
your rdds and finally you will see the
result getting generated or saved so
this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark UI and this is how overall Apache
spark Works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those so when you
look at spark and we have learned about
these different components so there is
you can find lot of use cases by just
going to Google and typing in companies
using spark now here there is one of the
case studies so open table now that's an
online restaurant reservation service
which is based in San Francisco
California and their service covers more
than 30 000 restaurants in U.S and they
have expanded to different countries now
what OpenTable had was that they were
facing issues while giving restaurant
recommendations to the customers and in
turn also analyzing the customer reviews
they started using spark basically to
tackle the challenges or problems they
had so Open Table uses Spark for
training its recommendation algorithms
so the algorithms which would be
basically recommending restaurants and
the services to different customers and
for that Open Table uses Spark now they
could then suggest restaurants to book
Open Table also use a spark for natural
language processing of restaurant
reviews which can then give new topic
models so with all this open table has
achieved 10 times speed enhancement it
has helped them by reducing the runtime
of their machine learning algorithms
from few weeks to just a few hours and
that has obviously increased their
productivity so these are your different
components you can look into the demos
where we talk about spark ml lib using
Scala or spark mlib using python you can
explore more on these different
components such as spark mlib spark
streaming spark SQL and data frames and
also your core API or the basic building
block of spark that is rdb in the last
video we learned about the equation of
line and how it can be represented on a
graph we also learned on using Scala and
ml basically to work on a linear
regression problem and here I will give
a quick demo on solving the similar
problem or in fact the same problem
using pi spark now here I have two
machines running so these are my
machines where I have a spark Standalone
cluster and if you have a look at this I
am also running a Hadoop cluster
although I intend to just use spark here
so I have a spark master and Spark
worker running on this machine and if I
go on to my second machine I have a
spark worker on this so I have a two
node spark Standalone cluster which can
be used to test our functionality of Pi
spark now we all know that we can always
look into the spark directory and look
in the bin which basically has the
binaries now last time we were using
spark shell to basically run Spark and
also try out ml or also your ml lib
which are your basically the components
or packages to work on machine learning
problems now here we have Pi spark and
we can be using this so let me just go
back here and we can bring a pi spark
now normally when you are trying to use
spice park it would be using python
which is installed on your machine and
if you check here on my machine it shows
python 3.5.2 Now by default it would be
Python 2.7 and you can do some steps so
that you can set your python to 3.5 then
you can install some modules which would
be useful when you are working on a
machine learning problem so let me just
show you what steps you need to do here
and what you can do is on all your
worker nodes you can just repeat these
steps basically first you can check like
what version of python you have now in
my case I had in my user bin I had 2.7
3.5 and so on although my python was set
to 2.7 so what I did was I did update
Alternatives and update alternatives to
set my python is 3.5 I checked my python
version if it was pointing 3.5 then I
did a APT get removed python pip if it
was installed earlier I then installed
Python 3 pip which would then be used to
install say packages numpy which we
would be using when we are working on
machine learning libraries now once this
is done on both your nodes you can check
if both your nodes have python 3.5.2 if
you have a spark Standalone cluster then
repeat this on all the worker nodes if
you intend to use spark with yarn then
make sure that on every node where you
would want your spark application to run
make sure that python is upgraded to say
the latest version in my case I'm using
3.5 and then install your python pip and
then you can import modules such as
numpy now once all these steps are done
I can basically also show you what's in
my bash RC here and this shows that I
have set my spark path to user locals
part now that's where I have installed
spark and I've also pointed it to the
binaries so technically speaking I can
give my python commands from anywhere
now here I'll just do a pi spark now
that should basically connect to spark
and this is where we will be using pi
spark to work on a linear regression
problem now in my previous video I
explained how you express equation of a
line what do you mean by linear
regression what does it mean when you
want to plot a regression line that is
basically looking into your dependent
and independent variables and trying to
get get a regression line that is doing
a regression analysis finding out your
residuals the points which do not lie on
your regression line also looking and
finding out your intercepts that is the
points which lie on the graph or on the
line or you could say x or y axis and
then also your gradients now how do we
solve a similar problem using pi spark
now obviously we will have to import
some packages for that so first thing
what we will do is we will import from
your Pi spark dot ml dot regression I
would import linear regression now we
know that spark has different components
and it also has support of these
libraries for ML so machine learning
algorithms and these algorithms are
already there we just need to use them
so import this package now once that is
done then we can work on a data set now
in my case I am going to use the same
data set which we used when we use Scala
that's also updated in the GitHub link
which I will show you towards the end of
this demo now here if I look in Sample
files I have various files and I would
be interested in working on this
e-commerce customers dot CSV and we can
have a look at this one so I could
basically look into this data set this
is a CSV data set which has various
Fields such as email address after and
we have seen the same data set when we
solve linear regression problem where we
use the same data set but we did use
spark shell nvs we use color programming
now here we intend to use Pi spark and
python so we have certain columns or
certain Fields here such as every
session length time on app time on
website length of membership and these
could be considered as the features
which we would be interested in and then
you have one more field called yearly
amount spend which we would then be
using as a label so this is the data set
which I would be working on and this is
in a particular folder so what I would
do is I would want to create say a data
frame out of this data set and let's do
that so first thing is I will use this
wherein I am creating a variable called
data set and then I am going to read in
this CSV file so let's go back to my Pi
spark so I'm saying data set now we
already know that similar way we do it
in Scala so here in pi spark we do a
spark.read.csv we could have also done
read.format specified a format as CSV
but here I'm straight away using this
file now remember if you are using a
spark Standalone cluster then you would
need the file to be existing on all your
worker nodes in my case I have taken
care of python being upgraded the module
such as numpy being downloaded and also
this file exist on all the worker nodes
I am also doing a infer schema to
basically understand the schema of the
file and I'm using header as true which
basically means the first row of the
file would be considered as header now
let's go ahead and do this and that
creates my data set which we can always
do a show and look into what does my
data set have now once this is done
using your Pi spark we can always do a
dataset DOT show remember it shows you
only 20 rows but then we will get an
idea what we have in our data set so you
see all my CSV Fields have now been
converted into a row in a column format
that is data frame which has email
address after and as I explained earlier
these fields do not have an impact on
the yearly amount spent however you have
other fields which we are interested in
and that are average session length time
on app time on website length of
membership now this is my data set
already created with the respective
fields which we would want to use to
solve a linear regression problem here
as I said we would be interested in
finding out the relation between
independent and dependent variables we
would look at the data and as I said
your yearly amount spent field can be
considered as label and we already know
that for supervised learning your labels
play an important role now let's go
further and what we will do is we'll
import two other packages here one is
vectors and one is Vector assembler now
we know that when you want to work on a
machine learning problem you would have
to use some feature extractors like
vector assembler and also convert your
data in the form of vectors let's copy
this and basically import vectors and
also import Vector assembler now
whenever you're working on a machine
learning problem we would be using
different kind of feature extractors now
to look into more detail about Vector
assembler you can go into spark
documentation and you can click on
classification and regression you can
then be looking into some examples of
linear regression what you could also be
doing is you could be searching for say
feature extractor for example we could
go here extracting transforming and then
here you can search for Vector assembler
which is over here and that basically
gives you an explanation if you would
want to learn more about it I explained
this in the previous session so Vector
assembler is a Transformer that combines
a list of columns as I said some of our
columns are the features into a single
Vector column and it is basically used
for combining raw features and features
generated by different feature
Transformers into a single feature
vector and machine learning would expect
the data to be in the form of vector so
that we we can then train our machine
learning models such as say logistic
regression decision trees and so on now
you could read more about this Vector
assembler and other similar feature
extractors here let's go back to my
terminal and what I would do is I have
already imported the packages now what
we can do is once this is done we will
create a variable called feature
assembler and here I would be using
Vector assembler which would then
consider these columns which I mentioned
as features and I would mention them as
the input columns and the output column
could be called as output features so
basically my Vector assembler would
combine all these features as one column
with comma separated values so let's do
that now once this is done we have our
feature assembler and at any point of
time you can then do a transform or you
can basically save this in a variable so
let's consider this output equals
feature assembler which we just created
and we will transform our data set based
on this and then we will have a look at
our output variable so let's do this and
then I can do a show which should then
show me that I have input independent
features now I have all the fields as we
saw in our earlier data frame but then
apart from my yearly amount spent I also
have independent features which is
basically a consolidation of values from
these four fields or four fields which
have our features now once that is done
we can then basically create a new
variable where we would want to just
select the independent features and the
yearly amounts spent so these are the
two variables in which we would want to
see the relation so let's do this and I
have created a finalized data which is
output dot select and here I have just
consider are these two columns that is
yearly amount spent and independent
features which is nothing but a vector
of all the features now once this is
done we can always do a finalized data
which we have created dot so let's do
this which shows me my finalized data
which has only these two columns so
independent features is basically the
set of features which have a label or a
response which is yearly amount spent
which can also be used to train our data
set or train our model and also then
test it against a model for making some
predictions once this is done let's do
this where I will say train data comma
test data where I would want to split my
data into training and test data set so
that training Getters can be used to
train your model and then test data can
be used to validate or evaluate its
efficiency so let's take this train
underscore data test underscore data I
would work on finalized data I would do
a random split into 75 25 so let's take
this one and here we have done this now
what we can do is then we can use our
linear regression algorithm so I'm
creating a variable called regressor I
will do a linear regression now that
needs the features column which is our
independent features and then the label
column which is yearly amount spent
let's take this and then let's create
this variable called regressor now once
this is done we can then do a fit method
on our training data which we have
created in the previous step so let's
take this where we will use the fit
method and once that is done we can then
find out our coefficients our intercepts
and also do some predictions so let's
work on this and I will say regressor
dot coefficients which would show me set
of coefficients here so this is my
coefficients I can also get intercepts
which is basically the points which lie
on the x or y axis and that gives me an
intercept and then I can also get the
predictions so for predictions what I
can do is I can basically create a
variable called red results and then I
can get my predictions out of it here I
am using a evaluate method on my test
data set so I would do a bread
underscore results and then I use my
regressor which we created here and then
what we could do is we could just say
regressor dot evaluate test data and
once this is done then we can pull out
our predictions so what we can do is we
can go in here and we get changes to a
spread results predictions dot show so
this gives me the prediction and if you
look at the values these are pretty much
close when you compare your Ela amount
spent and the predictions what we have
made based on the features now we can
always look at more values by just
adding in a value here and we can see
how close have we got with our
prediction in comparison to the labels
which we used so we use the training
data and then we evaluated or we use the
evaluate method to find out the
prediction when we were working on our
test data set this is a simple example
of linear regression where we have used
Pi spark and then either we have listed
down our predictions or we have looked
at the coefficients we have looked at
the intercept and we have worked on a
comma separated value or comma separated
file which has set of features a column
which explains the response or labels
and then we have been able to do the
predictions on this this is a simple
example of linear regression using pi
spark for more details you can always
look at the Sparks website and basically
you can find out some more interesting
examples when it comes to your linear
regression or any other problems which
you would want to solve and welcome to
this quick tutorial on using pi spark to
work on a regression problem now in my
previous videos you might have seen how
we used Scala programming and we used
spark shell to basically work on a
regression problem such as linear
regression and logistic regression and
if you look at the previous video I have
also explained how logistic regression
Works how you work on a sigmoid function
or basically if you have your data
points which would then relate to your S
curve using a threshold How would you do
your predictions now here I have a data
set in Sample files and that's called
credit card so let's look into this and
this is the data set which I would be
using for the logistic regression
problem now basically if we look into
this data set this basically has
information it has different fields so
there are 28 fields that is what V1 to
V28 there is a Time column there is also
amount and class and we would be using
this data set to solve a logistic
regression problem now when we talk
about logistic regression we know that
we would be interested in binary
classification which is basically
resulting in yes or no or a binary value
which is as one or zero now how do we
work on this using pi spark which is
also available so on my machine I
already have a spark Standalone cluster
running which has one master and two
worker processes now we have used the
same spark Standalone cluster to work on
our linear regression problem or
logistic regression problem using spark
shell I have also shown how you can be
using pi spark to solve a linear
regression and here I would give you a
quick demo on using logistic regression
or using your Pi spark to solve a
logistic regression problem now for that
as I mentioned earlier you will have to
make sure that your environment is set
up correctly that is basically repeating
all the steps if you have not done which
are shown here basically to make sure
that you have your python set up
correctly then you will have to install
the python modules now if you would be
working on a linear regression you could
be installing numpy and similarly if you
intend to work on say a logistic
regression problem also you could use
pandas which could then be used to
visualize the data if if you would be
wanting to visualize the data and
understand more about it now let's go
ahead now on this machine and the other
machine I have already done installed
pandas and also installed Pi spark SQL
now you can also have a look at this
link which talks about Arrow now that
could be used when you're working with
pandas and if you would want to
transform your data frame or a spark
data frame into a python data frame for
further analysis or further
visualization so the first thing what we
need to do is we need to basically start
our PI spark so what I would do here is
I will just go for pi spark now my spark
Standalone cluster is running and Pi
spark is basically the Python's way of
working with spark so we will still have
to load the data in memory so that we
can create a spark data frame out of it
and for that this is the first step
where I am doing a read.csv now I
already showed you a credit card CSV
file which has basically transactions
and so on although this is an anonymous
anonymous file and it does not have
relevance to any real data but then this
data is what I would be considering so
let's take this one and go ahead and
create a data frame to begin with now
once the data frame is created you can
do a print schema you can look into the
data to see what your data frame
contains and once this is done you can
always look into your data frame
remember if you are using a spark
Standalone cluster all the python
related installation has to be done on
all the nodes your data set has to be
existing on all the worker nodes now
here we can do a DF dot show to see what
our data frame contains we can also do a
DF dot print schema and basically look
at the schema which shows me the
different columns which are available in
this particular data set now what do we
need to do once this is done and we have
already created a distributed data frame
by loading the data set and we have used
Pi spark for it and what are we
interested in we are interested in
finding out or classifying the
transactions as fraud or not fraud so
basically we are looking for result in
form of binary that is yes or no now we
have these columns as I showed you here
V1 to V28 and these columns are
transformed features which are extracted
from the main data set so here data is
anonymous and it does not have relevance
to actual or real data now what do we do
we can always look at the length of the
columns in my data frame so I could do
this and we can see that there are
totally 31 columns in our data frames
now this is just a list comprehension
instead of writing all the 28 columns so
we could do this and we could be looking
at some of the columns and we could just
do this is to have a quick overview of
what our data or what are columns
containing the feature have now as I
said you could be optionally using
pandas that is if you have installed
pandas you could be converting your data
frame into a panda data frame you could
then visualize all your columns how they
are waiting across rows and for which we
can use matplotlib however that is not
within the scope of this session but you
can have a look I have given you the
code wherein you can use you can import
matplotlib and then you could be using
matplotlib to visualize the data in
these different columns just to get an
idea of what are the spikes what are the
different variations of transactions and
if we see some kind of pattern now
coming to specifically logistic
regression we will have to import
specific packages like what we did in
spark shell in the same way we will have
to import these packages over here so
let's get these packages let's copy this
and let's have all these packages
imported so which we will need for our
logistic regression code and to solve
basically the problem using logistic
regression so let's get these packages I
have already documented it here so that
I avoid typing while I'm giving a demo
and just import all the relevant
packages such as binary classification
evaluator logistic regression your
pipeline you have your tokenizer or
hashing TF you have your parameter grid
Builder and also cross validator which
we will be using for our use case here
so let's import these packages to begin
with and once this is done then we can
look at the columns in the data frame we
would not be interested in the The First
Column which talks about time we would
not be interested in the last column so
we would just be importing all these
packages and then you can just do a
slicing using your DF dot columns and
that shows you your columns from V1 to
V28 and then we would also be interested
in the amount column so classification
is something we are interested in so
class is what we have left we have left
out the time which is the first column
so we are looking at these columns now
what do we need to do further so if as I
mentioned if you would be using pandas
you could be doing visualization we
could have a visualization technique and
we would have noticed some kind of
patterns or spikes and for that I would
suggest if you are using something like
a notebook which is integrated with
spark it will be really useful or you
can have different ways wherein you can
use matplotlib and do the visualizations
of and of your variations now we could
use Roc curve instead of accuracy Matrix
which to basically help us in
determining and classifying a
transaction as fraud or not what we
would be doing is we would be just using
the column one onwards till the amount
only and then I would be interested in
casting each column into float so for
that you can basically get this Pi spark
SQL function and let's import this now
once this is done then we can basically
have a function where for the column
names in your data frame we would be
using a with column method and we would
like to cast it into float so this will
be useful for our further processing of
the data so let's take this for column
and basically do this and then you have
to use the python so you have to go for
indentation and let's get this one here
and once this is done so you would have
casted your columns as float now once
that is done then we would be interested
in renaming our columns as labels or the
class so we basically need to get the
features and also the label which is
used in supervised learning so let's
take this and let's have the columns
renamed now once that is done you can
always look at the columns how does it
look like so we have these columns which
we are working on and now I would be
using Vector assembler now I have
explained this earlier so Vector
assembler is for extracting your
features and what we would do is we
would create a variable called Vector
assembler here my input columns will be
all the feature columns and they can be
grouped together by calling in one
column which is features so this is what
I want to achieve using Vector assembler
now you know for your machine learning
it would always like the data in the
form of a vector or a single Vector of
features and vectors also a list right
where your data is vertically arranged
now once we have used Vector assembler
we can then do a transfer form on our
data frame using your vector assembler
which we have created in the previous
step now once the transformation is done
then you could be just selecting the two
columns one is the features which is
nothing but a consolidation of all your
28 columns and your label which is
nothing but the response now once that
is done we can again look at what does
our select show by doing this it's a
simple way of just looking what you have
been doing might be look at particular
fields and see what it shows up now once
this is done then comes using our
logistic regression where we will
specify how many number of iterations
what is the feature column what is the
label column so let's create a variable
called LR and I'm using the logistic
regression here the algorithm which is
already inbuilt with spark comes up with
now once this is done we can then create
a model by using the fit method on our
transformed data frame so let's take
this and we create a model by doing a
fit method which basically has to work
on our transformed data set which we
have created here now once this is done
then we can proceed so what we would
want to do is we could be doing this
where we are creating a model we can
print the model summary and we could
look into area under curve right now
that is one option or one way of doing
things but what we would be doing is
instead of going for this one we would
be using a cross validator right now
cross validator comes within your tuning
so you can always look into this this
link which talks about ml tuning and
here it talks about uh how to use ml
Libs tooling for tuning your ml
algorithms and pipelines so using a
built-in cross-validation and other
tooling allows us to optimize hyper
parameters right so one of the important
tasks in machine learning is model
selection or using data to find the best
model or parameters for a given task and
this is what we mean by tuning so that
could be done for individual that is
estimators using logistic regression or
an entire pipeline which includes
multiple algorithms so you could read
more about cross-validator how it works
what is cross-validation wherein you
split the data into a set of folds which
are used as separate training and test
data sets now this is what we have seen
even in linear regression so you could
be using cross validator which could be
generating your training and test data
set which could then be used to test the
accuracy of our problem solving or our
model right so read about more about
cross validation on this particular link
now coming back here what I would be
interested is rather than creating a
model using fit method and then looking
area under curve as I said I would be
interested in going for cross validation
so cross validation is usually good as
we can have values fit on the complete
data thus we can test how our evaluation
metrics is working on complete data set
and how good are parameters for the
model now in this case we need certain
things we need an intercept so that we
can fit into set for logistic or no you
need elastic net parameter and that is
basically your regularization of
parameters used in ml so that your one
of the parameters does not dominate over
other parameters or you don't have any
kind of overfitting now how do we do
that so for that we will use a parameter
grid Builder and I am saying add grid
now here I am giving regularization
parameters I am then doing a fit
intercept which is being provided with
both values that is true or false and
also your net parameters so let's take
this and let's go ahead and take it to
the next level now once this is done we
basically have to use the cross
validator so in this cross validator we
would be specifying an estimator what we
would want to use so that's our logistic
regression we are giving the parameter
map which is param grid we built in the
previous step and we are using a binary
classification evaluator we can also
specify how many number of folds we have
here so once this is done you are
basically creating a variable which is
using cross validator now once that is
done then we can basically use cross
validator to fit or use the fit method
on our transformed data frame and we can
create a model out of it so wait for
your model to be created and then to
check your accuracy Matrix we can simply
do an average Matrix so this is a simple
example of using logistic regression to
solve a problem and to look into your
data to classify it in the form of
binary is that is yes or no and we are
using pi spark to work on our problem
similarly you can also look at the
previous videos where we have done a
logistic regression using spark shell
and we have used basically a spark shell
and Scala to solve a business use case
so let's just give it some time where it
is creating this model now that might
depend on your system performance and
you can always look at the result of
this remember your spark mlib has
different algorithms already inbuilt to
solve your different data science kind
of problems or basically using your
different techniques to solve your
different problems so once this is done
let's come back here and so it is just
trying to use the cross validator on our
transformed data set once this is done
the last step would be to look into your
average metrics this is done and you can
always do average metrics to see your
metrics and to check your accuracy on
your problem now as I explained earlier
when you have your spark running you can
always go to the UI to see more
information and here I can go into this
particular link which shows me the
application which was running it's a pi
spark shell you can look in an
application detail UI which will give
you the dag it will tell you what kind
of Transformations happened and
basically you can click on any one of
these to see what it does you can always
look at how many tasks were run what
kind of internal steps were being done
in basically processing this particular
data set you can also look at the
executors you can look at other
information if there was something which
was cast so we see there was something
cached in memory in a deserialized
format and that was probably being used
for your further processing steps so
this is a simple example of using your
Pi spark to you use or to work on a
logistic regression problem work on your
data set to classify it with binary
values here we will learn on what is
spark streaming spark streaming data
sources features of spark streaming
working of spark streaming this
criticized streams caching or
persistence as we call checkpointing in
spark streaming and we will then have a
demo on spark streaming so let's learn
on what is spark streaming and what it
is capable of so it's an extension of
core spark API that basically enables
scalable High throughput fault tolerant
stream processing of live data streams
now data can be ingested from different
sources like Kafka Flume kindnesses or
TCP sockets and then it can be processed
using complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window low and when we
have the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if we
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
the streaming data is broken down into
smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
Kafka or Flume or say Twitter API or
also with different formats such as
parquet you could also have static data
sources coming in from mongodb hbase
MySQL and postgres so when we talk about
spark streaming it receives the input
data streams divides the data into
batches which can then be processed by
Spark engine to generate your final
stream of results again in batches so
your spark streaming actually provides a
high level abstraction called
discreticized stream and we will learn
about that or what we call as dstream
which represents a continuous stream of
data now when we look at your different
data sources from where the data can
come in spark streaming would take in
this input and then you could have even
your mlib component which could be used
that is Sparks component to build
machine learning algorithms wherein you
can train your models with live data and
you can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structurized and that could be done
by using Sparks components that is spark
SQL which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with SQL when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file system
such as sdfs or any other nosql or SQL
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with Advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
using spark streaming let's learn about
working of spark streaming so as I
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or perceived by your
receipt receivers which we have to
enable in our application your data
streams or streaming data which is
constantly getting generated and flowing
in is broken down into smaller batches
which will then be processed by spark so
you would have your final processed
results now if we look at the bigger
picture here we will talk about live
input data streams that could be divided
into smaller batches and when we say
batches these are batches of input data
as rdps so spark streaming performs
computation expressed using these
streams it generates rdd Transformations
so you would have your spark pad jobs to
execute rdd Transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we look
at examples later so once your spark
streaming works on Breaking the input
into smaller streams it can then process
the data finally giving you batches of
your result and that is again on the
streaming data now what is these these
streams let's understand about these
streams or discretized streams so that's
the basic abstraction provided by spark
streaming now it represents a continuous
stream of data either the input data
stream received from The Source or the
process data stream generated by
transforming the input stream now here
if we look at the dstream we would say
you would have series of rdds or series
of Transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the Transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time one to two and so on so that's how
your spark streaming works so if we look
at your different Transformations now
there could be various Transformations
which could be applied on your data so
this is something like your streaming
data which comes in you would want to
say have a receiver which monitors a
particular socket or a particular port
and looks for data coming in we would
also Define the time interval and for
that time interval the data is taken so
that's a smaller batch or a d stream on
which you could have your processing
done now within your application you
would have series of steps which are
nothing but Transformations which would
be performed on this data within this
time frame giving you a result which
could be stored which could be seen on
your console or which could just be
pushed further for processing and this
keeps happening at regular type
intervals whatever you have specified
till the spark streaming application
continues now when we talk about spark
we already know that there are different
kind of Transformations which can be
applied so you have map transformation
wherein you have map and then you pass
in a function which basically says you
would want to perform a function on
every element so when we say map
function that would return a new D
stream by passing each element of the
source D stream through a function which
is passed similarly it is for flat map
where you would be passing in a function
you would want to perform a flat map
transformation on the data stream or D
stream which comes in so each input item
can be mapped to zero or more output
elements you could be doing a filter
wherein you return a d stream by
selecting only the records of the source
D stream on which the function returns
true so filtering is used when you want
to run a transformation where you would
want to look at the input data for a
particular time interval as I mentioned
earlier and you would want to filter
that data as per whatever your function
is applied now you could be doing a
union where you could basically be
having a union of multiple D streams so
that this would return a new D stream
that contains Union of elements in the
source restraint and a other D string
you could be doing a transform function
that contains the union of elements you
could be doing a count you could be
doing a join so these are some of the
Transformations which can be performed
on your D streams now there is also a
concept of windowing and that is
basically to process the data for a
series of time intervals so when I
mention windowed stream processing I'm
saying spark streaming would allow you
to apply Transformations over a sliding
window of data now this operation is
called as windowed computation let's see
how it looks like so if you have your
original D stream which is p which is
basically your data coming in now that
would be looked upon for specific time
intervals such as time 1 time 2 and then
you could be doing a windowed
computation which could basically mean
that I could have a window which is a
series of these time intervals on which
you would want to perform series of your
rdd Transformations so you have a window
dstream at time one then at time 2 and
time three so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time 3 Time 4 and time 5
where you could be performing the series
of Transformations so this is usually
helpful where you would not only want to
process the data at particular type
interval but you would want a
Consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching in persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying Transformations
over as sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source D stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slides by two time units this shows that
any window operation needs to specify
two parameters one is the window length
which is basically the duration of
window so for example we can say 3 as we
see in the figure here and then you have
a sliding interval which is basically
the interval at which window operation
is performed so these two parameters
must be multiples of the batch interval
of source D stream so that's what we do
when we talk about window now there are
various other Transformations which can
be applied or window based operations
which can be done on your D streams here
to talk a little bit more on these
streams which is as I said it's a basic
abstraction provided by spark streaming
it represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from Source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
string so a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rtds which is Sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a dstream it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the lines now D stream to
generate the rdds of your words T Stream
So when we talk about your discreticized
streams understand that you would have a
series of Transformations which would be
applied for this time interval whatever
has been specified now when you talk
about your streaming or spark streaming
architecture as I mentioned here that is
your receivers now that plays a very
important role here so your input D
streams or data streams are representing
the stream of input data that is
received from your streaming sources now
we could have different kind of data and
we could be doing different kind of
Transformations so your receiver is
basically an object which receives the
data from a source and stores it in
Spark's memory for processing and that's
the main role of your receiver now spark
streaming provides two categories of
building streaming sources so you have
basic sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your Kafka
Flume kindnesses Etc and they would be
available to to extra utility classes so
your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the
spark core engine or as you should know
that rdds are say your logical steps or
rdds are created when you perform some
Transformations and these
Transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rtts or the
rdds which are result of some performing
some Transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your your caching
in persistence these streams also allows
developers to purchase the stream data
in memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
purchase the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a d stream which
will automatically persist every rdd of
that dstream in memory it could be every
rdd or it could be specifically chosen
rdds now this is really useful if the
data in dstream has to be or would be
computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like Reduce by
window Reduce by key and window wherein
you have group of operations being done
or you could have state based operations
like update state by key now in any of
these cases your D streams generated by
say window based operations are
automatically persisted in memory
without the developer calling for the
persist method now for input streams
that receive data over networks such as
Kafka Flume sockets Etc the default
persistence level is set to replicate
the data to two nodes for fault
tolerance now one thing which we should
remember is unlike your rdds the default
persistence level of D streams keeps the
data data serialized in memory and that
we can discuss again further about your
serializations or deserialization now
one important aspect which takes care of
your fault recovery is checkpointing
mechanism in spark streaming now when I
say checkpointing a streaming
application as in real scenario we would
want must operate 24 bar 7 and if the
streaming application is constantly
running then there has to be a mechanism
which can make your streaming
application resilient to failures which
can be unrelated to your application
logic so spawn streaming needs to do the
checkpointing it needs to checkpoint
enough information to a fault tolerant
underlying storage system such that it
can recover from failures so your
checkpointing is the process to make
streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
checkpointing to ensure your streaming
application is more fault tolerant you
have two kinds of checkpointing here so
you could have a metadata checkpointing
and you could have data checkpointing
now when we talk about metadata what
does that include so metadata data
includes configuration these stream
operations or even incomplete batches so
when we talk about metadata it has
configuration so configuration that was
used to create the streaming application
you could have t-stream operations that
is set of dstream operations that Define
the streaming application that is your
series of rtds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches whose jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be checkpointed so
metadata checkpointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete patches and D
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data checkpointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like sdfs now
that is used in stateful Transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about Transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rtds can be
periodically checkpointed and that could
be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata checkpointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or rdd
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
Transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
Transformations here so when we talk
about checkpointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful Transformations
where one series of rdds depend on the
result of your previous matches so
something like update state by key or
Reduce by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpointing when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful Transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because you are one batch
of rdds really does not depend on the
previous set of rdds which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk over spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a checkpointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
Define your dstream which is nothing but
series of your rdd Transformations your
streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the checkpoint which was created in case
of spark streaming one more thing we
need to remember is that your
checkpointing can be enabled by setting
it directly in a fault tolerant reliable
file system such as sdfs wherein the
checkpointing information will be saved
so we will have to add some methods
within your application like streaming
in context with the checkpoint and then
pointing into a checkpoint directory and
in that way we can have our stateful
Transformations or metadata information
stored in the underlying storage
whichever we have chosen now that we
have discussed about spark streaming
some basics of spark streaming let's
also understand about shared variables
or what we call as accumulator and
broadcast variables so normally when you
talk about your spark operations such as
your map or reduce these are executed on
one of the node of your cluster and what
happens is when you talk about your
operations they work on separate copies
of all variables used in the function
now in this case variables are copied to
each machine and no updates to the
variables on remote machines are
propagated back to the driver program
now when we talk about read write shared
variables across tasks that would be
inefficient so spar actually provides
two limited types of shared variables
for common usage patterns and those are
your broadcast variables and your
accumulators now when you talk about
your accumulators these are variables
that are only added through an
associative or commutative operation so
spark natively supports accumulators of
numeric types and programmers can add
support for your new types so when we
talk about accumulators they can be used
to implement counters such as your map
reduce or sums so as a user you can
create named or unnamed accumulators now
as we see in the image here it named
accumulator in this instance counter
will display in web UI for the stage
that modifies that accumulator spark
displays the value for each accumulator
Modified by a task in the tasks table
now tracking accumulators in the UI can
be useful for understanding the progress
of your running stages but we should
remember that as of now this is not
supported in Python might be in future
the support for python will also be
added now when you talk about your
accumulators you can have say a numeric
accumulator created by calling a spark
context and its method such as long
accumulator or you could have double
accumulator to accumulate values of type
long or double respectively so tasks
running on a cluster can then add to it
using the add method now we cannot I
mean in this case the value cannot be
read but driver program can read the
accumulators value using its Value
method we can look at some examples to
understand this later now when you talk
about your broadcast variables that is
one more type of variables which allows
the programmers to keep a read-only
variable cast on each machine rather
than shipping a copy of it with tasks
now what we know is some sometimes you
might be doing very costly operations
like joins where you might be working on
multiple rtds they need to be joined and
these rtds could also be pair rdds which
could be key value pairs now whenever
you're performing a join there would be
kind of two level of shuffling one
within a particular rdd so if you are
joining two rdds the first RTD which
might have data in the form of key value
pairs that rdd would have to have some
shuffling where all the similar keys can
be brought into one partition and this
would happen on the second RTD also
which has again key value Pairs and then
if you are doing a join these rtds will
be shipped to the node or basically the
data would be loaded in the memory and
then basically your Transformations will
happen this can be a cost clear Affair
so what can be done is you could create
broadcast variables so for example if we
have two rtds and we want to perform a
join operation and if one rdd is known
to be small color then we can create a
broadcast variable of the smaller rdd so
that this variable itself can be shipped
to each machine and then this variable
can be used for your join operations
with the other rdd which is existing in
the memory of those nodes so that saves
time and that improves your performance
so spark basically attempts to
distribute the broadcast variable using
efficient broadcast algorithms to reduce
the communication cost now if for
example you have multiple nodes in a
cluster and if you would want to give
every node a copy of large input data
set in an efficient manner so spark
actions are executed through a set of
stages now we know that and stages are
separated by your Shuffle operations so
whenever we talk about narrow
dependencies such as map flat map filter
you would not have any shuffling
involved but if you go for group by key
Reduce by key and such operations to
bring the similar Keys together there
would be shuffling involved and also
this applies when you're doing some join
operations so in that case broadcast
variables could be a really plus where
one set of data or rdd which is already
computed that could be broadcasted to
other nodes so the data broadcasted will
be cached in serialized form and
deserialized before running each task
this means that explicitly creating
broadcast variables can be useful when
tasks across multiple stages need the
same data or when caching the data in
deserialized form is important so we can
create broadcast variables using spark
context and its method called broadcast
and your broadcast variable can then be
shipped to other nodes which can be used
for your other operations now when you
talk about smart streaming it is used in
various use cases I mean you could talk
about speech recognition you could talk
about sentiment analysis you could talk
about uh streaming applications which
would be performing some kind of
analytics on the data which is coming in
it is also used widely in retail chain
companies now if you look at the example
here so big retail chain companies would
want to build real-time dashboards so
that they can keep a track of their
inventory and operations and for this
they would need one streaming data or
data which is constantly getting
generated as source which needs to be
processed on and this information can
then be populating your dashboards to
give you a real-time scenario or
real-time information of what is
happening so in case of an inventory
dashboard you could use then these
interactive dashboards wherein you could
draw insights about the business and
that's what retail companies are doing
so how many products are being purchased
or products that have been shipped or
how many products have been delivered to
customers and this kind of information
would be good to capture in real time so
when the streaming data is basically
being processed so at one end you have
your data which is getting generated
that might be based on the sales which
are happening that might be based on the
products which are being shipped or that
might be based on the acknowledgment
that the products have been received now
while this data is getting generated at
various sources it can be subjected to a
spark streaming application which will
look into the streaming data perform
series of Transformations which you
would want to process the data at
regular time intervals and then pushing
it to your dashboards or to your storage
layer wherein it could then be used to
answer such questions so when we talk
about spark streaming it's an ideal
choice to process this kind of data in
real time and there are various use
cases so at one end if you see you have
a input stream which shows the product
status that is how many products were
purchased or shipped or delivered now
this would be then handled by your spark
streaming and also your spark core
engine which would then process the data
to give you an output stream which gives
you a status such as what was the total
count of products which are purchased
products which were shipped and products
which were delivered so this was a quick
and brief introduction to spark
streaming and how it works now we can
also see how spark streaming works or
how we create an application for that
what we can do is we can basically set
up our Eclipse to have your Scala based
spark applications and for that what you
could do is you could have your Eclipse
which can then be having a Scala plugin
added to it now if somebody would want
to look at the Scala plugin then you can
always go to Scala Dot
ide.org and this is the play case where
you can scroll towards the bottom you
can click on stable and that basically
also shows you a video how Scala plugin
can be added to your Eclipse it also
tells from where you can get the Scala
latest release and this can be added to
your Eclipse so in my case it has
already been added to the eclipse I'm
bringing it up here and then you can
have your applications built using your
IDE people would prefer to use IntelliJ
and that's also fine so you could also
look for videos on setting up IntelliJ
with your Scala plugin now there are two
ways one you can build your application
run it on your Windows machine when you
could have some kind of utility like
netcat which can be used to send in some
messages in a streaming fashion you
could have a receiver which looks at a
particular socket at a particular port
and you could build a streaming
application within your IDE run it on
your Windows machine in a local mode
which would then be looking at your
Source where the data is getting
generated that's one option the second
option is you could build your
application package it as jar and then
run it on a cluster now that could be a
spark Standalone cluster or spark with
yarn and then you could be packaging
your application using tools like SBT
and then use spark submit to submit your
application now I'll show you both the
ways in which you can work with
streaming applications so first is get
your eclipse and make sure that scalar
plugin is already added now in my case
on the right top corner I see Scala
symbol that says I can be using Scala
perspective now here I have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new Scala
project you can give it a name so for
example I could say my apps 3 and then
you can say finish so that creates a
project now within your project what you
can do is you can create a package so
for example I could say something like
main dot Scala and then say finish so
that creates your package now also one
thing to remember is it would be good to
change your compiler instead of 2.12 to
2.11 normally for different environments
you might have spark with different
versions and Scala with 2.10 or 2.11 so
it would be good to have the compiler
change to the bundle 2.11 so we can
select this project I can do a right
click I can go to the build path I can
say configure build path and then I can
click on Scala compiler where I will use
project settings and I will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
okay it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take effect just hit on
OK so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that or as I said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your IDE but you can
package it using SVT and then run it as
jar so what I'm doing here is on my
machine within my C drive I already have
spark distribution which I've downloaded
so basically I have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 I have
unzipped or untied it I have kept it in
my C and this basically has my spark now
within which I have my jars and this has
all my spark related jars so technically
speaking I can even use Windows command
line and I can start working on spark in
an interactive way or packaging my
application and running it in a local
mode so you could also do this so
basically have your spark and then if
you see on my desktop I have a Hadoop
folder within which I have a bin folder
and within which I have a win utils.exe
and this will be basically required when
you want to try out your spark based
applications whether that is streaming
or data frames to be tested on your
Windows machine so you can always search
and download the win utils.exe place it
in a Hadoop folder within the bin folder
on your machine so once you get your win
utils.exe once you have your charts what
you can do is for your project you can
just say right click you can go to the
build path and you can say configure
build path and here you had add external
jars so we can select all of these jars
here which I would want to add to my
build path so that my code can compile
and I can test it on the Windows machine
itself I can say open and then just
basically do apply and okay so that has
created my project with a package my
compiler is changed to 2.11 I have added
the external charge the spark related
jars and that is good enough for my code
now what we need is a streaming
application which we need to build so
let me show you from my existing project
how it looks like so within your Source
the same way I have main package and
here I have a streaming application so
this streaming application is to test or
to work on capturing the data which is
generated at this particular stream on a
particular IP and a particular port and
I would want to do some series of
Transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then I would want to print the results I
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is say spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here I have created an object I've
called this fifth app and I'm saying
extends app and this this is because
within my project I already have an
application which has been defined as
main so if your application has been
defined as main one application is
already existing then you can just have
your new objects with extending app so
we don't need to define the main method
here now here I am saying while conf new
spark conf so I'm creating a
configuration object I am setting my
application name and to test it on
Windows we will have to set the master
as local and it is advisable to give it
more than one thread because you would
be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here I am saying set master
local and then I am saying two threads I
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and I've given a time into level
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which I am setting for which I
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so I say stream
rdd which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket text stream now there are various
methods of spark streaming context for
example if I just go here and if I just
do a dot it shows me what are the
different options you have file stream
you have q stream you have socket stream
receiver stream and so on so I am using
socket text stream and I would want to
point it to this machine so I'll say
127.0.0.1 I will also specify Port 2222
okay and here once I have created my
configuration object my spark context my
spark streaming context with the time
interval and I have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular IP on this particular
Port now then I am specifying what I
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular Port so I'm saying well word
counts so I would want to work on the
stream rdd that is the D stream I would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space I would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then I
would want to do a Reduce by key now
Reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do I could do a count of this I could
print the result or I could even save it
with an output using the Java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you are done with this here
I'm mentioning spark streaming context
start now this will basically trigger my
spark streaming context to start and it
will run till we terminate this
application now here to run this on
Windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what I have
done is in my environment I basically
want to use let's say okay now let's
look at the configuration what you need
to set so here I have my streaming
application and let's look at the Run
configuration which basically shows my
application has started and it's running
on the environment so if you see here I
have added Hadoop underscore home
pointing to this Hadoop directory which
has been and when utils X I have also
given spark local IP which is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as scholar application and let's see
what it does so it tries to connect to
127.0.0.1 so receiver is done trying to
do that but it does not find anything on
that particular machine on that
particular Port so my receiver is not
able to find it is not able to establish
a connection now what I can do is I can
go to my command line and here I will go
into downloads so I've already
downloaded the netcat utility for
Windows and here we can basically search
for something which I have on my machine
within downloads and that is your netcat
utility so what I would do is I will
come back here and I would say NC DOT
exe lvp and then I could say my port
which I have specified in my streaming
application and I can just start this
netcat utility now here it says
listening on 222 it says connection to
127.0.0.1 and then if I look in the
background my receiver will now be able
to establish a connection establish a
connection with this netcat utility now
whatever I type here will be taken for
processing every 10 seconds and we would
see a word count while my application is
running so let's test this so I'll say
this is a test test is being done and as
soon as I pass in this message we see
that there is a word count happening for
the stream of data which is coming in we
can say Winters are coming Winters will
be cold and once I given these messages
we will see our streaming application
which will try to work on the data which
is coming in and process it and show us
the result so we can say this is a test
of winters and let's see if it continues
to do the processing and shows us doubt
right so my streaming application is
running fine it is looking at The Words
which we are passing in and we can say
if it is able to process my data and
every 10 seconds the 10 desktop socket
stream is looking on this machine at
this particular Port doing a series of
Transformations and these series of
Transformations and then are seen within
your console now in my application if I
had used word counts.save as text file
then I could also have my output getting
generated at every 10 second interval
and that would get saved here I could
also decide to have my output saved and
stored on a sdfs or any other storage so
this is a simple streaming application
what we saw which is using socket text
stream it is looking at this machine on
a particular Port where we are running a
netcat utility it does series of your
rdd Transformations that is flat map map
and then you reduce by key and finally
we are invoking an action such as print
which basically triggers these rdts
which work on my streaming data so this
is one example now what I could also be
doing is this is particularly my
application now I already have SBT for
windows installed so I can be going into
my project space so I could say
workspace I could go into my apps and
I'm in my project folder so I could say
SBT package and this will basically then
based on my build file which I already
have within my project folder so if you
see here this is my build file which
says name the version Scala version
spark version and the repository with
the spark to manage the dependencies for
all its components like spark core SQL
mlib streaming And Hive so you need to
have this build dot SBT file within your
project folder which can be used to
package your application as jar now we
have done the packaging and it shows me
that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once I have this I can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where I can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here I have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark Standalone
cluster you could look at the previous
videos which wherein I explain how to
set up a spark Standalone cluster now
here I can go into the spark directory
and then I could just say s bin start
all dot sh which will start by spark
master in worker node now I do have
Hadoop cluster also set up on this but
right now I'm running a spark Standalone
cluster which shows me I have a master
and worker process on this machine and I
have a worker process on this machine so
my spark Standalone cluster is running
we can always bring up the UI to see how
it looks like so here I can just to be
giving HTTP slash
um18080 so that's my spark Standalone
cluster with two worker nodes right now
there is no application running we can
come back here and we can check if we
have my jar file so I've already placed
my jar here now at any point of time if
you have your jar which has been
packaged you can always go and do a jar
minus x v f and you can choose your jar
to see what is within your jar which
I've already done on this machine so if
I look in the main folder I have Scala
and within Scala if you see these are
the different classes what we have so my
code was packaged as HR it has a fifth
app class which we would want to run
here so what I can do is I can just be
saying spark submit because now I would
want my application to run on the
cluster so I can say class main dot
Scala and then my object name so I will
say fifth app now that's my class my jar
is this one and we will also say master
which is going to be spark which is
running on um one and it listens on 7077
Port so that would basically start my
streaming application but what we would
also need is like our windows we would
also need some utility like netcat so
basically what I can do is I can here
use a netcat utility to basically
connect or send in some messages for our
streaming application so let's say let
me search if I have already the netcat
which I might have used here so let's
see so we on your Ubuntu machine you
will have to install your netcat utility
by saying a app get netcat so here I can
say NC minus L and then I can say Port
which is 2222 so we can see if this is
working so this is a test and let's see
if it works so let's start our
application streaming application which
then needs the receiver to establish a
connection with the particular machine
and let's see if that is done so here I
could also be canceling this and give it
a particular Port so I can say 192 168
0.18 now the only problem is when we
packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the IP and also
comment out the local so when I package
this to run on the cluster I commented
out this part and I obviously would not
be giving 127 but the IP where my netcat
is running so right now let's test it so
we will say this is a test new test for
our application and I'm sending in some
messages so it is already doing the word
count as we expected it to do and if
while we are doing it if you come back
here so you would see your application
is now running on the cluster so it is
my application it is using four cores
what is the memory per executor and you
can basically click on your application
now here you can look at the application
detail UI to see what is being done so
for our application we have streaming
job running receiver which says this is
my application it says it is running you
can basically click at this click on
this and it says your dag visualization
which will say the streaming job which
is running you can look at the stages if
you would want to see if there are
multiple stages which we don't have
because we are not doing any wider
transformation we can look at storage if
we have used some persisting or caching
we can look at the executors which are
being used and one of the important
things when you talk about your
streaming is the streaming tab which
gets activated now that does not show up
when you run your batch applications but
in your streaming applications you have
the UI shows you the streaming Tab and
that basically says running batches of
10 seconds for 2 minutes 9 seconds
already now we see the input rate we see
the receivers we see if there is any
delay in scheduling what is the
processing time how many batches it has
completed and it basically shows me what
is the processing time how many tasks
were run and so on so my application is
running fine and unless and until we go
ahead and cancel this my application
will continue to run it will keep
looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if I would want
to just copy this and start again where
I would keep passing in this is say test
one test one is this where we test
streaming application right and I can be
seeing that my message edges are being
processed I am getting a word count so
we can say winter winter summer Old
Winter and you can always look at if
your streaming application is doing the
word count so this is a simple way where
you can run your streaming application
either on a Windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
Standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a
yarn-based cluster now that we have seen
a streaming application which does a
word count it will be interesting to
also see the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as I explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here I'm
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
and Spark context spark configuration
I'm also so using the spark API Java
function I am then using spark streaming
API and I'm also using Storage level
because I also intend to have the
persistence or caching done now here we
create an application say streaming app
extends app we create our configuration
object where we say app name and then we
set master with appropriate number of
threads we create the smart streaming
context that we initialize it and then
we have the spark streaming context
which depends on SC and we have given a
time interval of 10 seconds we then set
up a receiver so we say stream rdd which
will use socket extreme like we did
earlier with which will look for this
particular machine at this port wherein
I am also using Storage level so what I
would want is that the data stream which
would get generated here every 10
seconds should be cached in memory now
we could use different storage levels
that is we could use memory only disk
only memory and disk you could have
memory and disk with replication Factor
so you have different storage levels now
here we are then doing some series of
Transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduced by key and here I am
using a transformation which is reduced
by key and window now this one basically
takes the function as I said the
windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each interval which we
would want to look at so these are the
two main aspects One is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
Consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice I am also doing a check
pointing here wherein I have not
specified a specific directory but what
I am saying here is I would want to
checkpoint or I would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using Storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
checkpointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so I can basically
start this application by just doing a
run as Scala application now this would
start my streaming application with
window based computations now we can
open up our command line where we would
want to start a netcat utility so I
could go to downloads let me just
minimize this window here and what I can
do is I can then be starting my netcat
utility so I could say NC DOT exe minus
lvp and on a port 222 as soon as I do
this in background my application
receiver will be able to establish
connection to this netcat utility
running on this particular Port now
that's done so we can see if the word
count happens for our 10 second interval
so let's do that so I'll say this is my
first test and if I do this it should
give me the word count for the data
which I have passed in now I can say
this is my second test this is my third
test and if you see here it basically is
doing this now if I say this is my first
test again so since we are doing window
based operation also we will see a
Consolidated set of Transformations
which happen for a window of three
intervals so if you see here now my this
is giving me a count but it is not
showing me totally this as 4 or say this
because it is only looking at a window
of last two or three time intervals so
now it is back because it is looking at
the last one so if I say this is my test
test is done test is done so if you do
this it will show you the word count
which is for whatever you have passed in
like test is done is twice test is
Thrice but then since windowing based
operation is done you will look at the
time interval of the messages which were
passed within the that particular window
now we can also since my application is
running and it is on Windows we can
bring up your spark UI so I can go to
http and slash slash I can be looking at
my machine and the port so for example I
could do this this shows my streaming
application which is running in wherein
I can see the window based application
which is running but what would be
interesting is to look at the stages if
there is any kind of shuffling which is
happening looking at the storage should
show me the persistence which we are
doing now if you see here it shows me
that we have been persisting in the
memory what size it occupies how many
partitions were cast and this is because
of the persistence or the Storage level
what we have used as memory only now if
we change that to disk we will see our
rdds will be cached on disk and then you
can look at your streaming tab which
gives you more information about your
batches so this is is a very simple
example obviously you can change what
kind of RTD computations you would want
to do here whether you want to do a word
count or something else whether you want
to save your processed output now here
we are able to do that you can always do
a Refresh on your project and here what
we see is we see some entries of a
folder getting created right and we can
decide whether we would want our output
to be created we can also see within
this what would be containing and since
we have set checkpointing in the project
folder it would also be checkpointing
temporarily the information for any kind
of failure so this is a classic example
of streaming application using window
based computations persisting your
computations and also doing the
checkpointing simultaneously we will
learn about what is spark SQL what are
spark SQL features it's r architecture
spark SQL data frame API data source API
spark SQL Catalyst Optimizer running SQL
queries and then we can have a quick
demo on spark SQL so what is spark SQL
it's a Sparks model or Apache Sparks
module for structured data processing
now it allows you to work with
structured semi-structured and even
unstructured data but primarily with
structured and semi-structured it
originated to overcome the limitations
of Apache Hive now we know that Apache
Hive is a data warehouse package on top
of Hadoop and this basically is quite
extensible it allows you to work on
structured data or data which can be
structuralized with the various features
such as user-defined functions or
support of complex data types or custom
mapreduce scripts and many more however
there are a lot of limitations in terms
of using Apache hive such as it always
depends on mapreduce as an execution
engine or processing framework or it
could also use these you would not be
able to do insert update deletes when it
comes to Apache Hive it is more of a
patch oriented operation and basically
querying with Hive can be time consuming
however how is Hive is quite extensible
in the way it supports data warehousing
use cases it lags in performance as I
said it goes for map reduce and it's not
really suitable when you would want to
do faster querying or ad-hoc querying it
does not allow you to resume a job if it
fails somewhere in the middle and these
are some high level limitations of Hive
when we talk about spark it performs
better than Hive now spark we already
know is a in memory Computing framework
which basically works on having the data
loaded into the memory that is in the
form of rdds and then having the dag
execution whenever a action is invoked
now if we compare latency in terms of
hours we would see spark is quite
competitive in that with Hive and is a
better performant when you talk about
CPU in days or CPU reservation time in
all of these cases spark wins over hive
now let's look at spark SQL features and
let's understand how it helps so as I
mentioned spark SQL is a module for
structured data processing primarily now
unlike the basic Sparks rdd API the
interface is provided by spark SQL
provide spark with more information
about the structure of both the data and
computation being performed now we know
that spark has a dag scheduler behind
the scenes and if that tax scheduler
could know what are the steps which are
part of your processing application then
it would understand the steps it would
benefit from data which would be
structured and thus have a better way of
processing your data internally spark
SQL uses this extra information to
perform extra optimizations now there
are different ways in which you can
interact with spark SQL including SQL
and data set API you could be using data
frames API data source API and also the
older way that is RTD API now some of
these features really make spark SQL a
compelling framework for data processing
and analyzing especially if you have
data which is structured you can
integrate spark SQL and query structured
data inside spark programs it is highly
compatible with a SQL based Frameworks
like Hive so it can work on the data
which is stored in Hive it can work on
the data which is stored in your rdbmss
which are external to your big data
setup or even on the files which are
stored on your distributed file system
such as sdfs when we talk Sparks
integration with Hive you can run
unmodified Hive queries on existing
warehouses in spark SQL so while
existing Hive data queries and udfs
Spark SQL offers full compatibility now
spark SQL leverages the rdd model as it
supports large jobs and mid query fault
tolerance for interactive and long
queries it uses the same engine so in
terms of spark 1.6 and all older
versions We had rdd API that is whenever
you do some Transformations such as map
flat map filter and many more that would
create rdds and you can say logical
steps in the dag which would be executed
only and only when a in action was
invoked now in terms of older apis we
said that spark has rdd and when we talk
about newer versions of spark we have
spark data frames or data sets and when
we talk about data frames that is using
an implementation of rdd which we call
as schema rdds or you could say in older
versions of spark we were talking about
schema DDS which get created based on
your Transformations and in newer
versions the same schema rdds are called
Data frames there are different ways in
which you can use spark SQL so you could
use an odbc or jdbc connector and then
you could be connecting to your external
databases business intelligence tools
and then extract the data from your
underlying data stores and process them
remember spark does not have its own
storage it has various components such
as spark SQL streaming ml lab you have
rdds and you have Graphics but then
spark always relies on a storage now
that storage could be a Hadoop
distributed file system that could be a
nosql database it could also be a rdbms
to which you can connect using jdbc odbc
or it could be just your local file
system on which your files are stored
and Spark can use those files and
process the data within those files now
when we talk about your spark
architecture or spark SQL architecture
you have basically at the lowest level
you have your data sources now that
could be your data in CSV format or Json
format or also coming in from external
sources using your jdbc odbc connectors
you have different apis so you have a
data source API we'll learn about it you
have a data frame and a data set API
which allows you to work with data and
then you have different ways in using
these so you could have a data frame
domain specific language that is DSL or
you could be using spark SQL or Hive
querying language to use one of these
apis to process your data so spark SQL
is Apache Sparks module mainly to work
with structured data now when we talk
about spark SQL it has three main layers
it has a language API so spark is very
compatible as it supports multiple
languages such as python your Scala Java
even R which is used in data science
activities and your hive querying
language when we talk about schema rdd
so shows at spark SQL works on schema
tables and records and what it creates
behind the scenes is a schema rdd or an
rdd which has schema within it which
helps the DAC scheduler to understand
the data and the steps which are being
performed and as I said in newer
versions your schema rdd is your data
frame which is nothing but a
representation of your data in the form
of rows and columns with column headings
and you could call it as a temporary
table where your data is getting stored
the third layer is your data sources so
that is your data coming in from varied
sources that could be your files in
different formats such as CSV Json text
parquet Avro and so on you could be
getting your data from different nosql
databases such as Cassandra mongodb your
Edge base or anything else you could
also be getting data directly from hive
which are your logical stock just such
as databases and tables however the data
is stored on an underlying file system
such as sdfs now when we talk about your
data frames and data sets so a data
frame is basically a data set organized
into named columns so what is a data set
so a data set is a distributed
collection of data it's it's a new
interface which was added in spark 1.6
which provides the benefits of rdds such
as strong typing ability to use powerful
Lambda functions and with the benefits
of spark X sqls optimized execution
engine so a data set can be constructed
from jvm objects and then manipulated
using functional transformation such as
map flat map filter and so on so your
data set API is available in Scala and
Java and python did not support the real
estate API but I think that's been work
upon for the future releases when we
talk about data frame it is basically a
data set organized into named columns or
we can say representing your structured
data or semi-structured data in the form
of rows and columns with columns having
headings so it is conceptually
equivalent to a table in a relational
database or a data frame in python or
our programming language but it has
richer optimizations under the hood so
data frames can be constructed from wide
array of your sources such as your
structured data files tables in Hive
external databases or even existing rdds
so again your data frame API is
available in Scala Java Python and R
programming and your data frame is
represented by a data set of rows we can
just say that a frame is simply Alias of
your data set of rows now when we talk
about your data frames let's also
understand about your spark SQL data
source API spark SQL it supports
operating on a variety of data sources
through the data frame interface it
supports your different formats such as
CSV Hive Avro Json parquet text and so
on as we know about in spark it is
lazily evaluated like your Apache spark
Transformations and can be accessed
through SQL context And Hive context so
as we have seen in previous tutorials
your spark context or your hive context
or in later versions what we have is
spark session these are basically the
classes which are your entry point of
your application so when you start a
spark shell in an interactive way or a
pi spark you would see the spark context
is initialized or your spark session is
automatically initialized if you are
building your applications using an IDE
then we would have to Define and
initialize our spark context and Spark
session which is in later versions of
spark in older versions you had spark
context and then you had SQL context or
Hive context it can be spark can be
easily integrated with big data tools
and Frameworks we have spark core engine
now before we learn about spark Catalyst
Optimizer let's have a quick look so if
I look in my machine here and if I look
in my machine I could look in my C drive
and if you see here I have downloaded
spark and Spark
2.4.3 now if you could follow previous
tutorials you would know how to set up
spark on Windows however just for new
people I can just give here some
information saying let's look at
environment variables and here I have
set up two important variables one is
your Hadoop underscore home which points
to a folder called Hadoop on my desktop
and I'll show you what is there in that
I also have spark underscore home which
has been set to my spark path Now what
is my desktop and my Hadoop folder
contain it basically contains a bin
folder and within that I have a win
utils executable which helps our spark
when launching to just realize if there
was a dummy Hadoop support here now what
we can do here is I can go in to my
command line I can go into my spark
directory and then I can go in pin here
if I just do a dir slash P I would see
that within this I have different
binaries or different programs and what
we can do is we can just start by doing
a DOT slash spark shell so this is
basically an interactive way of working
with spark for people who would be more
comfortable with Scala as a programming
language they could use spark shell or
if people are comfortable with python
then they could be using pi spark so
here I'm trying to launch the spark
shell which will run in a local mode it
will not be contacting any yarn or
resource manager however it will just
start an application locally on this
machine it will initiate the spark
context as I mentioned earlier or
basically your spark session depending
on which version of spark we are working
on so if you see here I have spark
version 2.4.3 Scala is 2.11 it has a
spark context which is available as SC
and Spark session which is available as
spark so this basically allows me to
work either with rdd API using SC or I
could be creating a data frame using
spark so both of these classes have got
initialized and they will act as an
entry point of my application into the
cluster in older versions of spark which
is 1.6 we still had spark context
available but then if we wanted to work
on spark SQL which was launched in an in
an experimental way with spark 1.6 we
could be using instead of spark session
we could be using SQL context or Hive
context so this is the spark context or
spark session which is getting
initialized if I was building an
application using IDE then I would have
to depending on my use case and need I
will have to initialize spark context or
spark session within my IDE coming back
and understanding about your Catalyst
Optimizer so when we talk about Catalyst
Optimizer what is it and what does it do
spark your Catalyst Optimizer leverages
Advanced programming language features
such as colors pattern matching and
Cassie quotes in a novel way to build an
extensible query Optimizer so what it
does it works in four phases your
Catalyst Optimizer it analyzes a logical
plan to resolve the references when you
are querying the data it has a logical
plan optimization internally which will
come up with the best way to get to the
data it has a physical planning layer
and then it also does code generation to
compile parts of query to your Java byte
codes when we talk about your Catalyst
Optimizer we can say if you have a SQL
query now that SQL query would result in
an unresolved logical plan which can
then help in analyzing the logical plan
and it also depends on the reference to
internal catalog which has information
about your data which you are trying to
query then there is a logical plan based
on the analysis analogical optimized
plan which is post your local logical
optimization which then relates in
physical plans and a cost model which
helps the catalyze of catalyst Optimizer
know what is the best way to reach and
access the data it gives away a selected
physical plan which will then generate
code based on the rdds which would be
implemented based on your query now
that's how Catalyst Optimizer works when
we talk about SQL context or spark
session as I explained it is a class
used for initializing the
functionalities of spark SQL so in older
versions of spark such as spark 1.6 when
you would start your spark shell or when
you would start your Pi spark so we can
see that here now I could just do a
simple quit and I could then try
bringing a pi Spar which is also a
binary or a program to work with your
spark but then that brings up your
Python's shell and useful for people who
are well versed with python as a
programming language now if you see here
we again have spark context initialized
as SC and then we have spark session
available as spark if I was working in
older version I would not have spark
session but I would have SQL context
which could be used to use the
functionality of spark SQL or basically
using Spar to work with structured data
so your SQL context is a class which is
used for initializing the
functionalities of your spark SQL or you
can say it is the class which becomes an
entry point of your application for the
resources which your application would
need for processing so we could just
start a spark shell and basically that
would start your spark context or spark
so when we talk about the spark context
or spark session you can also create a
SQL context or a spark session using
something like this on an interactive
cell so you can say Val SQL context
equals new org Apache SQL SQL context SC
and you could then start building your
application I will show that how you do
that in your IDE wherein you have to
initialize your spark context however as
I said in spark shell or in pi Spark
your spark on text gets initialized
automatically and you can work with your
rdd API or you could be using spark
session which is available as spark to
work on spark SQL whether you're working
with pi spark or you're working with
spark SQL using your spark shell now
moving forward when we talk about spark
session so this is an entry point to any
functionality in spark so to create a
basic spark session you could be using a
spark session dot Builder if you are
working in an IDE like Eclipse so here
you have to import a package that is org
Apache spark SQL spark session and then
you could create a variable such as well
spark you could use spark session dot
Builder you could provide an app name
you could also provide config properties
that is your configuration properties
and then you could say get or create now
that creates spark which can then be
used to work with your spark SQL you
could then do Imports parking implicits
and continue to work now here let me
start my eclipse parallelly and I can
show you how it looks here now when we
talk about working with data frames
either we can be doing that using your
spark shell Pi spark or we could be
using our Eclipse so let's see how we
can work with data frames here so let me
just quit by spark and let me get into
spark shell so I could just do this and
this will start my spark shell that's an
interactive way or working with my files
I could be using spark here and I could
be using spark session now for this we
would need some files now I could be
working on Windows or I could be working
on my Linux machine so here I can show
you both now this is basically a spark
Standalone setup where I have set up
things you can refer to the previous
tutorials where that I have shown how
you can set up spark Standalone or spark
on your windows I've started my spark
Standalone cluster if I look at the
processes on these two machines that
would show me that I have a master and
two worker processes I can also open up
the spark UI if we would want to look
into our applications and here we can
just say sdtp slash slash
um1 and then 8080 so that shows me my
spark Standalone cluster which had two
worker nodes as of now there are no
applications which are started and we
can start spark shell here so I can go
into user local spark and then I can see
that I have basically a bin folder which
has my programs or binaries which we can
use now we could be using that from
anywhere because in my bash RC I have
set up my spark path so that will allow
me to give my spark commands for
anywhere and here we can also see that I
have some data in Sample files we can
pick up one of the files here which we
can then use to create a data frame so I
can just say spark shell from my home
directory where I will Target a Json
file which is already here to create a
data frame now once I am starting my
spark shell it basically shows that it
has started an application it shows a UI
which is available it is basically
interacting with my spark Master there
is spark context available as a SC and
Spark session which is available as
spark same thing we see in our Windows
machine that is you have spark context a
web UI available which I can launch I
can look at spark context available and
Spark session which is available now
taking this file what we can do is we
can say Val X and then I can say spark
which is the short form of spark session
and then if you are not sure what method
should be used you can just do a tab and
that will show you all the possible
options which are available within spark
so here we can use read and again do a
DOT and then do a tab and it shows me
that we can get our data in different
formats Now by default if you do not
mention a format then it will expect the
file which you are working on in a
parquet format we can use a load method
here or I can just say
spark.read.json and then I'll point it
to a file which is in my sample files
folder and I will point it to
people.json and I can hit on enter now
here since we are using spark session we
will see if it creates a data frame now
if you see here it is pointing to a
driver issue basically saying it is not
able to reach MySQL or The Meta store so
by default spark also expects if it can
connect to your meta store which is
being used by Hive so now I'm on my
right machine
um1 where I have my MySQL installed
which I just checked by testing and I
have my MySQL installed here which is
being pointed within the spark conf by
Hive hyphen site file so now I will
start my spark shell again here which
should bring up your spark context and
also your spark session it will
basically interact with spark Master
which is running on this machine and as
we have given in the conf and in your
spark default conf so once my spark
shell has started I can start doing this
I can say Val X spark dot read dot Json
and then I'll point it to a file which
is in this directory called
people.json so that's the file and it is
in Sample files directory now once we do
this we are using spark session in which
is available as spark and when I do this
it refers to the config files and then
it is able to internally discover the
hive's meta store which is in mySQL
database that's because of the way I
have set up my spark Standalone cluster
also so that it can work with Hive now
here we see that a data frame has got
created and we can always look into this
so I can just do a x dot show to see
what is in my data frame so we pointed
to a Json file and my spark session
allowed me to create a data frame now at
any point of time unless and until you
use a show or an action you will not see
the result it would just create a data
frame now here we have x dot show which
shows my data frame I can also do a x
dot print schema and then I can see what
is the schema assigned to this so in
this way we just easily created a data
frame using a Json file now if I I come
here and if I do a refresh that will
show me the application which is running
which has been started by spark shell I
can click on this and then I can go into
application detail UI to see what we
have done so I did a spark.read.json and
I can look at the dag here which shows
what happened what code was generated
what were the Transformations which were
done it shows me how many tasks were run
for this and then I can go and look back
at my second job which is basically
ending with show where I see this in a
different stage I see the code which was
generated I see the map partitions and
then the map transformation also we can
always look at the SQL tab which is
getting created when you use spark SQL
and within that we can see what kind of
queries were run how much time did they
take and you can always click on the
query to see what internally it did so
it had a scan Json number of output rows
number of files what was the main data
time and basically I am seeing the
result so this is how I create a simple
data frame from a file and as I
mentioned you can read any file format
however if you do not give a format or
if you do not specify the right method
then it will expect the file to be in
parquet format so we just created a
simple data frame from a file now we can
do many other operations we can do
filtering we can do selection so we can
do this I can just do a x dot select and
I can choose one or multiple Fields so
either you could use a dollar and then
mention your column name here something
like this and then I could say I would
want to look at the name I would want to
look at the age but remember if I just
do this it will just create a data frame
so if I would want to see the result I
will be doing a DOT show and that shows
me what I have I can always do some more
things here I can into a filter and I
can say I would want to see the age
which is more than say 20 and at any
point of time when you do these
Transformations it always creates a data
frame or a data set now here I see that
when I did a filter it created a data
set so it is using the data set API now
I can just do a show to see the result
and that will show me the result in the
form of rows and columns with column
headings I could do a select I could do
a filter and I could work on my data in
this way on a particular data frame now
you could also do some computations if
you are interested in so you could
always do a x dot select and then you
could be selecting a particular field
for example I would say age and I would
say I would want to increase its value
by 1 and I would like to do a show so we
are working on a data frame wherein it
shows me the column name and then it
shows me the value so these are some
simple data frame operations which we
are doing based on a file which we have
here now I could be picking up a bigger
file and doing more functions or more
Transformations on that I could be doing
a filter as I said a select I could be
running MySQL queries by creating a
temporary view out of it now here we
could pick up a different file I would
say well my data and then I could say
spark dot read and this time I'm going
to use the format method here so I'll
say format now I would specify I would
like to work on CSV file then I could
basically also use something called as
option and then I could be specifying I
would want to infer the schema from the
file so I'll say true I will say option
and then I could also say a delimiter if
you would want to specify now here I
have infer schema as true and we would
then want header that is first row in
the file to be considered as the header
or the column headings then I can just
say load and I would want to load my
file so I'm going to pick up sample
files and then I will point it to a file
which I think is existing in this
directory something like this and then I
do this which should basically create a
data frame from a CSV file you see it
shows 15 fields and the schema is
understood so I can just say my data dot
print schema and this will show me the
schema which was inferred and we have
our data frame created we can always do
a my data dot so and that shows me some
rows and columns now remember it will
always show you only 20 rows if you
would want more then you could be giving
it here in the bracket and then you
could see more values so here we have
created a data frame from a CSV file we
could do a filter we could do a select
from this we could basically do any kind
of computations I could give different
conditions so this is a bank related
data where some kind of campaign was
done to find out if customers would be
interested in subscribing for a deposit
now all these sample files are existing
in my GitHub link and I'll share that
link towards the end of session you can
always use these files or you can use
some of your own files now here I could
just do a my data dot select and I could
be selecting multiple columns if I'm
interested in so I could just do a
dollar I could say I would be interested
in age I could be interested in job
marital status or even the column which
says about subscription the last one
which says y so I could say dollar and
then I could say job I would say I would
want to see the subscription and then I
could be doing this close the bracket
now remember that will just create a
data frame so we need to do a show to
show me the results so I'm doing a
select and I've started working on my
data frame you could be doing some other
kind of calculations say we want to find
out what are the total number of rows in
this particular data frame so I could
just do a count and then I could do show
or what I could do is I could convert
this to a double value by doing this and
it shows me the total count of entries
in this data frame is forty five
thousand two hundred eleven now I could
basically be assigning this to a
variable say well total count and then I
get my value so for example we would
want to find out what is the success
rate of this campaign and how many
people were really interested in
subscribing for a deposit with bank I
could do that by just saying creating a
variable called subscription account and
what I would want is I would want to
work on my data frame I I would want to
basically filter the values where the
value for subscription holds true if it
is yes and then we could just do a count
of this and convert this to double value
like we did earlier for total count and
that tells me how many people were
interested in subscription so it gives
me a count of people who who are
interested in subscribing for a deposit
now we could do some computation on this
so we could say well success rate and
then I could just say subscription count
divided by total count and you could
even multiply this by 100 to see the
percentage so it tells me the success
rate of this campaign was 11 because
this or these many number of people were
interested in subscribing for a deposit
and in this way you could be doing many
more computations you could be using
different functions you could be using
different combination of functions so
for example I could just do a my data
dot select and then I could say I would
want the average on the balance column
to find out what is the average balance
of the customers which we would want to
understand now here I could just do a
show and that could show me what is the
average balance of a customer who was
inquired about his or her interest in a
deposit in similar way you could be
using multiple functions like average
mean median percentile and so on now
there is one more thing about data
frames you could basically be creating a
temporary View and then people could be
using their select queries to work on
data so we could do the same thing now
here we could say my data dot create or
replace Temp View and we could give it a
name so let's say Bank data and this
basically facility dates querying so now
we can just use spark dot SQL and then
start using our queries to query
structured data which we would have
basically used to create a data frame so
and now I can do a select star from Bank
data where age is greater than might be
75 and I could just close this and
whenever I do this remember it creates a
data frame so if you would want to see
the result you can just do a show and
that will show you the result of your
data frame and we are seeing the fields
which are having values greater than 80
or 75 so I not only created a temporary
view but now I am able to query that
using spark dot SQL now here this is one
way in which you can work with your data
frames work on different formats look
into the schema run your queries do some
computations and then basically all also
save it as a data frame we could do many
more things so here for example if I
would want to write this data in a
different format or save it I can always
do a spark dot SQL now the same query
which we ran here we could put this in a
variable so for example let's say well
result and I can just do this now I know
that creates a data frame which has been
now assigned to result and now with
result I can basically look into
different methods which are available so
food if you would want to save it if you
would want to write it in a particular
format remember if you do not specify a
format then it will always be read or
written in par K so I can always do a
write dot either I could be using a
particular format or I could straight
away say save and then I could say for
example my new DF data frame and if I do
this the whole point is your data frame
would now be saved on your machine in
this particular directory in a parquet
format so I can come in here and then I
can look in if I have the directory
created so we see here and we can look
in this what does this have and this
basically has a parquet file which got
created now I can always do a SSH to my
second machine because this is a
standalone cluster and then I can see if
there was any directory created on this
machine which has the data if no then
that's fine if we have a data directory
we can always look for our file so we
just saved the output of our data frame
in a parquet file and that's my parquet
file now there is a easier way of
checking if this was fine so this is in
my new DF directory now what I can do
here is I can just say spark dot read
and this time I will not specify a
format and we know when we do not do
that it expects the file to be in a
parquet format so I'll say load my new
DF that's the directory I'll give the
file name and then basically I'll see if
it reads this parquet file creates a
data frame and yes it has done that we
can always do a show and we can see our
new data frame now I know you might see
some error like this and that is because
this file did not exist on both the
machines and when you're looking in a
spark Standalone cluster if you are
trying to do a read operation it
basically expects the file to be
existing on both the machines or you
should have been getting the file from a
distributed file system now we can try
this again and I can just do a SCP I can
take this directory and I know there is
a SSH access which I have set up across
machine so I can say sdu at um2 in the
home directory so that this directory
and file exists on both the machines and
now we will will try it again so if you
see now I'm trying to read the file I
don't get any error message so we worked
on a CSV file we created a data frame
then we saved the data frame using write
dot save and by default it was stored in
a parquet format we could test that by
just doing a read.load now the way we
did a write dot save and we did not give
a format we could have chosen a format
so we could have said format and we
could have set Json and then do a save
and basically give a directory name now
this is also saving my data frame but
now it is saving it in a format of my
choice so I can look in new df1 I should
have my data coming in here it might
take some time and then we can come back
and check here if it has saved my file
in a Json format so in this way you can
either store the data in a default
format or basically you can store it in
a particular format of your choice such
as Json or text or some other format so
this is how we are just interacting with
a file on local file system I am
creating a data frame out of it and then
basically I am doing some computations
now as I said if you have a setup now in
this case I have a spark Standalone
cluster but if I I would want I can
start up a Hadoop cluster I can just say
s bin start DFS dot SH now that will
start my Hadoop related processes based
on the setup I have and why am I doing
it because I would want to try spark
interacting with Hive now Hive is using
hdfs as the storage layer so I'm
starting my Hadoop cluster I can go into
my second machine and then basically I
can again start my rest of processes so
I can just say s bin and then I can say
start yarn dot sh and that will start my
yarn related processes so I have a
Hadoop cluster running which basically
means now I can also work with Hive so I
can just go into Hive directory I've
already set up Hive I can get into hive
by just doing a bin slash Hive I can
look into a database if it is existing I
can look into a table which is existing
see if that contains data and try
querying it using your spark so I can
say show databases and that basically
shows me that I have a database called
testdb let's use that in Hive and now
I'm in the database I can say show
tables that shows me some tables let's
select one of the table I can say s t b
l two might be we can just do a limit of
10 rows and see if it works fine so that
does not have any data let's look into
another table and let's see if that has
some data that also does not have any
data and that might be if we are not
looking into the right metadata let's
look into one more and see if that's
fine so we will say test TBL TBL limit
10 doesn't have the data so let's do one
thing let's create a table so I'll say
create table new TBL I will say ID is
integer name is string I will say the
table is created you can always do a
listing from here by looking in user
Hive Warehouse my test database and then
I can see if that my database has the
table directory it has new table let's
look into that new TBL and then does
that have any data as of now no so I can
say load data local in path I will take
this sample files I know there is a file
called kv1.txt which has internal format
and I will say overwrite into table and
then I can say new TBL so I'm loading
some data it does not like the because
it does not find this directory so let's
give the right path so we will say home
hdu sample files now I'm loading some
data I have done that and now I can say
new TBL limit 10 so this is a simple
example of loading some data in Hive
table which has two columns we did not
give any delimiters because I know the
file also does not have any specific
delimiters now here I can just exit this
our main task was not to work with Hive
but to work with spark SQL in
interacting with Hive which is a data
warehouse package on top of Hadoop so it
is using hadoop's distributed file
system I mean Hive is using hadoop's
distributed file system to store the
data and we would want to use spark SQL
and especially its data frame API to
work on interacting with Hive now let's
do a spark dot SQL now if you remember I
mentioned that my spark conf directory
has already a hive hyphen site file so
it knows where Highway storing the
metadata and that basically means that
your spark SQL can directly work with
Hive and you can then start using all
your hive queries within spark benefit
from in-memory processing and the data
frame API so here I can say use test DB
so I basically would want to get into
the database and I'm using this spark
SQL you see there is a empty data frame
created now let's say select star from
new TBL limit 10 and I could do this and
this is basically your data frame now
you could do a show and you have started
interacting with Hive directly which
creates a data frame which allows you to
look at the data and then you can store
it in a variable you can store this file
not only this you could also create a
table from spark SQL so you could
basically do all your hive related
operations from here using your data
frame API so I could be saying similarly
create table new tbl2 and then I could
say ID would be integer name would be
string and then I could just close this
so I'm creating a table and I would like
to close this so let's do that now you
see somewhere it interacts with Hive
metastore it has created a new table and
that should be stored in my hive
metastore and also on your hdfs where
Hive related data is getting stored now
we can even load data into it so we will
say spark.sql I will use the same
statement load data local in path I will
pick up the file from sample files slash
kv1.txt I will say over right into table
new tbl2 close the bracket and that
should load data into your hive table
now let's try querying it so we'll say
spark.sql I will say select star from
new tbl2 I will say order by ID is
sending and then I can say limit 10 so
I'm running a query which if would have
run in Hive would have triggered a
mapreduce job now here this uses a data
frame and you can always do a show which
will see show you the result so we are
interacting with Hive we are creating
table we are loading data into it we are
running a query using in-memory
processing using data frames and that
does not trigger a mapreduce job if we
had done the same thing using Hive let
me just show you here so let's get into
Hive let's start the hive Shell let's
use our database and then we can query
our table so I can do use sdb and if I
say select star from New tbl2 Order by
ID descending limit then and just run
this now you will see that this triggers
a mapreduce job because Hive uses
mapreduce now it also mentions on the
first line that high one map reduces
deprecated in Hive 2 will not be
available in future versions you can use
other execution engines like spark and
taste but we are querying the table
which we have created using spark and
now we are using Hive to do it which
obviously takes more time it triggers a
mapreduce job and does the work for you
so this is how you can use your spark
SQL and your data frames to work let me
just exit this and there is one more
option where you can be interacting with
your rdbms now that is say I have MySQL
here and I have I can login into the
this I can just say show databases so I
have my databases here I can say use
MySQL I can say show tables and then I
can query one of the tables like for
example help underscore keyword and then
let's do a limit 10 so that shows me
some data here now it would be good if
we could interact with rdbms and then
get the data from here and for that we
will have to do certain things so that
we can connect to this and we can work
with this rdbms so if you look in your
user local spark now that has a jars
directory and if I look in my jars
directory I have lot of Jar files here
but I would be interested in doing a
graph and finding out if I have a MySQL
related jar file so if you see here we
have placed the MySQL jar file now where
does this jar file come from so this
MySQL jar file if I look in my home hdu
downloads and then if I look in here you
would see I have a MySQL connector tar
file which I have downloaded now that
particular tar connect or contains your
MySQL connector jar file and this MySQL
connector jar file has an inbuilt driver
class which allows any particular
service to connect with mySQL so we need
the jdbc connector jar file only then we
can have our spark connect with mySQL
which we already know is doing because
your spark is able to look at the hive
metastore And Hive metastore is getting
stored in MySQL now how do we establish
a connection from spark SQL to this
MySQL like we connected using spark Hive
you can always use spark to connect to
an external rdbms as I mentioned and you
can always search for that you can just
say spark SQL jdbc data frame and then
look into the data frame documentation
which will show you the syntax but for
this remember you will have to set up a
MySQL instance you will have to get the
driver and then you can be giving all
these options such as URL DB query your
driver and then other options to connect
to an rdbms you can connect to any
particular rdbms by just basically doing
this spark dot read dot format connect
to an rdbms get the data from it create
a data frame and work on it for many
more examples you can always look into
the data frame documentation you can
always be clicking on this and then you
can see how you can connect with Hive
how you can work with data sets and data
frames you can also look into different
data formats which are selected and you
can do much more with data frames now
here in this tutorial we will learn
about what is spark MLF what is machine
learning about machine learning
algorithms you have spark ml lip tools
and different data types that it
supports machine learning pipelines
machine learning library algorithms and
then we can have a quick demo on spark
mlib use case now when we talk about
spark ml lip of different components in
Sparks such as spark streaming rdts your
data frame so data sets you have spark
mlib which stands for machine learning
library in spark the goal of this
library is to make practical machine
learning scalable and easy to implement
now when we talk about ml lab this is
Sparks machine learning library and
basically it provides tools such as ml
algorithms which include common learning
algorithms such as classification
regression clustering and collaborative
filtering it also gives you
featurization that is feature extraction
transformation dimensionality reduction
and selection you have pipelines that is
stored for constructing evaluating and
tuning ml pipelines it has the features
for persistence that is saving and load
algorithms models and pipelines and then
you also have utilities for your linear
algebra statistics data handling Etc so
when you talk about your ml lib it has a
data frame based API which is a primary
API now as of spark 2 onwards the rdd
based API that is in the spark ml lip
package entered a maintenance mode and
your primary machine learning API for
spark now is data frame based API that
is spark dot ml we'll learn about that
now when you talk about machine learning
and Sparks ml lib it basically works on
data which is collected it can process
the data that is you can build your
machine learning algorithms using spark
ml lip it also helps you in building
data models which can then be used for
further process thing so before we
understand about spark ml lib and its
features and its capabilities it will be
good to learn about what is machine
learning now machine learning is the
science of training computers to learn
from data and perform specific tasks
without being explicitly programmed and
when I say training computers it is
basically training computers or making
your algorithms learn by themselves
based on the input which is provided you
have lot of use cases for machine
learning uh recently I have been working
in autonomous driving space and again
there is lot of usage of machine
learning algorithms especially in driver
assistance systems object classification
or even autonomous driving you have
various use cases where think about your
mailbox where you receive emails and
they are automatically filtered and
pushed into a spam folder now how does
that happen so there is a machine
learning algorithm running in the
background which looks at the content of
the data probably looks at some words or
patterns and identifies your mail as a
scam take an example of Google search
where you would want to search something
and your auto complete feature allows
you to complete what you would want to
search for and then helps you in finding
something other companies can be
something like LinkedIn where you have
data driven Services based on the
connections a particular user has based
on the postings a user has done you
could have recommendations based on
courses or job openings and so on and
this is happening based on
recommendation systems which are also a
form of machine learning algorithms so
when you talk about your machine
learning you have to have human
intervention so you would have data
which might be accumulated now that
might be batch data that might be
streaming data and your algorithms or or
computer or system has to learn from the
past data and then it should be able to
predict the output now when we talk
about analytics there are different kind
of analytics you have prescriptive
analytics descriptive analytics you have
statistical analytics you have
preemptive analytics and you have
Predictive Analytics and in various
scenarios machine learning plays a very
important role it's an important branch
of artificial intelligence now when you
talk about machine learning algorithms
they can be classified mainly into three
main categories you have supervised
learning based algorithms that is
algorithms which depend on labeled data
or data which has response based on the
features and which makes it easier to
predict the output now you might also
have unsupervised learning algorithms
that do not have labeled data or do not
have responses so they have unlabeled
data and it is used to discover patterns
from the data you could all also have
reinforcement based algorithms and in
reinforcement learning algorithms an
agent receives a reward in the next time
step to evaluate its previous action so
these are three main categories of your
machine learning algorithms now if we
would want to learn more on supervised
learning look at the image here which
says labeled data of dogs and cats and
if this is the kind of data which is fed
into your algorithm it process the data
wherein it would again depend on the
labels so looking at the images labels
would say well the first part of the
image is dogs or you have cats and so on
now once the data is processed then you
could say your algorithm is trained or
the model which is being used is
strained based on the past data which
was fed in and then you have your
trained model which basically can then
look at an unknown piece of data to
predict the outcome so you could be
working on label data training your
model and then basically the same model
can be tested against a data which does
not have a label but your algorithm
would be able to successfully classify
or identify the object now when you talk
about supervised learning it is
classified into regression and
classification so you have various
different techniques you have linear
regression you have logistic regression
you have decision tree random Forest
support Vector machines K nearest
neighbors name space and so on so when
you talk about these one of the primary
criteria of choosing supervised learning
depends on the data what you have and
whether that data has label or no plus
it also depends on what is the kind of
output which is expected and based on
that one which is a data scientist or a
developer would choose if he or she
would go with linear regression or
logistic regression decision tree or
anything else when you talk about
unsupervised learning now this is where
your data is still fed to the algorithm
but here our data does not have a label
or a response now how does the algorithm
work in that way so algorithm would look
at the features now for example if you
look at the image we might say feature
would be color of the element or the
size of the element or basically the
shape of the element or anything else
which can categorize or help us in
identifying the object so your
unsupervised learning based algorithms
would learn the patterns in the data and
based on that you would have your
trained model which could then classify
your group your objects into specific
groups which have similar kind of
characteristics now again for your
unsupervised learning that can be
classified into clustering and
Association rules so you have various
again techniques and models here such as
k-means clustering quite popular one you
have hierarchical clustering you have
DBS scan you have principal component
analysis gaussian mixture and hidden
Markov process if you talk about
reinforcement learning so in
reinforcement learning it basically has
to interpret the shape now when we talk
about reinforcement learning as I said
an agent is provided a reward to
identify a particular pattern then you
could have your trained model which
basically would identify the element
based on the shape or any other pattern
now for your reinforcement learning the
proper popular algorithms or techniques
are your Q learning temporal learning
and your general adverse real networks
now when you talk about spark ml lip
tools spark MLF component provides
different tools so when you talk about
your ml algorithms you have your
classification regression clustering and
collaborative filtering you also have
for featurization that is your feature
extraction transformation dimensionality
reduction and selection for your
pipelines you have tools for
constructing and evaluating tuning or
tuning your ml pipelines for persistence
you have saving and loading algorithms
models and pipelines and then you have
different utilities such as linear
algebra statistics data handling and so
on so when we talk about data types so
your spark mlib supports different data
types so it supports local vectors and
matrices stored on a single machine as
well as distributed matrices now for
your spark mlib data types as I said it
supports your local vectors and matrices
so it supports many data types your
machine learning library now you have
local vectors and matrices which can be
stored on a single machine or you could
have your distributed matrices which are
packed by one or more rdds so your local
vectors and local matrices are simple
data models they can be serving as
public interfaces now you have certain
tools like breeze which offers the
underlying linear algebra operations a
training example which we use in
supervised learning is what we call a
labeled point in mlib now when you talk
about your data types your categories
could be local Vector it could be
labeled point it could be local Matrix
and it could be distributed Matrix and
then you have other criteria such as row
Matrix index row Matrix coordinate
Matrix and block Matrix so when you talk
about your data types now on the left we
look at local vectors where we are
seeing a vector with certain values you
could have different formats supported
here that is dense format or sparse
format so if you would want to
understand about Vector data types let's
see this so in your dense Vector data
types a vector which is backed by a
double array representing its entry
values known as dense Vector so here we
are looking at a double array
representation now when you talk about
your sparse format this is a vector
which is backed by two parallel arrays
or two parallel array like elements so
you have indices and values which are
shown here in sparse Vector now we can
we could represent the vector such as
seen on the first line 1.0 0.0 and 3.0
in a dense format as a list of elements
or in a sparse format where we give the
size of it by specifying 3 and then we
give our elements that is we are giving
here 0 comma 2 and your 1.0 and 3.0 so
here 3 is the size of the vector vector
being the Base Class of your local
vectors and it provides two
implementations such as your dense or
sparse Vector now we can basically
create uh these dense vectors using
Sparks MLM package that is linear
algebra which then supports your vector
and your dense vectors for both the
formats we would have to import also
some packages like scalar.colection
immutable vector or mlab.linear algebra
dot Vector we'll talk about that later
again in detail when you talk about your
labeled Point data types whether you are
talking about dense or sparse which is
associated with a label or a response so
a label point is a local Vector which
could be of any of these types such as
dents and sparse which is associated
with a label or a response so basically
when we talk about your supervised
learning algorithms they use labeled
points right because supervised learning
algorithms depend on labels now here we
use a double to store a label therefore
we can use label points in both
regression as well as classification now
a label could either be 0 that is
negative or 1 which is positive for
binary classification but if you have
multi-class classification labels should
be class indices starting from 0 such as
0 1 2 and a label point is represented
by your case class called labeled point
now you have other data types also other
than your local vector and label point
so you basically have local Matrix now
this has an integer type row and column
indices and double type values that is
stored in a single machine now here when
we talk about your ml lab mlib supports
dense matrices in which entry values are
stored in a single double array in
columns as we see here with the major
order now when you talk about non-zero
entry values they are stored in
compressed sparse column format now if
we talk about an example let's look at
this Matrix what we are seeing here
which has 1.0 2.0 3.0 4.05 and 6. now
your one dimensional array is
represented in the form of Matrix which
has a size of 3 into 2. here Matrix or
Matrix is the base class of local Matrix
it provides again two implementations
you can have a dense Matrix and sparse
Matrix and to create local matrices we
can use different Factory methods
implemented in matrices now when you
talk about your distributed Matrix that
has a long typed row and column adhesis
and double type values so this is when
you would have your distributed Matrix
stored distributively in one or more
rdds this is actually very important to
choose the right format to store large
and distributed matrices so convert
converting a distributed Matrix to a
different format can lead or can need a
global Shuffle which is quite expensive
so there are four types of distributed
matrices so you have row Matrix in spark
mlib which is a row oriented distributed
Matrix without having any meaningful row
indices you can say it is mainly
dependent on rdd of its rows where each
row is like a local Vector when you talk
about something like indexed row Matrix
the difference with if you compare your
index row Matrix with just your row
Matrix is that you have some row indices
here so index row Matrix is backed by an
rdd of indexed rows in comparison to row
Matrix which is rdd of rows now here the
index is long typed and a local Vector
represents its every row you could also
have a coordinate Matrix which is backed
by rdd of its entries so we can say each
entry is a tuple here of you can say I
as long J is long and value is double so
it's a row index where you could have a
column index and the value so these are
your different types when it comes to
your distributed Matrix you also have
something called as block Matrix which
we did not see here but when you say
blocked Matrix it is basically RTD of
Matrix blocks now to understand Matrix
block it is a tuple of int comma int
comma Matrix so to understand these
different data types we can look at some
examples and then it would be more clear
in understanding different data types
which your MLF supports when we talk
about your ml lip basic statistics now
just looking at an example here ml lab
provides summary statistics for rdd that
is basically a vector through the
function call stats available in
statistics packages so we could be using
say Pi spark to work on on ML lip so you
have Pi spark dot mlib dot stat and you
could import statistics you could have
your spark context initialized you could
have your rdd of vectors and then you
could compute column summary statistics
using your call stats on your rdd so
here we say summary equal statistics dot
call stats on mat and then we could
print the mean variance or num of
non-zero so call Stat Returns the column
wise Max minimum mean variance number of
non-zero values and the total count now
this is just a simple example of using
your ml lib and the statistics package
if you look further and if we look at
this example where we say mlib can
perform correlation between two series
of data again using your statistics
package now in this example we see we
are using the pi spark ml lip Style at
where we import the statistics package
we would Define our spark context we
would then have our series now when we
say series X and series y we are talking
about two series on which we would want
to perform correlation so you have a
series and the other series must have
the same number of partitions and
cardinality as your series X now you
could be Computing the correlation using
Pearson's method you could enter spare
man for spearman's method and if a
method is not specified Pearson's method
will be used by default so here we are
saying print statistics dot correlation
that is c o r r on these two series and
the method which we specify is person
then we have data that's an rdd of
vectors So based on the type of input if
there are two rdds which are of double
type or an rdd of a vector type the
output would be a double or a
correlation Matrix so this example just
says that you could calculate the
correlation Matrix using Pearson's
method and you could also be using
spearmint for using your spareman method
when we say print statistics correlation
I could be saying I would want to work
on a data which is a double rdd or an
rdd of vector and then I could be
specifying My Method this is just a
simple example of using spark ml lib
statistics basic package now when you
talk about simplifying methods you have
sample by key and Sample by key exact
that can be performed on rdds of key
value pairs or rdds which have been
converted as key value pairs so your
sample by key exact is not currently
supported in Python but in future the
support might be added now this sample
by key method or function will flip a
coin to decide whether an observation
will be sampled or not you specify your
spark text you specify the data that is
an rdd of any key value pairs you give
fractions that is specified the exact
fraction desired from each key as a
dictionary and then we use sample by key
method saying data dot sample by key
false and the fraction so this is again
one example and we can look for these
examples when we are looking into the
demo of your ml app if you talk about
your random data generation then your
random data generation is used for
randomized algorithms prototyping and
also performance testing so if you would
want to generate a random double rdd
whose values follow the standard normal
distribution of 0 comma 1 and then map
it to a distribution of 1 comma 4 we
could be using the random package here
so we say from PI spark dot random
import random rdts you create your spark
context now our aim would be to generate
a random term double RTD that contains 1
million IID values drawn from the
standard normal distribution evenly
distributed in 10 partitions so what we
could do here is we could have your
random rdds dot uniform RTD and here I
specify my spark context I give range
and then basically I say the number of
partitions so if you would want to apply
a transform transformation to get a
random double rtds following the
distribution of 1 comma 4 we could be
using U which is random rdt's dot
uniform rdd you do a map and you use the
Lambda function to basically pass in the
function which you would want to apply
to get a double or a random double RTD
with normal distribution of 1 comma 4.
Now when you talk about machine learning
pipelines now that is basically
understanding your different stages and
that might include something like
estimator something which is evaluator
or you could also have your Transformer
so machine learning pipelines provide a
uniform set of high-level apis which is
built on top of data frames and it is
usually and mainly used with your
structured data or data which can be
structuralized so it is used to create
and tune practical machine learning
pipelines so as I said when you talk
about your pipelines it would have
basically your different stages so when
we talk about data frame or in the older
version of spark which was called as
schema rdds so a data frame from spark
SQL is used as a machine learning data
set it holds a variety of data types
such as text feature vectors and labels
now you also have something like a
Transformer algorithm which is used to
transform one data frame into another
data frame you have estimator which
gives you a model so an estimator is an
algorithm which can be a applied or fit
on a data frame to produce a Transformer
or to give you a model and then
basically you can have also an evaluator
which will evaluate the model which was
created now what when we talk about
pipeline overall pipeline integrates
your multiple Transformers and
estimators to specify a machine learning
workflow now when we talk about your
machine learning there are two important
pipeline components you have Transformer
which basically works on a data frame
transforms it to create one more data
frame when you talk about your estimator
you have a fit method which gives you a
model or you can say a Transformer which
can be used for your further data
processing now before we understand
about classification and regression in
mlib we can just understand a little bit
more on the classification and
regression and what does that mean
before we understand and what are the
different types for these two different
type of algorithms so when I talk about
classification and regression in ml lib
or in specifically machine learning and
statistics classification is a
supervised learning approach in which
your algorithm or computer program
learns from the data input given to it
and then uses this learning to classify
new observation now this data set May
Simply Be by class like identifying
whether the person is male or female or
that male is Spam or non-spam or it may
be a multi-class too so when you talk
about different classification problems
you can have use cases such as speech
recognition handwriting recognition
biometric identification document
classification and so on when we talk
about different types of classification
algorithms in machine learning then we
have your linear classifiers such as
logistic regression you have name base
classifier you have nearest neighbor you
have support Vector machines decision
trees boosted trees random forest and
neutral networks if we talk about
regression in machine learning then
regression models are used to predict a
continuous value so predicting prices of
a house given the features of house like
size price Etc or you could be having
different other examples so it's again a
supervised technique and when you talk
about types of regression you could have
simple linear regression you could have
decision tree regression random Forest
you have support Vector you have
isotonic you have gradient boosted and
polynomial regression now when you talk
about regression you could have your
linear regression or you would have your
logistic regression in case of your
logistic regression this is used in
different social and science
applications it is used when your
dependent variable or Target is
categorical now take an example if you
would want to predict an email is Spam
then it could have an option as one or
zero which basically means whether the
email is Spam or it's not or take an
example of checking if a tumor is
malignant and again that could have
binary values which is one or zero or
take an example of a content and you
would like to classify it whether that
content is basically a science based
content or in Social based content so in
this case you could be using logistic
regression now if we would have used
linear regression for a problem like
email a Spam or not there would be a
need for setting up a threshold based on
which classification can be done now if
actual class is melanin predicted
continuous value of 0.4 or threshold of
value 5 right your data point would be
classified as not melanin which could
lead to a serious consequence now
logistic regression can be very useful
in solving such problems if we talk
about your binomial logistic regression
it is also referred as simply logistic
regression where it can predict the
probability that an observation falls
into one of two categories of a
dichotomous dependent variable based on
one or more independent variables that
could be either continuous or
categorical now for this I would suggest
little bit of reading on your dependent
or independent variables looking at your
variate univariate multivariate
variables so that understanding on
logistic regression can be in depth now
when we look at the example of binomial
logistic regression where we basically
would want to work on a particular text
file so here we are using pi Square ml
classification and we are importing the
logistic regression package we would
want to load the training data and we
would say specify a variable training we
say
spark.read.format we basically give a
format and we load a text file now on
that what we would want to do is we want
to use the binomial logistic regression
so here I say LR logistic regression
wherein you specify the maximum number
of iterations the parameters which you
would want to pass an elastic net
parameters you would want to fit the
model so you say LR model and then you
would want to do a LR dot fit on the
training data set now you could print
the coefficients and intercepts for
logistic regression using print and
using string method Str and here you
would be working on model dot
coefficients we could also use
multinomial family for binary
classification as shown here you could
fit the model on the training data set
and finally print the coefficients and
intercepts for logistic regression with
multinomial family when we talk about
clustering in MLive then your ml lab
supports following clustering algorithms
such as your gaussian mixture latent
dirichlet allocation bisecting k-means
and k-means clustering so for k-means
clustering you could also be referring
to say one of the easy examples of
clustering wherein this is basically an
algorithm which allows you to Cluster
your data points based on some
similarity now if you look at this this
is just a visualization of k-means
algorithm where in a set of data points
you would select say random points and
then you would calculate the euclidean
distance or distance between different
points with this random point you would
then shift the centroid in a cluster of
points and again calculate the distance
and you would reiterate or iterate
through this for a specific number of
iterations till you can identify the
right center point for set of cluster
points which could be grouped together
so key means clustering is a very
efficient algorithm when you would want
to Cluster data points based on
particular criteria have a look at this
link for more details now here we also
have an example of using k-means
clustering that is you could be
importing packages or modules such as
numpy math then you could be from your
ml lib use clustering wherein you would
import k-means and k-means mode you
would load your file and then you could
be doing a map transformation where you
would work on the values or the data
coming in from this data.txt and you
could be performing a split based on
delimiter or space you would build the
model using k-means dot train method you
could evaluate clustering by Computing
within set sum of squared errors and
then you could save and load the model
now we can see a demo on this and then
we could see how it works when you would
create your applications use using spark
ml or ml lib and you could try and test
those applications in a Windows based
setup or on a spark cluster or even
where Spark works with yarn so let's
have a quick demo on using spark ml lib
to solve some of our problems and see
how spark ml can be used now here I'll
take an example of regression analysis
now to understand regression analysis or
regression line it would be good to
understand a little bit of Basics about
the equation of a straight line and then
we can see how regression analysis which
is a predictive modeling technique which
can be used to estimate the relationship
between a dependent variable and an
independent variable which Acts as a
predictor now to understand regression
analysis let's just have some quick
Basics so for example if you would have
a line say y equals MX plus C now this
is usually a form of line or you can say
usually the equation of line so a
straight line is represented in this
equation where you basically have M and
C as constants now let's see how would
that look like when you are basically
having different points and you would
like to have a line which can represent
these different points in a particular
graph so for this equation if you would
want to understand let's take a simple
example say I would say y equals 2 X
plus C now if this is an equation and if
we want to plot a line for this equation
we could consider say for example sample
we could take a table which could have X
and Y values so let's say X and Y and
here we can just put in some values for
X so for example I would start with
minus 3 minus 2 you can have minus 1 you
can have 0 and then you can have one and
two now if these are the values of X and
these values can be seen on this
particular place where we would want to
plot a line for this equation and
regression analysis relates to this and
that's why it would be good to
understand the basics of the equation of
line now here if your x value is minus 3
and if we submit if we substitute that
in this equation so we would get the
value of y so for example here it would
be wherein you would say let's say this
equation is y equals to X plus one let's
say this is the equation so if I had
value of x as minus 3 that would be 2
into 3 minus six plus one so that would
be minus 5 for the value of y now you
could similarly if x value was minus 2
then it would be minus 4 plus 1 that
becomes minus 3 and similarly you could
calculate so wherein you will get values
as 1 and then basically as 3 and as 4.
now if we would want to point these
values on the graph then we could say
say for example X you have minus 1 minus
2 minus 3 so if this is my X for minus 3
and then y I would go to minus 1 minus 2
minus 3 minus 4 and minus 5 so I could
say my y point would be somewhere here
right so that would be -3 being X and Y
being minus 5. now if we have X as minus
2 and Y is minus 3 then I could say I
would have my point here if I would say
X is minus 1 and Y is minus 1 so it
would be here so if we already see these
points are falling in a straight line
now if x is 0 and basically Y is 1 so
that would fall on the line itself so we
would put in here then basically we can
have x value as 1 and y value as 3 so
somewhere approximately here and then
you have the value of x value as 2 and
then basically y value is 4 which would
come somewhere here so if I would join
all these points sorry for the curve but
then this would be a straight line this
would be a straight line similarly we
could take a different equation if we
would want to see if this is a
coincidence that we are getting a
straight line for these points or is
there some kind of logic so if I say y
equals minus x minus 3 and if I take a
similar table where I would have the
value of x and Y and X we can start with
minus 4 minus 3 minus 2 minus 1 0 and
then one and if we calculate the values
of Y here so if x is minus 4 then it
becomes minus of minus 4 so that becomes
plus 4 and 4 minus 3 that gives me 1. so
if you have x value as minus 3 so it
becomes minus of minus 3 and then that
becomes plus 3 and minus 3 so this would
give me 0 and if we calculate further
for all these values we would get say
minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 n minus 4. so
this is the value is what we have got
for y and x and if we would want to plot
these values where X is minus 4 and Y
would be 1 so we could get our Point
here if x would be minus 3 and then y
would be 0 we would have a point here if
we have X as my minus 2 and Y is minus 1
so it would be here similarly X as minus
2 we have done and then we have minus 2
and minus 1 and then we could say for
example if x value was minus 1 y value
would be minus 2 and so on if x is 0 y
would be minus 3 so if we basically plot
a line joining these points
approximately it would give me a
straight line now here this is how your
equation of a straight line is following
a form of y equals m x plus C where your
C and M are constant and here we say m
is a gradient and I'll explain what is
gradient and your Y is an intercept and
your C is a constant now if we look at
these numbers and if we look at these
lines we can also see that whenever a
value of x is increased by i1 so
basically we have minus 3 and then you
increase the value of x by 1 so that is
minus 3 it goes to minus 2 so we would
see the value of y increases by 2.
similarly you increase the value of x to
1 so y value will increase by 2 and so
on so if we would want to look into the
graph so if the value of x was minus 3
and if we increase the value of x by 1
we would see the value of y would also
increase by 2. so where my X was minus 3
and my y was say minus Phi now when I
increase the value of x by 1 that is I
move towards the left towards the right
my y value would also increase by 2. if
you further increase the value of x by 1
you would again see the value of y value
increases by 2. and that we can see on
the light so this is basically the
equation of a straight line now if we
compare that with the second equation
even there we would see the same pattern
which would be followed so when you
increase the value or you decrease the
value of x by minus 1 you would see the
value of y would increase by y value
would also be decreasing right so here
if I say minus 4 has been increased by 1
so we would see the value of y is
decreasing by 1 and then you again
increase the value of x by 1 so you
would see the value of y is increasing
by 1. so if we understand these
equations then here we can see the value
2 what we see the value of y with
changes or basically if you're seeing
the value of y here so in first equation
whenever you increase the value of x by
1 it increase the value of y by 2 and
that is what we see here 2 in front of X
in the second equation we see that
whenever the value of x was increased by
1 your value of y was decreasing by 1
and that is what we see here so these
values which is 2 R minus 1 in this case
are the gradients now at a particular
time your one of the point falls on this
line of y axis and that is your
intercept so your y value is The
Intercept your m is the gradient and
your C is the constant now this is what
happens when we represent a line whether
the line goes in a positive direction or
in a negative Direction line is
expressed in this form which is y equals
MX plus C where M and C are constants
and if we look in graph we see if the
value of x is increased by one unit then
y value increases by 2 units so this is
how you can understand the equation of a
line which is represented in the form of
an equation now sometimes you might also
see that people would represent this
equation as y equals b0 plus B1 X and
that's also same as your y equals MX
plus C where your b0 is the constant
your B1 which is the gradient is the
slope of the line and we could basically
be representing this equation in any
form now we could have basically X and Y
plotted on a graph so if we had a small
graph we basically would want to find
out if the value of x and if the value
of y are related that is if you increase
the value of x does the value of y
increase if you increase the value of x
does your value of y decrease so this is
what we want to find out and then we
could basically get a line or a slope
here so you could either have a line
going upwards or you would have a line
going downwards so this is how you
understand the equation of a particular
line now when we talk about real-time
scenarios and when we talk about
regression analysis so if you have set
of points which you need to work upon if
you have set of points so basically
finding a line that connects all the
points possible is what you mean by
regression analysis so this line which
connects all the points or all the
possible points is called your
regression line now this is calculated
based on a least squares method and we
also need to minimize the estimated and
actual value so there are other points
which do not fall on these lines such as
this or such as this and these are
called your residual points let's take a
simple example to understand this so for
example example if I have x axis which
is the height of a father and y axis is
the sun's height now we would want to
find out if a change in Father's height
affects the sun's height so as we see
the values of Father's height plotted
over x-axis we could see or find out if
that would basically relate to a Sun's
height increasing or decreasing so that
could be represented in the form of your
y equals MX plus C now if both of them
increase that is as the value of I X X
is seen increasing you see the value of
y also increases then that's a positive
relationship if the value of X increases
but y decreases while X is increasing
now that is a negative relationship
which would see a line going downwards
so your regression line or your
regression analysis is about finding the
relationship between been dependent and
independent variables so let's look at
this one now when you talk about your
regression analysis it's a predictive
modeling technique it estimates the
relationship between a dependent
variable that is in our case we were
saying whatever is on x-axis and in an
independent variable which is on the
y-axis so X variable can increase its
value as much as it wants so far an
arbitrary value of x we are predicting
value of y now prediction is done using
regression so when you talk about linear
regression we would basically want to
find out a line that can basically
connect all the points also find out the
points which would be your residual
points that is the points which are
close to your regression line whether
your line goes upwards or it goes
downwards so your regression analysis is
a supervised learning based powerful
modeling technique and it is basically
used for predicting the unknown value of
a dependent variable from the known
value of an independent variable now to
look at a use case what we can do is we
can look at a data set here and we can
further do we can use spark ml lib to
see an example on that now if we look at
a data set here on my machine which I
have also uploaded in the git link so
here you can look into this location
where I have a sample data set which is
called e-commerce customers and if we
would want to look into this data set
which is in a CSV format let's look into
this data set and we can probably just
look at some of the entries here so we
can say head my B minus 5 so this is the
data set which I have and it is in a CSV
format where we see Fields like email
address Avatar average session length
time on app time on website length of
membership yearly amounts and spent and
then we have values for these now this
is a CSV file now if we would want to
find out what is the impact of yearly
amount spent based on your fields we
would have to work on this data set now
here we have some Fields like email
address Avatar and they would not have
any kind of impact on yearly amount
spent so those fields are not required
but then we have other set of fields
which is basically your average session
length time on app time on website
length of membership and these fields
are very important so we could say your
average session length time on app time
on website length of membership all
these are your independent variables
your yearly amount spent is the
dependent variable now how do we do a
regression analysis if we would want to
work on this so the first thing what we
will have to do is now as I explained
earlier you have spark ml lib has
basically a spark MLive basically has
set of libraries and functions which can
be used for your machine learning
algorithms so first let's go to spark
that is start spark and then import some
packages now here in my machine if we
look in here we have my Spar quality
setup so let me see this so here if you
see I have a master and a worker running
and if I look at my second machine I
have a worker running so I have a spark
Standalone cluster which has two worker
nodes and one master which we can also
see from the UI now to test an
application first you can do the
interactive way and if that works and
everything is fine you can even build an
application using an IDE need like
eclipse or IntelliJ so here I see I have
two worker nodes I have my spark
Standalone cluster running so let's come
in here and let's go back to this
machine well my spark is already running
so I can just say spark shell now there
are other settings also which makes my
spark works with the Standalone but
that's not the point here we are
discussing so we would like to do a
regression analysis on this data set
which has information about fields which
can basically affect the dependent
variable which is yearly amount spent as
I was showing we have uh average session
length time on app time on website and
length of membership which are the
independent variables so how do we work
on this problem so first thing is let's
import some packages which has these
classes which will be used so I will
import one of these one by one all of
these packages so import where we have
your org Apache spark and that gives me
a error here because I had a typo so
this is fine so I import the package
which is going for ML evaluation
regression evaluator similarly I'll go
for linear regression that's what we
want to do here then let's import some
more packages and we will go for log 4J
also this would be good if you are
building an application using an IDE but
we can just import the packages then we
have a feature Transformer which is
Vector assembler I'll show you the link
where you can read more about it and
then we have vectors because when you
talk about machine learning it would
like to take the data as input in the
form of vectors so these are some of the
packages which we have imported now what
we need to do is we need to get that
data set which we can create a data
frame from so here the path for my data
set is this one so this is the data set
I am interested in so let me take this
one which is e-commerce customers.csv
let's come here and what we want to do
is we want to just paste it here I will
use it and what we can do is we can
basically create a data frame out of it
using the statement let's copy this and
here let's go into our spark shell now
what I'll do is I have imported the
relevant packages so I will say this is
my file so I'll say file colon slash
slash slash home hdu and that's the path
where I have my CSV file which I just
showed you so what we are doing is we
are doing a spark.read DOT option we are
using header as true because we want the
first row of that data set to be
considered as the headings we have
option as in for schema we say format as
CSV and then we are loading the file now
this should basically create a data
frame out of this file which we can
easily use to work on the regression
problem what we have here so let's just
wait till it creates a data frame we can
always assign that data frame to a
different variable so let's do that by
doing this so we know we have created a
data frame here it shows me in the last
line or Apache spark SQL data frame so
now I will assign this data to
e-commerce data frame you can always do
a Ecom DF dot show to see what does your
data frame contain and it shows me the
values which we had in CSV are now
transformed and existing in the form of
a data frame where we have Fields such
as average session length time on app
time on website and length of membership
which are basically your independent
variables and you have yearly amount
spent which is dependent variable now
what do we do with this so basically now
we would want to look at the schema of
this data frame to understand the data
types and we can do that by just doing a
print schema which tells me what are the
fields what are their types which are
assigned to them so spark has inferred
the data type based on the values now
what we can do is we can filter The
Columns here especially the columns such
as your yearly amount spent so that we
would want to project as label right so
when you talk about supervised learning
you would have always data which would
have a label or a response so your
yearly amount spent would be a response
or a label and your other fields would
be more or less like features so let's
get this and here we can just do this
which says well Ecom so I'm creating a
new data frame df1 I'm taking DF which
has been created earlier Ecom DF I'm
doing a select and I'm saying this
yearly amount spent which was the last
column would be the label and then you
have your other fields which is your
average session then time on app time on
website and length of membership so I'm
selecting all this data here and I'm
creating a new data frame out of it so
that's also done you can anytime do a
Ecom df1 dot so to see what is happening
in this data frame now one point as I
said your machine learning expects data
in a n dimensional vector format that is
a matrix format it does not line the
data in an array or a list or something
although Vector is also like a list
which is vertically arranged so if you
would want to read more about your ml
features or a feature Transformer like
vector assembler then you can basically
refer to this link which I have given
here and if you just go to your browser
and just search for this you should be
able to reach to the spark documentation
which shows about Vector assembler now
what is that it's a Transformer that
combines in given list of columns into a
single Vector call column you see here
single Vector column it is useful for
combining raw features and features
generated by different feature
Transformers into a single feature
Vector so we have multiple Fields here
that is time on app time on website
length of membership and we would want
to convert those features into one
column and that's why we are using
Vector assembler which we have not used
so far but we would want to use it so we
created a new data frame now here if you
see I am using new Vector assembler
wherein I am providing the input columns
as the array that is average session
length time on app time on website
length of membership and then I am
saying set the output column as features
so let's copy this let's come here in my
spark cell and what I'll do is I will
use this Vector assembler and I will say
set input columns which will then have
these fields as features so earlier we
did yearly amount spent as label and now
we have this one which will be your
feature set so now we have the data
frame Ecom df1 we have also the
assembler which should have the values
in the form of a vector wherein The
Heading of that would be features now we
have done this let me just close this
window and now once we have used our
Vector assembler we can basically create
a new data frame based on assembler
which will transform your First Data
frame which had labels and then you are
also using the features so let's copy
this and I just want to avoid some time
in typing all this and I avoid any kind
of manual errors so here we are working
on this assembler which we created in
the first step and then we are doing a
transform using the first one and we are
selecting label and features all
together now so this is done it has
created a vector now if you would want
this is a vector if you would want and
you would do something like this it
shows me the label and it shows me the
features now all the features are in one
column which is basically the three
fields which we have combined together
now we have done so far we can do a show
now we can create an object of linear
regression so this is where we are then
moving towards machine learning where we
want to use the linear regression here
an algorithm which is already existing
we just need to use it so I'm creating
an object with this linear regression
then I can use the fit method on my data
frame that is what we created here which
is Ecom df2 so I'm using a new variable
called LR model I will use this object
of linear regression and then I'll use
the fit method so I'm doing this and
this basically is implementing the least
squares method as I said when you talk
about your regression which internally
uses the least squares so this is also
done now we have the model and basically
what we can do is we can extract
information such as coefficients and
intercepts Etc that is your gradient
coefficients and so on so we can just go
in here and we can try in this this
basically gives me the coefficients and
intercept which will make obviously more
meaning to the data scientists who are
looking for the coefficient values and
The Intercept values now further we can
also look at the summary based on this
model and we can do that by doing this
training summary we have the model right
which shows the linear regression
training summary that's what we have in
training summary and we can print out
how many iterations were done or the
total number of iterations which should
show me one and that's perfectly fine
and then I can also print the objective
history training summary into in the
form of a list so that's also done and
finally we can also list down our
residuals that is the points which are
not on the line which are far from the
line and one of the main things as a
part of linear regression is that you
would want to reduce the distance as
much as possible so this is list of my
residuals so this is a simple example of
using your linear regression where we
worked on a pretty much structured file
that is CSV and this will give us
information on your residuals your
gradients your coefficients and
basically if we had a plotting
integrated utility or software we could
have also seen this on a graph so this
is your linear regression and a simple
demo on usage of mlib further to this if
you would want to test or try this
application you can always refer to the
GitHub link where I have given the
sample data set the code and also some
more applications so you can look into
this path which is the git link with my
name here and here you can be looking
into Spark applications and setup you
can look into the spark MLM folder where
I have given you the sample data set
here which is e-commerce customers which
I was using for this demonstration of
using regression and linear regression
and you can also look into this linear
regression document which has the sample
code which we just now executed now for
the application which we ran from an
interactive shell obviously we can go to
the spark UI and here we can look for
our application if you would want to
look at the tag and what it did so here
is my application you can click on this
I can click on application detail UI and
which shows me that from the time we
loaded data into Data frame wherein we
created a data frame what was the stage
what was the job number we were doing a
load and it shows me what were the steps
in the dag you can go further and you
can look at all the show commands what
you did where you were trying to see
what is there in the data frame and even
towards the end where you have show or
you have counted linear regression or
some at linear regression Matrix so we
can always see these steps how many
stages did it take how many tasks were
running and basically dag which will
give you more information on what
happened on your application you can
always look at different stages you can
look at the storage if there was any
caching done you can look at environment
variables executors which were used for
this particular application and the
steps it had and we can also look at the
SQL tab which basically shows up when
you are using spark SQL and data frames
and we can look at the queries which
were completed always click on a
particular link and that can give you
more details on what was happening in
the background when you were executing a
particular query or using a statistical
model so this is how you can run your
linear regression using Spark ML and you
can build a model you can build a
machine learning algorithm which is
following a supervised way of
understanding from the data separating
the fields as features and labels and
finally helping us getting the slope of
the line getting the residuals and
basically also doing a linear regression
onset of data points which finally end
up in giving up a regression line let's
have a quick uh demo on logistic
regression and using spark ml lib to
solve a problem which is based on
logistic regression now for that let's
also briefly discuss on what is logistic
regression now this is a technique for
traditional statistics and also goes
well with machine learning mainly to
solve your classification problems now
here outcome that is the outcome
variable or result is binary it could be
one or zero it could be true or false it
could be yes or or no based on predictor
variable it's same as linear regression
but instead it predicts whether
something is true or false instead of
predicting something continuous like
what we saw in linear regression now
instead of fitting data into a straight
line it fits points into an s-shaped
logistic function or an s-shaped curved
now this s-shaped logistic function is
called your sigmoid function so you can
search for sigmoid function in Google
and that could give you more information
on how this function works now it also
depends on a threshold value which we
would set now below which we would
basically have a probability of say 0
and above which we would have a
probability of one so based on the
threshold value which is set we decide
the output from this sigmoid function so
logistic regression is usually used for
classification it can work with
continuous data or discrete data now
here we test if a variables effect on
the prediction is significantly
different than zero if not then variable
is not helping the prediction so
logistic regressions ability to provide
probabilities and classify new samples
using continuous and discrete
measurements makes it a popular machine
learning method now with linear
regression as we saw we fit the line for
data points using a least squares method
that is we find the line that minimizes
the sum of squares of these residuals
residuals are the points which are close
to the straight line which we plot now
logistic regression does not have
concept of residuals instead it uses
something called as maximum likelihood
wherein through iterations the curve
with the maximum likelihood is selected
so in case of logistic regression we
were seeing that when you have set of
data points you try to plot a graph or
try to plot a straight line which would
be to have all the data points or
maximum data points which would fall on
that particular line and that's how you
find out the slope in case of logistic
regression as I said we would want to
find out the probability of a result
either being yes or no or being true or
false so here the graph would look
something like this so it's a s-shaped
curve where you would also have a
threshold defined and Below which you
could say that it would be say 0 and
above which the data points would
classify as 1 or below which the data
points would classify as false and above
which they would classify as true so
that is the whole gist of your logistic
regression now how do we solve logistic
regression so ml lab also comes with
different packages which can be used so
here we will try to solve a problem
wherein the statement is you would want
to predict a customer if a customer
would be bankrupt or no now this is
probably for a bank which would want to
identify if the customer is about to be
bankrupt or no and if customer will be
able to pay back the loan how do we do
this so for this there is a data set
qualitative bankruptcy text let me let
me show you that so here I have the data
set let me come out of this and here we
can look at the data set which is in
this location and here I have
qualitative bankruptcy dot text this is
the location and if I look into this
data set it basically has some
qualitative values which we will have to
convert into quantitative so if you look
at these this is the data set I have
which has p e and n and a and b now we
want to work on this kind of data set to
basically classify the customer if the
customer is having more probability
towards bankruptcy or no how do we do
that so for that what we can do is first
we will start our spark when we will
import some packages which are more for
your logistic regression so here I will
start my spark shell now spark mlib
comes with different classes and
different libraries which help us in
solving these problems so it already has
these algorithms say linear regression
logistic regression and many more which
can be used so here what we will do is
first we will import the relevant
packages which are required for our
example so import now this is what we
have so spark ml lab so I'm missing in
something here and then we can get the
others also so there is a correction
here which we can I'll update in the kit
also so it should be ml lib then we will
get something else for the labeled
points and we will also get something
for vectors because when you talk about
machine learning it would expect the
data in the vector format for which a
linear regression we saw using a feature
Transformer such as Vector assembler so
these are the packages which we need now
if you see here I would want the data
which we have to be understood so the
data file has these different fields you
can say which are existing so P is for
positive e is for average n is negative
B is bankruptcy or NB is non-bankruptcy
so this is the schema of the data file
on which we have to work on so what we
would do is we would first transform
each qualitative data in the data set
into a double numeric value which we can
do using a function so here we are
defining a function called get double
value let's do that and this one will
basically be declaring some variables
and then we would be converting the
qualitative values into quantitative
values so that's the function so let's
copy this line by line and looks like
there was an error let me try it again
here so there was a error where there
was an extra bracket so I corrected that
so this is the function which will
basically convert the qualitative values
into quantitative values now once we
have this our function is ready what we
can do is further we would have to read
the data in memory now here I would be
using the older way that is the rdd's
way to work on our data set so I would
be using Val data SC dot text file and
then I'll point it to my file which is
qualitative bankruptcy so let's get that
file from here so let me open up a
different terminal and here the file is
in this particular location where we
have this qualitative data set so let's
take this is what we are interested in
so here I would say well and then I
would say basically data equals SC dot
text file so using the text file method
of spark context and here I would say
file home htu and that's my path of the
file so let's create an rdd of this
particular file now once we have an rdd
created we can always see how much data
we have here by just doing a data dot
count and it shows me there are 258 rows
which has these fields which we intend
to convert into quantitative values
using this function now once we are done
with that we need to prepare the data
for logistic regression algorithm so
basically what we will do is we will do
this we where I will say parsed data I
will do a map transformation on my data
wherein I want to split the data based
on comma and then I'm using the labeled
Point method wherein I'm using the
function which we defined which will
basically then convert this data and
convert the values into quantitative
values so let's do this which says
sparse data doing the map transformation
splitting the data based on comma as the
delimiter using your labeled Point
wherein I am using the function and then
basically I'm going to convert that into
a vector now once that is done it has
created an rdd which is based on ML lab
regression labeled point which we have
used here once that is done we can even
print the data to see what are the
values now which should show me that my
data which was with attributes like p a
etc has now been converted into the
quantitative values which we can use for
any kind of computation now once this is
done then you can split your data into
training and test data set which will be
used to train our algorithm so what we
will do is we would do splits wherein we
are converting this into a 60 and 40
percent so let's do this once that is
done I could then have my training data
which will be at index position 0 and I
will have my test data set which will
have at index position one once this is
done then we need to train the model so
how do we train the model now this is
where we use the logistic regression
algorithm with lb fgs we will take this
and we will apply this on our training
data now once this is done we have a
model which is based on logistic
regression which would work on our
training data which is 60 percent of our
data set now once this is done it has
basically given me a model logistic
regression based model now here I need
to evaluate the model on training
examples and compute the training error
so I can take this wherein I am working
on test data so that is being applied a
map transformation where we would want
to see if my model is working fine so
let's get this here and that's done fine
so our model looks fine now we can
basically get the training errors based
on this and once this is done you can
print your training error out of what
you have done in the previous step so
that gives me training error of
0.0.20 that is 20 percent is the error
now this is a simple example of logistic
regression where we are basically
reading data in memory we are preparing
the data to be used by logistic
regression algorithm we are then
splitting our data into training and
test we are training our model and then
we are evaluating our model on training
examples and Computing the training
error it so this easily shows how we can
use spark ml lib to basically work on
your problems such as linear regression
or logistic regression now since we have
run the application we can always come
back here and we can look at our
application which was launched using
spark shell we can look at application
detail UI which will show me what are
the different steps we did when we were
using spark ml lib and you can go into
any one of these jobs and see what it
has done you can look at the dag of the
steps which were executed which shows
how we picked up the file what kind of
Transformations we did and finally how
we got our resultant data now here this
is my spark UI if you would want to look
at the code and the sample data set you
can find on the GitHub Link in this
particular place where you have spark
mlib where I've given you the
documentation with the code I've also
given you the sample document which
sample data which can be used and a
notepad file which also has the code
wherein there is one correction in our
function which can be changed here we
will learn about what is spice Park what
are Pi spark features Pi spark with
python and Scala Pi spark contents Pi
Sparks sub packages companies using spy
spark and also we will see some demos
using pi spark so what is spice park now
it is in Python's API to support Apache
spark now all of you would have known
about Apache spark or would be knowing a
little bit about Apache spark as of now
that that is a in memory Computing
framework which basically gives you a
faster processing capability and it is
widely used in terms of real-time
processing or machine learning and then
there are various other use cases so
when we talk about Apache spark it
supports different programming languages
such as pythons Scala or anyone you
could be working on structured data
structures using spark SQL now we all
know that spark context is the entry
point to any spark functionality so
we'll see that now here when we talk
about Pi spark it is basically a way of
using python or for people who are more
comfortable with Python programming
language to use Python and work with
Apache spark and that's what you have as
a component from spark called Pi spark
now here just to show you I have two
machines now I have already set up a
spark Standalone cluster on these two
machines so if you see here I have given
a start all command and this has
basically started by spark master and
two worker nodes so we can check this by
just doing a JPS on this machine and if
I go to my second machine and if I do a
JPS to see the Java related processes I
see two worker us in a master node
running so my spark as a standalone
cluster is running now we can always
check this using the spark UI if I go to
my browser and then if I just do HTTP
slash slash and then if I say um1 and
8080 so that shows me my spark cluster
which has two worker nodes it shows
their address and all these details now
if we come back to the terminal and if I
look in binaries so I see a lot of spark
related programs like you have spark
shell if you would be interactively
working using Scala and you would want
to work with spark you can use spark R
if this has been set up and you can use
your R programming language knowledge
you can be using spark SQL to work with
structured data you can use spy spark
which is Python's API allowing users to
use Python to work with spark and
obviously you also have spark Summit now
the other way would be that if your
machine has python installed you could
write your applications in a python file
that is a file with an extension of Dot
py and then you could be using that so
here if I would want to work with pi
spark I can just say bin by spark and
that should start my interactive shell
in Python and then basically I can be
using my Python's language now here if
you see it's a spark session is
available as spark and then by default
when you start your spark shell or
basically Pi spark it would have spark
context which is the entry point of your
application available so that you could
do your processing now there are
different ways of doing it for example
if I would just say x SC dot text file
Now text file is basically a method of
spark context and as I said when we use
in attractive way of working with spark
such as using pi spark or spark shell
then we have spark context and Spark
session automatically getting
initialized if we are building our own
application using an IDE for example in
case of python using a pycharm or you
writing your code in dot py files then
in that case you would have to
initialize the spark context now here I
could be pointing to a particular file
which could be coming in from my machine
so for example I could do this home
slash sdu
slash sample files slash let's take a
file which I think should be existing
here in this location and this file and
this directory would be existing on all
your worker nodes so if I just do this
we know that this since we are using
spark context which is an entry point it
would have created an rdd now rdds are
the building blocks of spark you might
have learned about that through the
previous tutorials now if I just say
what is X it shows me it is a map
partitions rdb which has got created
because we used a spark context now if
we do further Transformations on this
rdt it will further create multiple rtds
so we'll see that but this was a quick
look at you using your Pi spark now we
have not seen the complete execution but
if I go here if I say refresh my UI it
tells me that there is an application
running so we have started the pi spark
shell which is using all the cores of
the machine it is basically using 1GB
memory and then we have an application
which was started because we started Pi
spark shell now I'm clicking on this I
can go to application detail UI and as
of now I have not done any execution in
terms of spark until and unless you
invoke an action everything would be
lazily evaluated so we don't see
anything here but we do see that Pi
spark shell has started an application
that application is using some resources
and basically as we do further
processing we will see the application
related tag getting built up now when we
talk about Pi spark as I said it's
Python's API now if we look further into
Pi spark features it basically as I said
when you work with spark it is a
in-memory cluster Computing framework
which is polyglot which basically
supports different programming languages
such as you could be doing things with
the Scala you could be doing things with
python you could be working with r or
you could also be using spark SQL when
we talk about other features spark also
allows you to do faster processing it
allows you to do real-time analysis and
there are also features where you can be
caching in your computation that is the
intermittent computation so you could be
caching in and you could also have disk
persistence so those are the features of
your spark and when you work with python
you will be able to leverage all Sparks
features now when we talk about spark
with python and Scala and if we do a
quick comparison if we talk about
performance then python is slower than
Scala when used with spark however when
you talk about spark since it is written
in Scala it integrates well and it is
faster than python now learning curve
obviously we know that both of these
languages support concise code and
python is very rich with the amount of
libraries which are available community
support and so on but python has simple
syntax and being a high level language
it's easy to learn Scala has a little
bit of complex syntax since it is newer
in comparison to Pi python but then it
also allows you to write concise code
and sometimes it might be for the new
programmers learning Scala might not be
so easy in comparison to python when we
talk about code readability so in case
of python readability maintenance and
familiarity of code is better in Python
API now Scala is a sophisticated
language developers have to pay a lot of
attention towards the readability of
code and if we talk about data science
libraries as I already mentioned python
provides a rich set of libraries for
data visualization and model building
now Scala lacks in providing data
science libraries and tools for data
visualization there is a lot of work
happening when it comes to data science
and machine learning with spark
different components such as mlib and ml
which allows you to work with data
science kind of projects however python
would be more advanced in that case now
when we talk about by spark contents so
these are a quick list of Pi spark
content so you have a spark conf now
that is basically how we Define our
configuration so we would be creating a
configuration object using Sparks spark
conf class spark context is basically
the entry point of your application
which will basically take your
application to the cluster manager
whether that is yarn or it is spark
master in case of spark Standalone or
even local now we have spark files now
that allows you to read files from a
file system whether that's a local file
system or a distributed file system you
have rdd these are the building blocks
of spark that is anything you do
starting from using a spark context or
spark session till you invoke an action
that is anytime you use a method of
spark context or spark session you do
some transformation you are always
creating an rdt that's a resilient
distributed data set and memory and that
is in one way a logical step which is
part of a dag that is direct a cyclic
graph which gets executed when you
invoke an action now you also have
Storage level and different classes
within that which allows you persistence
you can be using Sparks higher apis such
as data frame or data sets and then you
also have ways where you can be
efficiently doing wider Transformations
or wider operations using broadcaster
and accumulators now when we talk about
spark conf spark conf provides
configurations to run a spark
application now we will see that further
when we build our applications using pi
spark now if we look at the code block
of sparkconf class which is used so that
would show you class spicebar dot spark
conf and that has load defaults it has
for jvm and J configuration which can be
passed now if if you look further these
are some of the most commonly used
attributes of sparkconf so you have
something called a set key and value to
set a configuration property and this is
where we can be passing in our
configuration properties and passing in
values we can basically say how many
executors we would want for our
application we can say how much memory
per executor or course per executor and
many other properties which can be set
in the form of key value now you can
also be saying set master and then pass
in a value now that will take your
Master's URL you can set an app name
which is basically value to set an
application name and you can do a get
key and default value to get a
configuration value of a particular key
now there are various other options
which you can use with your Pi spark dot
sparkconf so if we look into spark
context now as I said when we look or
when we understand spark architecture
which you would have learned from
previous tutorials or of some of your
ways of self-learning that's spark
basically has or whenever you build
applications to work with spark as a
processing framework your applications
would have a driver program and driver
program basically has a spark context
now spark context is the main entry
point in any spark program so if we look
at the data flow so in terms of local we
are talking about spark context which
basically allows you to talk to local
file system and then you basically have
something called as Pi 4J so when you
run any spark application a driver
program starts which has the main
function and it has your spark context
which gets initiated now the driver
program then runs the operations inside
the executor so what are executors these
are jvm processes now spark context uses
Pi 4J to launch a jvm and creates a Java
spark context by default your buy spark
has a spark context available which I
just now showed on the machine and
that's your SC so creating a new spark
context would not be required if you are
working in an interactive way but if you
are developing your application using an
IDE or basically in a file then you
would have to initialize your spark
context now if we look here so we see
that spark context has some kind of
socket connection with spark Pi 4J
implementation that's the jvm and then
you could be having a cluster underlying
which has multiple worker nodes wherein
on those worker nodes you would have
executed processes which will take care
of your execution now if we look at this
code we see that this is an
implementation of Pi spark class and the
parameters per context can take so we
can be passing in values for all these
parameters such as Master app name spark
home Pi files and so on so Master now
this is where you will say the URL of
the cluster it connects to right so we
would be interested in using python to
work with spark and Spark would be
either as a standalone cluster or that
would be integrated with Hadoop or
Apache mesos and so on so your master
will point the URL of the cluster app
name is basically your application name
spark home basically says where your
smart related jars or config files or
what's your spark installation directory
Pi files basically tells the dot zip or
dot py files to send to the cluster and
add to the python path so this is where
you would specify what are the python
files wherein you have written the code
which needs to be added to the class
path you have a parameter environment
wherein you would specify worker node
environment variables such as your jvm
or your memory and cores which need to
be used you have something called as
batch size so this is number of python
objects represented as a single Java
object now it is set 1 to disable
batching 0 to automatically choose the
batch size based on object sizes or
minus 1 to use the unlimited batch size
then you can also be specifying
serializer and this is the serializer
which will be used so RTD serializer now
here we can be specifying say for
example pickle serializer so by default
we know that when we work with spark and
we work with rdds spark internally uses
either a Cairo serializer or Java
serializer you have something called as
conf now this is an object of your spark
conf to set all your spark properties
right so this is where we are creating a
configuration object we have something
called as Gateway now we can use an
existing Gateway and jvm otherwise
initialize a new jvm you have Java spark
context instance that is JSC and you
have profile now this is a class of
custom profiler used to do profiling and
for example we can pass in pi Spar dot
profiler.batch profiler so in all these
above parameters master and app name are
mainly used now we could basically write
a particular code and I'll show that in
further slides wherein we can just say
from PI spark Imports per context and
then we can be specifying parameters
which go into the spark context if we go
further we can see how that looks so
spark files now what is this used for so
you have spark files which allows you to
upload your files using methods of spark
context such as ADD file and you can
even get the path on a worker node using
sparkfiles.get so this is just a simple
example which we can use so you have
these class methods one is get so you
can get the file name and you can even
say get root directory if you would want
to look at the path so this is a simple
example now get root directory function
here or method here specifies the path
to the root directory which basically
contains the file that is added through
your add file method so if I would be
writing the code in a file and not doing
it interactively I could be doing from
PI spark import spark context from PI
spark import spark file so if we are
doing it from the interactive way we
don't need to really use spark context
we can just import spark files and that
should be enough then here I am saying
find distance and I'm specifying a path
to a file then basically I am saying
find distance name and then I am
pointing to this file here I am creating
my spark context or I'm initializing my
spark context by passing in parameters
such as what would be my master and I'm
saying local what will be my app name
and I'm saying spark file app and then
I'm using a add file method where I'm
passing in this fine distance where we
have created a variable to point to a
file finally I am doing a print absolute
path and I can also say
sparkfiles.get to get the root directory
for this particular file so we can be
just doing this in a simple way and I'll
show you some examples here so when we
talk about your Pi spark rdd now rdd is
the building block of spark so you have
resilient distributed data set that is
basically the basic abstraction in spark
so anything you do in spark until you
would want to see the result starting
from using your SC dot method till
you're doing Transformations like map
flat map filter or any other
Transformations all that would be
creating a resilient distributed data
set and what is that it is basically a
logical data set when data is not
evaluated you are not doing any
transformation every step in your
application is ending up creating a rdt
and that rdd is basically a step in the
tag and this tag will get executed when
you invoke in action so it's an
immutable partitioned collection of
elements Now by default whenever an rdd
is created it will always have
partitions and we can always look at the
partitions we can see how many
partitions are there and the more number
of partitions you have the more number
of parallel tasks you will have so when
we talk about rdt there are mainly two
kind of operations so you have
Transformations so these are operations
such as map filter join Union and so on
which are performed on an rdd that
basically results in a new RTD now how
is the first rdd created on which you
could do a map or a filter or a join or
something else is by using a method of
spark context like I showed you example
in this session in the beginning action
is when you would want to see the result
so these are operations such as reduce
first count take and so on which
basically trigger the execution of dag
right from the beginning so this is a
simple example of creating a pi spark
rdd so here you are using
classpyspark.rdd and then you are saying
jrdd you can have your whatever name you
would want to give like context you can
be specifying your serializer which you
would want to use okay so if I would be
doing this in a file I would be writing
in code like this now this is just a
simple Pi spark program to return the
number of elements in the rdt so you are
creating a spark context you say SC dot
parallelism of SC dot parallelize is a
method to work on collection of elements
and here you have some words which are
being passed so this is just just like a
collection or a list you can say and
then you are doing accounts where you
take this rdd and you're just doing an
action on it now that would give you the
result and finally you are printing it
out let's just have a look at some
examples where we can use spice Park and
in an interactive way so let me go to my
console here and what I can do is for
example I can be referring to a file now
as I said with your spark your spark
context and Spark session both get
initialized so here we can use SC and
then with SC you have different methods
which can be used to work with your
spark now here we can be looking at
method like text file which basically
allows you to pick up a file so let's
say text file and then I can be pointing
it to a path so I can say home hdu
sample files now that's a directory in
my machine and that this directory
exists on both the worker nodes because
we are working on a spark Standalone
cluster and here for example I can pick
up people.txt so I know that there is a
file here in this path and let's also
give this in quotes So this would have
created a rdt if I just do X it shows me
that it has created a map partitions rdd
using a text file method now I can do
some more Transformations on it so for
example I can say y x dot map and map is
basically a transformation which I am
doing on an rdd which is already created
using a method of spark context so here
when I would want to do a map I would
have to pass in a function now in spark
and when you are using python you can be
using Lambda functions which is for
anonymous functions so I can say Lambda
and then I can say take every element
here and what do you want to do with
that so I can say n Dot Upper now that's
a inbuilt function which we can be using
and when I do this this one would again
create an rdd and here we see it has
created a python rdt and this rdd again
has not really done the evaluation now
unless and until we would want to look
at the result there is no evaluation
happening here so in the first one we
created an RTD using a file in second
one we applied a function using map now
I could do a filter I could just do a
simple y dot collect and that's
basically an action which you are
invoking which will let this dag get
executed and then I look at the content
of my file which has been converted into
an upper case this is one example now I
could also be say creating a list for
example let's create a list of strings
so let's say hello let's say world let's
say cool let's say winter okay and let's
say summer so I could be giving in some
words and this usually creates a list
right so I've created a list and I can
basically see what is this so it has
created a tuple and that's also fine so
basically now you have created a list or
a tuple and you would want to work on it
so it's a collection of elements now I
can basically say B and then I can use
again SC Dot and this time I would be
interested in using this method which is
parallelized which allows you to work on
collection of elements so I can just
pass in a here and if I look at B it has
basically created a parallel collection
rdd using the parallelize method of
spark context now we can be printing out
some values from here so for example I
could also be invoking an action so I
can say B dot count and this should give
me the count of elements in this
particular rdd so these are two
applications which I just ran starting
from creating a list passing it in
parallelize and then doing account or in
our previous example we read a file we
applied a map function and then
basically we did a collect so if I would
go back to my spark UI if I would do a
refresh now here it shows me the
application which is now running you can
look at application detail UI and that
shows me the two jobs which have run
starting from the first rdd created till
the action was invoked so if we look at
this one so this one shows me the dag
and it shows me it started with a text
file and then basically you'd you did a
map so it also shows me how many tasks
which were run so this also means that
there were two partitions created for
this particular file and I can also be
looking at say different stages what
were there in my application which has
two jobs you can look at storage if
there was any caching done you can look
at the environment variables you can
look at how many executors were used for
this particular application and how much
memory was used for storage how much was
it for processing if there was any
shuffling happening and you can also
look at a spark SQL although we are not
using any spark SQL component here if I
look at the second one which shows me
four tasks so it started with
parallelize and then basically we
created a python RTD we finally ended up
with account and this tells me how many
tasks we had run so we can always go and
look at the number of partitions of a
particular rdd so whenever you would be
creating an RTD so for example we have B
here or in this case we have y here so
you can always do a y Dot and search for
different methods which are available
and then you can basically be checking
so for example simple if I would want to
look at the number of partitions what
was created for these why when I was
converting my text into uppercase and
then I can be just doing this and this
will tell me how many partitions were
created similarly if you would search
for B which was when we worked on a list
and if we would want to see so it shows
me the number of partitions for 4 and
that also tells me that based on the
number of partitions you are seeing the
number of tasks which were executed so
automatically based on your data size or
based on the number of cores which are
being used it has created partitions and
per partition you would have a task
running right so for example we had this
where we were creating a list and then
in B is what I was doing was I was doing
SC dot parallelize now what if I had
done something like this so if I would
have done something like this then my B
would have created two partitions right
and then if I do to a execution on B
like what we did for count so it still
gives me the count but now the
partitions were two so we can again see
how many tasks were run so if I go back
here and if I go to the jobs and then I
see one more job which was run and you
see it shows me two tasks so the same
job which was showing four tasks earlier
is showing now two tasks and that
basically means that the number of
partitions was changed and per partition
you will have a task running so this is
just a simple example of seeing how you
can be basically using pi spark now I
could also be taking this whole thing
and putting it in a file and then
executing it and I'll show that later so
when you talk about Storage level now
that's a very important concept and if
you have followed previous tutorials
where we would have spoken about Storage
level so basically this decides whether
the rdd should be stored in memory or
should it be stored on disk or both so
when we talk about your Storage level
now if we look into the package which
comes for spark it basically has Storage
level and you can always go to Google
and check more for this one so for
example I could basically be checking
this so for example if I would say
Storage level and just check this so
Storage level and then you can do a
spark and you see it says you have
different options memory and disk you
have memory only serialized memory and
the serialized disk only memory only so
there are different options here and
this one you can also search what
package it comes in for and then you can
see there should be a package which
talks about Storage level and that would
be for example let's see so here it says
org Apache spark dot storage dot Storage
level now this is a way parent you would
be importing a package in terms of Scala
when you're doing but then Storage level
as a class comes within your org Apache
spark storage Storage level and
similarly you would have your Storage
level for pi spark also wherein you have
to import the particular package in this
Storage level then has different options
like memory only disk only memory and
disk serialized and so on so here what
we can do is we can basically see what
is the usage of Storage level so in this
example if you see we are saying class
five spark dot Storage level now we
could be saying it should use disk or it
should use memory it should use off Heap
or should it be deserialized what should
be the replication so Storage level is
one way wherein you can have your rdd
which gets created at any step of your
application to be cached so that's
basically making your computation cast
or computation persisted so that if down
your application if you are using the
same step again on same series of Step
you will not have to have your complete
dag executed right from the beginning
but you could benefit from the cash or
persisted computed rdt now here we are
saying from PI spark Imports bar context
we are saying import by spark and here
we are creating a spark context that is
spark context local storage level then I
say I would want to do a SC dot
parallelize on these elements and then I
can basically say that this rdd which
gets created in this step needs to be
persisted using pi spark in Storage
level and then you can say memory and
disk with a replication of two now I
could then just be checking if my rdd
was persisted and I can check for the
get Storage level I could even print it
so this basically tells me that if I was
doing something on rdd1 for the first
time it would have cached my computation
or whatever we did in this step in one
of these options which comes as a part
of Storage level and if next time I
would be executing that series of Step
it would benefit from getting the data
from cash now here we have a quick
example of using Storage level and then
caching your rdd and we can then also
see how we can recognize if that is
coming from your UI the information can
be seen in UI and you can see if the
caching is really benefiting so for
example like what we did earlier we can
basically create a list and then I am
doing a b a c Dot parallelize and here
before we can use the spice bar we will
have to import the package so for
example I could be just doing this now I
could import the spice Park package here
which we will be using to use the
Storage level class now what we were
doing earlier is we were just doing a b
dot SC dot parallelize now that creates
an RDP and we can do that and here I am
doing a persist where I am saying that
SC dot parallelize which creates an rdd
that RTD or that stage of computation
should be persisted using pi spark
Storage level and I am specifying memory
only and as I said you can have
different options here like memory only
memory and disk only memory and disk
replicated so you can give different
options here with Storage level now we
could be straight away doing this where
we will be caching in this in memory now
once I have done this I can basically
just do a b dot count and when I do this
now this B dot count would have
triggered the execution of dag right
from B onwards so by basically this list
would have been created that's not part
of your dag here I am basically using SC
dot parallelize so this is where my
first RTD is created you are persisting
it and then you are doing account now if
I go back to my UI right now if I do a
refresh it basically shows me an
application which completed with two
tasks if we see here we see that there
was a parallel collection cached now
which we have done that and it shows the
duration is two seconds if I look at my
storage it shows me that the parallel
collection was 100 cached and the size
in memory is 175 bytes and then it says
how many partitions were cached and we
can look at the executors to just tell
me we had one for driver and then you
had two executors for two tasks each one
of them were running on two different
nodes they were using by default to
cores how much memory was used for
storage how much was used for execution
it tells how many tasks were run by each
executor and that gives me an overall
summary now if we basically run this
again now what will this benefit from we
will not again start with a c dot
parallelize because your that RTD is
already persisted in memory so I could
just be doing a b dot count where it
will get the persisted RDP from memory
and give me account so if we do this and
we go back here in my jobs it shows me
the second job look at the time
difference so this is two seconds and
this is 0.2 seconds and if we look at
this one it basically says the input is
175 bytes now that's what we know that
rdd was cached in memory and we are
benefiting from caching so this is a
simple example of using Storage level
where I could have written the whole
code in basically a file and done it now
as it says you can also do a get Storage
level so you know which rdd you have
persisted and basically you can if you
would want to check that so we have B
dot get and then I can do a tab which
shows me different options so we will
use Storage level to basically see what
was the Storage level and it basically
based on different storage levels it
gives me we when we used memory only it
shows the value as true so you can also
be looking at the storage level here you
can be printing out the Storage level if
you would be interested in doing that so
the same thing what I have B dot get
Storage level I could just wrap it using
a print to see what it shows here and
that shows me memory serialized with 1X
replicated that means it was not
replicated so I could be using storage
and then I could be using memory and
disk too so that's one more option which
you can do and then you can see how is
it cached where is it cash where is it
persisted right so that's an example of
your Storage level now when we talk
about Pi spark it also has something
called as data frames and we look at
that so when you're working with spark
Sparks basic or core API was rdd and
then there were higher level apis that
is data frames and data sets which were
introduced as experimental features in
spark 1.6 but then they became the main
apis which are extensively used these
days when you're working with structured
data and they were introduced from Spar
2 onwards now Pi spark or basically
using python you can also be working
with data frames and data frames is
basically a structured way of looking at
data or you could say if your data is
already structured it would be good to
inform about the structure and format to
the backend tax scheduler and then it
would be be more efficient in accessing
the data now when you talk about data
frames in pi spark data frame is
basically a distributed collection of
rows with named columns now that's what
you would have seen if you have worked
with Pythons pandas library or you also
have you can be using or creating data
frames using Scala as a programming
language so data frames is basically a
table of data with rows and columns now
when you talk about rdts we know that
they are immutable in nature by default
if you are working on a collection of
elements you could basically have
mutable or immutable structures created
but when you talk about rdds these are
immutable in nature you have basically
lazy evaluation so rdds are lazily
evaluated and they are distributed
across memory so when you talk about
creating data frames in spark you can be
creating using different data formats
you can be loading data from exist
testing rdd you can also be
programmatically specifying schema so
there are different ways in which you
can work with data frames so let me
quickly show you an example here now
when we go to our machine and Let's do
let's get to Pi spark so here I'll just
say bin slash Pi spark that brings my
pythons python prompt to basically allow
you to work with spark now as I said
your spark context gets initialized
automatically and when you use a method
of spark context you are moreover
working with rdds and if you would be
interested in working with structured
data then you would be using spark
session so for example what we can do is
we can say x equals and then I can just
say spark Dot and then I can check what
are the methods available here so you do
have a method which is called create
data frame now we would be interested in
reading a file which might be say Json
or a CSV file and then creating a data
frame out of it so we we can do that
using read and then I can again say what
are the methods which are available with
read so you have an option like format
which can be used or you can straight
away be using CSV or Json or text or orc
so I can say format and for now I will
select a Json file and what I would also
do is I would want to infer the schema
so I can basically use option and with
option I can say for example infer
schema and then I can say true what I
can also do is I can specify one more
option and I can say header if there is
a header then I can set it to true if
there is no header then basically it
will just look at your data and then we
can do a load where we would want to
point to a file so I'll say home slash
sdu sample files and here I have a file
people.json which does not have used
data we can take a look at bigger data
set also and here when I do this this
would have created or should create a
data frame so data frame where it infers
the schema where it understands the
first row as the header and it creates a
data frame and whenever you would want
to look at a data frame I could just do
a x dot show that shows me it is a data
frame which has got created now since we
are in Python we could do a type and
that shows me if this was a data frame
created you can straight away start
doing a select and here I could say for
example show me the age now at this
point of time if I do not do a show then
it just shows me that it is a data frame
and it has one field and that's of the
type big end so I could again do a show
and that shows me the result of data
free so you can be then doing multiple
other operations you can do a filter you
can basically do a group by you can do a
count so you can do all that and if you
have any doubt just do a tab and it will
show you what are the options for
example I'll say let me get age which is
greater than 19 and here you are working
on basically a string so you can do
these things but then you will have to
follow different syntax but if you see x
dot and then I can search what are the
different options which are available so
only the syntax has to be corrected but
then I have something called as x dot
filter and then basically I can be
specifying what I would be interested in
and then filter out the values okay now
this is basically a data frame so
similarly I can be also looking at a
bigger file for example let's say I have
a file called Bank underscore full one
dot CSV if I'm right and then we can
basically point this to format as being
CSV let's quickly check if we have this
file so let me open up a new terminal I
look into the sample files and I have a
bank underscore full Dot CSV so that's
the file I'm interested in and that's a
CSV file unless like last time we saw a
Json file and here we gave the path
which is wrong and that's why it was
giving me an error so let's go back here
and change this to the right path and
then basically it should create a data
frame out of this if I do a x dot so
that should show me the data frame and
by default when you look at your data
frame it shows me only the top 20 rows
and then you can start doing a select on
this you can filter the data you can do
a group by you can do operations you can
do functions on it and you can do
various ways in working with a data
frame so this is just a simple example
of using pi spark to create a data frame
and then you can start doing your other
operations on it now when it comes to
your broadcast and accumulator so
broadcast and accumulator so broadcast
variable allows the programmers to keep
a read-only variable asked on each
machine rather than shipping a copy of
it with tasks now why do we need this so
for example you are doing a bigger
operation such as join or Union on two
rdds or two data sets or two data frames
now in that case we know that whenever
we basically have a data frame created
or an rdd created it would have
partitions so for example we had this
here and I can do a x dot and check what
are the different ways in which I can be
looking at this so as I said by default
each rdd or data frame which gets
created that would have your partitions
now you could convert your X into say
nrdd if you would want to do it right
and then basically I could have done
this by saying y equals right and then
you can check at your Y what are the
different options like you have get num
partitions right so I could just do it
this one and I I could see how many
partitions are created so that was a big
file and it shows me there is only one
partition created right so based on the
partition you would have the number of
tasks now if you have multiple data
frames or data sets on which you would
want to do a join operation then the
point here is that if both are large and
if you would be doing a join based on a
particular column now in that case there
would be a lot of shuffling involved so
basically if you have your data in the
form of a pair rdd or if you have your
data frames where you would want to do
join on a particular column it would
have to shuffle the data for both the
data sets so data frames or rdds so that
it can be doing your operation now in
that case we can always use a broadcast
variable and in that what happens is
that the smaller data set or data frame
can be converted as a broadcast variable
and then this variable is shipped to the
memory of each machine which can then be
used to directly do your join or other
operations with the variable or with the
smaller set of data in memory with the
larger data set on that particular node
now that's where broadcast variables are
useful so for example you can be saying
dot broadcast so like what we were doing
earlier you can create a spark context
you can say broadcast and I would want
to broadcast this particular list as a
variable now you can always be looking
at the value of it okay now once this
broadcast variable is created we can
then be using this so for example B is
my broadcast variable and a could be a
huge list of elements and if I would
want to do a join or some other
operation between them then this B would
be shipped to the memory of every node
now what would have happened is on every
worker node the memory would have a
partition of your larger data set so
this a small variable or this broadcast
variable having less number of values
could be used to do a join operation
with each partition on each node now
that's the benefit of broadcast now when
you talk about accumulators these are
variables that are only added through an
associative and commutative operation so
for example if I would want to use
accumulator so here I would say SC dot
accumulator now I am defining a function
here so I'm specifying Global num and
then I would want to increment the value
of num based on X now here you create an
rdd so you say C dot parallelize on a
particular number and for each element
here you would want to apply this
particular function so basically this
function which takes X as a value and it
keeps adding all the values we are
applying this function to every element
in the list so once we start iterating
through the list 20 would get added to
Thirty third then the total would get
added to 40 and so on or you could say
other way that you will start with 20
and then 30 plus 20 and then 40 is added
to the sum 50 is added to the sum and
finally look at the value so when you
are talking about accumulators here so
we can basically looking at the
accumulator value here which would show
me 150 so you can try this out like what
I have shown other examples either this
one or the broadcast and basically you
will get a better idea of how broadcast
variables and how your accumulators work
so moving forward now that we have
looked at broadcasts and accumulators
let's also look at some sub packages in
pi Spar now as I said whether you work
with python or Scala or r or spark SQL
you have spark has different components
which allows you to handle different
kind of workloads handle different kind
of work packages and work on different
kind of data sets so when you work with
pi spark it has a component and for SQL
so you can also be using pi spark.sql
module and that basically allows you to
work with structured data like what we
were seeing an example of data frames
you could be using pi spark.streaming
module and that is if you are interested
in working on streaming kind of data
wherein you could be doing stream
processing if you would be interested in
building machine learning algorithms
then you can use
spysparks.ml package and also the ml lib
package so these are two different
packages one mainly for data frames and
one with other machine learning
algorithms so there are a lot of sub
packages in pi spark which you can use
and you can be appropriately using the
modules now there are different
companies which are using pi spark and I
would say all the companies which are
using Spar would be having their
applications either in Scala or written
in Python where they would be benefiting
from PI spark or spark shell and thus
working on structured data so you have
amplab now that's basically where Spark
started you have Mind Tree you have
Walmart Repro Tech Systems students cab
Gemini Alibaba and many more so there
are different other companies which are
using pi spark now to look at the demo
we can be looking at a particular data
set and then we can see how we can use
Pi Spar to analyze that particular data
now for our demo we will look at this
Walmart stock related data what we have
and this is basically saved in a CSV
format so as I showed earlier we can be
using the CSV format we can create a
data frame out of it and then we can
basically ask some questions to it so
for example if I would be interested in
working on this one so here if you see I
have imported finds bar and I have
initialized it and then from PI spark
I'm using the SQL module where I import
spark session and then I can be doing a
spark session Builder app name Walmart I
can just say get or create now you would
not be doing all these things if you
were working in an interactive way like
I was showing in our spark setup so you
could straight away start from here
where you are reading a file into a data
frame so you could be loading the data
now if that data is existing so here in
this step you are basically doing a
read.csv you are pointing into a file
wherever your data is stored and then
you say in for schema and you say header
true so that it knows the first row is
basically your headache now once you are
done with this now in certain cases if
you are using a notebook to do it or if
you would want to do it from your
command line right now in that case you
will have to make sure that if you are
doing it from the command line you will
have to get these packages so for
example what I can do is I can be going
into say in my case I have an account
installed and that's where I'm showing
you this notebook so what you can be
doing is go into your anaconda prompt if
Anaconda is installed or if you have
your python then you can just be doing a
pip install find spark you can be doing
a pip install Pi spark and it should get
your modules and then it also installs
Pi 4J which I was explaining earlier it
will basically set up all these packages
so Pi 4J and Pi spark shows you the
version and then you should be all set
so if you are using Anaconda which has
basically all these different ways of
working with your python so you have
Jupiter you have basically spider you
have Visual Studio code so if you would
want to use Anaconda then just install
Anaconda Navigator where you can use
notebook then you can also get to your
anaconda prompt and install the packages
and then you can start your jupyter
notebook so here you could be doing this
other way is you could be doing it from
your command line provided you have
installed these packages the Third Way
is you can be doing it from your spark
Standalone cluster and in that case you
don't have to do all this stuff you can
straight away start reading the CSV and
then start working on it so here we are
reading a Walmart file now this is what
we have open what was the open price
what was the high low and closing price
right shows me the date and it shows me
the volume so if you want to do some
analysis on it so you can create a data
frame out of it then you can be looking
at the columns what are part of those
data frames you could be just looking at
the first row of the data frame using
head and you can see the values you can
check the schema using a print schema
you can be printing in first five rows
so for line in the data frame dot head
and you are saying I would want to look
at first five rows and I would want to
print it in line by line now I can be
getting some general statistics out so I
can just be using a data frame start
describe now that is the method which
gives you just a summary right so when
you are looking at these values so it
gives you count and mean standard
deviation minimum Max so that's like
your final summary or your described
summary you could also be formatting
columns to just show two decimal places
so here I'm using from PI spark.sql
functions within the SQL package I'm
importing format number and what I'm
doing is I am doing a described look at
the stats and then for the same stats I
would be doing a select where I would be
interested in looking at this summary
and what I would want is all of these
columns which we were seeing here open
high low close volume all of these I
would want to just look at values with
two decibel points so I'm just
specifying from my data frame what is
the column name how do you want to cast
it as and basically giving the limit and
then I'm saying what would be this
called so you you could change the name
if you would wish to and here we have
reduced the information what we were
seeing here just to two decimal points
so this is a simple example where you
are doing some formatting now you can
create a new data frame with a column
called HV ratio that is ratio of high
price versus volume of stock and how do
you do that you use the with column
method so with column method now here we
are doing this now with column I could
also be passing a function if I have
created my user defined function so here
I am saying DF that's my data frame I
say with column what would be my column
call so that's your HV ratio now how do
you get that so out of your data frame
you take the high column divide that
with the volume right and then you would
basically do a select on this HV ratio
so what we are doing is we are not only
in this part creating a new column into
the data frame so my this data frame DF
underscore HV the new one will have this
particular column and what we are doing
is with this width column it would have
added HV ratio as a column in your data
frame and then I'm just doing a select
on that so here it shows me the H3 ratio
and the values so if you would want to
answer some more questions like which
day has the Peak High in price you can
do a order by so here you are again
working on your data frame you say DF
you would be interested in looking at
the high column you would want to sort
it in a descending way and then whatever
is the result you would want to
basically select the date and head value
for your first index position so you
could also be doing a mean of the close
column so here we are using import mean
and then we are applying the mean
function on the close value what is the
maximum and minimum value of volume
column so you could be doing this by
just doing import minimum and Max and
apply this on your volume column how
many days did the stock close lower than
60 dollars and you can be looking at at
60 and you can be doing a filter so what
percentage of time was high greater than
80 dollars again you are doing some
computation on the high column where
you're looking for the value which is
greater than 80 which is given in this
brackets and you are doing a filter what
is the Pearson correlation between high
and volume so you can just use the
correlation method here on high and
volume column and you can get the value
you can import correlation and you could
also be doing it in this way where you
could do a DF dot select use the
correlation method or you can say
function on high end volume and then
basically show the results if you would
want to find out what is the max High
per year now in this case you would be
importing some other packages like day
of month hour day of year you have month
year week of year and so on and then you
are using with column where you are
creating year and you are extracting the
year aspect from the the date and that
would become your ear column and then
what you're doing is using this here
column you're doing a group by and
finding out the max high value per year
so what is the average close for each
calendar month and basically you create
a month column using with column by
extracting the month out of this date
and then you do a group by month and do
a mean or order by month and then you
can do a average close so these are
different ways in which you can answer
questions on a particular data set using
pi spark and then obviously once you
have run this you can always go to the
spark UI and basically look at this so
this code will be available for you and
here you can always look at this which
basically gives me an idea of working
with your data frame using pi spark and
different modules and functions and
different packages which we are using to
extract useful information from a
particular data set so this is your Pi
spark let's have a quick look at some
spark interview questions which will
just prepare you with different aspects
of spark and its competence and can help
you when you're facing an interview now
here we have some generic spark
questions such as how is Apache spark
different from mapreduce now this is one
of the common questions which you might
be asked about you would have to answer
about differences between Apache spark
and mapreduce right now mapreduce is a
programming model and Apache spark is a
processing framework so when we talk
about spark you can basically say that
spark processes data in batch but then
it is also good for real-time processing
in fact it is one of the features of
spark that it is good with real time or
faster processing spark runs nearly 100
times faster than Hadoop map produce
well that actually depends on how your
spark application has been written and
in comparison to how your mapreduce
application has been written but then if
you would say spark application whether
that is written in Scala python your R
in any way if it has been well written
then spark can give you a performance
benefit it would be 100 times faster
than your traditional map reduce now
spark as I mentioned earlier does not
have its own storage so for processing
it would be picking up the data from say
an rdbms or from Hadoop distributed file
system or from a data warehouse package
such as Hive but then spark is known to
do a in memory processing now it stores
data in Ram in the form of rdds and that
is why it gives you a faster performance
now when you talk about map reduce map
produces slower due to the reason that
it has two phases mapping and reducing
wherein the intermittent result that is
the result of your map phase is
basically written to hdfs and then it is
picked up from sdfs for your further
reducing so mapreduce also processes the
data stored in hdfs but as I mentioned
while processing also the staging data
or the data which is result of map phase
and has to be picked up by reduce phase
is also stored in hdfs spark also has
features such as caching and in-memory
data storage so you can have your
computations that is the result of rdds
getting stored in cash now that could be
different ways so you can use a Storage
level and then you can specify whether
the caching is going to be in memory is
it going to be in disk or is it going to
be a combination of memory and disk but
those possibilities are there in spark
now mapreduce does not have this when
you have a feature of distributed cache
but that's not as efficient as spark so
Hadoop is highly disk dependent
now if somebody asks you what are the
important components of spark ecosystem
so spark basically has language support
for different programming languages such
as Java python Scala and even our
programming language and Spark has
different components for different use
cases and different kind of data so it
has a core API that is your spark core
engine you have spark SQL to process
your structured data you have spark
streaming which helps you in processing
streaming data mlib to create your
machine learning algorithms by using
different statistical methods and
algorithms which are available and
Graphics which is for your graph based
processing now when you talk about spark
it can be set up as a standalone cluster
that is having one master and multiple
worker nodes it can be integrated with
Apache mesos and then you also have yarn
with which your spark cluster can be
integrated so if you are describing
about important components of spark
ecosystem then you will mainly speak
about the mid layer that is the core
components you could also speak about
your language support and the cluster
Management Solutions which can be used
when you're working with spark explain
how spark runs applications with the
help of its architecture now when we
talk about spark application it runs
basically as independent processes or
basically you have application which
would be split into tasks and these
tasks would be running across your
different machines now you could have
basically spark session or your spark
context which are these important
classes or you can say the entry point
of your spark applications Every Spark
application would have a driver and what
does the driver have it basically knows
the flow of your application at the back
end you also have a dag scheduler so for
all the steps what you doing in your
application DAC scheduler is aware of
what are the different steps which make
your dag that is direct a cyclic graph
for your in memory processing now your
spark session or your spark context
which is your entry point of your
application interacts with the cluster
manager now in this case we can be
specifically speaking about yarn which
has resource manager as the master of
the cluster and node manager as the
slaves of the cluster so your spark
session or spark context speaks to
resource manager that is the cluster
manager which basically would request
resources from the worker nodes where
the execution would happen now worker
nodes would have a processing slave that
is node manager which grants the
approval of usage of resources to
resource manager now this request which
we are talking about that is requesting
resources is called container so
resource manager request containers from
one or multiple worker nodes worker
nodes or the node manager process
running on them grants these containers
and it is within these containers a
executor process is launched which is
responsible to take care of the
application related tasks so when you
talk about iterative algorithms they
apply operations repeatedly to the data
and they can benefit from caching data
sets across iteration so you can also
have the rdds which are created or the
computations which are done they could
be cached and this Cache can be
beneficial for your further run of the
similar tasks or similar computation now
what is a task here it is basically the
unit of work to the data which is coming
from the respective disk to basically
transform or work on it so when you talk
about execution which is taken care by
executors which could be either one or
multiple on a particular node now which
depends basically on the data on the
Node which depends on the resources
available on the load you could have
multiple executors the result is then
sent back to the driver and that's how
your application execution happens in
case of spark one of the common
questions which is asked is what are the
different cluster managers available in
Apache spark or how does spark work with
different setups so by default you can
have spark in a standalone mode this
basically means spark would be running
with one master and multiple worker
nodes with one master and multiple
worker processes across machines you
would not have any Hadoop setup or mess
Source or anything else so by default
here applications would be submitted to
the Standalone mode and they would run
in a fifo order that is first in first
out and each application would try to
use the resources on available worker
nodes spark can also be integrated with
Apache mesos and that's a open source
project to manage computer clusters and
can also run Hadoop applications in fact
Spark initially came into existence to
prove The credibility of Apache spark
and then later became a independent
project you have spark integration with
Hadoop yarn so that is where yarn is
taking care of resource allocation in a
Hadoop cluster and Spark leverages the
benefit of using yarn you could also
have spark working with in a kubernetes
environment now kubernetes is an open
source system for automating deployment
running your microservices scaling and
management of containerized applications
so spark can even work in a kubernetes
setup one of the important things of
spark which really makes it powerful is
lazy evaluation so what is lazy
evaluation in spark when spark operates
on any data set that is the data which
you are interested in processing it
would take care of the processing based
on various steps within your application
each step basically creates a rdd a
resilient distributed data set so for
example if I would want to read a file I
could use a method of spark context
called text file and this would create
an rdd then you could do a map or a flat
map or a filter and all these steps what
you code in your application are lazily
evaluated that is they are not evaluated
as soon as the step is created they are
evaluated they are executed only when
action is invoked so whenever you do a
transformation such as map or filter or
flat map or you just use a method of
spark context in this case it will only
and only create an rdd a resilient
distributed data set which exists in the
memory but this rdd does not have any
data loaded does not have any
transformation done so transformations
in spark are evaluated only when one
would invoke an action so till then it
is called as lazy evaluation that is it
does not evaluate the file which you are
processing or any map or filter or any
other transformation so the question is
what makes spark good at low latency
workloads like graph processing and
machine learning so how does spark
achieve that so as we discussed earlier
your Apache spark is good in storing
data in memory for faster processing and
model building so any component of spark
you use such as spark SQL spark core
spark ml lab spark streaming or Graphics
in any of these cases it is in-memory
processing that means the data is loaded
into the memory of the respective worker
nodes and then the processing happens
plus the data which is loaded in memory
which is undergoing some Transformations
and results in some kind of intermittent
data that data can be stored or cached
in memory for further processing when
you talk about machine learning machine
learning algorithms require sometimes
multiple iterations to create a optimal
model even your graph algorithms
Traverse all the nodes and edges so
basically these low latency work nodes
that need multiple iterations can lead
to an increased performance because you
are doing the processing in smaller
iterations by loading data in the memory
so there is also a concept of automatic
cleanups so the question is how can you
trigger automatic cleanups in spark to
handle accumulated metadata and there is
a parameter or you can say property
which needs to be set to trigger the
cleanups you need to set parameter
spark.cleaner.td LX time to live and
that's where your job which is running
which is divided into batches and writes
the data to the disk you could trigger a
cleanup based on this parameter now how
do you connect Spa to Apache mesos so
suppose you have Apache meso setup but
then you would also want to do in-memory
processing using Park how do you do it
so first thing what we will have to do
here is configure the spark driver
program to basically connect to apache's
mesos that is you have to give your
connection details to connect to Apache
mesos then you will have to put your
spark binary package that is spark
installation package or binary package
in a location accessible by mesos so
mesos knows that where Spark is existing
spark can install in the same location
as that of Apache mesos and then you can
also configure some properties which
says what is the spark mesos executor
home pointing to location where Spark is
installed so basically your Apache
Resource has to be informed about spark
and Spark can be existing with
apachement Source or within Apache main
source so that it can use Apache mesos
now one more question which you can
expect in interview or if somebody is
testing your knowledge is about
different data formats now other than
your regular formats such as Json XML
text CSV there are other intelligent
format such as binary files or sequence
file formats you have Avro you have
parquet and so on so parquet is
basically columnar format which is
supported by several data processing
systems so if you have say for example
you have data which is in CSV which has
multiple fields or multiple columns and
you do not access all the fields or all
the columns all the time it would be
advisable to go for a parquet format
wherein spark can perform read and write
operations by default that is whenever
spark tries to data set it will assume
that data is in a parquet format and if
your data is in a different format then
you have to specify that so advantages
of having a columnar storages you can
fetch specific columns for access it
consumes less space obviously brings
down your disk usage by 62 percent
approximately it follows type specific
encoding and controls your IO operation
so if you would be interested in reading
about different formats I can share a
good link with you which talks about
formats and here can find let's look at
formats this is the good link which
basically shows you details about
different data formats such as
compression schemes you have metadata
management you have different common
file formats you have binary files or
sequence file formats which can be
compressed at a block level or record
level and support splitability you also
have other formats such as Avro and
parquet and this is a very good document
you can refer to now coming back let's
look at the next question so what is
shuffling in spark and when does this
happen now shuffling as we know would
basically mean similar kind of data
being brought together so shuffling is
the process of redistributing your data
across partitions now what we know is
whenever we do a transformation whenever
we use a method of spark what does it do
it creates an oddity now unless and
until you have specified how many
logical partitions of that rdd you want
it will by default create number of
partitions based on either the data set
size or based on the number of cores
which are available in your cluster or
it could be that you are basically
creating partitions by default that is
two so say for example you have a data
which you would want to process and that
data is converted into a key value pair
so take an example you have a sentence
welcome to my world now if I want to
split this in a key value combination
where I would say my first word will
become the key and the complete line
becomes the value so my key would be
welcome and the value would be welcome
to my world now if you have similar data
like this which is key value Pairs and
that is because of some transformation
you did on a data set all this data
would be in a rdd during the time of
valuation and this rdd would have
partitions so you would have some key
value pairs in Partition one some key
value pairs in Partition two now suppose
you would want to do something like a
join or suppose you want to do a group
by or a sort by based on key now how
would that happen that would be possible
when the similar keys are brought into
the same partition so that will trigger
shuffling so that your key value pairs
which are stored in rdd which are stored
in rdd in partitions you will have your
similar Keys shuffled and brought to the
same partition where then you can do
some key based operations now that's
where you're shuffling in spark happens
there is also an operation called
collace and why is that used in spark so
spark use collace method to reduce the
number of partitions in a data frame now
what we know is whenever you are working
on structured data and this structured
data basically whenever you do a
transformation on it it creates a schema
rdd or what we call as data frame so
what is data frame you know like a table
which has rows and columns with headings
so scolace is basically used to reduce
the number of partitions in a data frame
so for example you have four partitions
which have some values and what you
would want to do is you would want to
filter the data in such a way that you
will remove the multiples of 10. so here
you see we can be using Collis for this
which will remove all the values which
are multiples of 10. so data is read
from a CSV into an rdd the rdd has some
empty partitions it makes sense to
reduce the number of partitions why not
and using collace you can bring your
data together in less number of
partitions and get rid of the partitions
which really do not have any data now
the question is how can you calculate
the executor memory or calculate the
memory which will be required by the
executors which will take care of your
tasks okay so let's continue new
learning on some spark interview
questions now here's our next question
so how can you calculate the executor
memory right now when you talk about
executor it is the jvm process which
will take care of your spark application
related tasks that would be executed so
let's say this is your cluster so you
have 10 nodes each node has 16 cores
that is you can then take away one for
your operating system itself each node
has Ram which is 61 gigabyte of RAM and
when you talk about your course your
course is the number of concurrent tasks
an Executor can run in parallel so the
general rule of thumb for optimal value
is Phi now it depends now when you talk
about number of executor identification
how do you do that so number of
executors is equal to number of cores
that the machine has divided by the
concurrent tasks so if we say we have 15
cores and we have five concurrent tasks
so we get number of executors is three
and depending on the number of nodes you
have you can multiply that with the
number of executor in each node which
would run for your data processing and
that will give you number of executors
for your spark job so in our case we
have 10 nodes we are talking about the
number of executor in each node which we
just calculated as three and then that
gives me the total number of executors
right now this is how you can basically
calculate the executor related memory
now let's look at some spark core
questions so what are the various
functionalities supported by spark core
so what is parkour spark core is the
engine for parallel and distributed
processing of large data sets so you
could be scheduling and monitoring your
jobs you could be doing memory
management fault recovery and task
dispatching so these are various
functionalities which are supported by
your spark core now what is the
significance of rdds that is your
resilient distributed data sets in spark
now rdds are the building blocks in
spark so spark core is embedded with
rdds which is basically the fundamental
data data structure of Apache spark what
are rdds these are immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects that can be operated in parallel
and when are these rtds getting created
whenever you do some transformation so
either you would be using a method of
spark context or say the initial entry
point for your application that's your
spark context so methods could be
something like text file whole text file
parallelize and so on or you could be
doing some series of Transformations so
per transformation you do on your rdd it
creates a further rdd so you could be
doing a map flat map filter and many
more so rdds by default whenever they
are created they are split into what we
call as logical partitions now when we
are creating an rdd we could also
mention how many partitions we want so
rdds are split into partitions and they
can be executed on different nodes of a
cluster how do you convert a spark rdd
into a data frame now we know that spark
core comes with the rdd concept that
spark RTD is the basic API and then you
have other apis and Sparks such as data
frame and data sets so if you would want
to convert a rdd into Data frame you
could be using a helper function called
to DF so here we are importing a package
and then we would want to create a data
frame so we use the spark context we
load from map rdb so we basically are
getting the data from a table we are
also giving some conditions like where
field is something you are doing a
select and finally you are doing a two
data frame which will convert your rdd
into a data frame now you could also be
doing that using spark sessions method
create data frame so as we know that
when you work with spark rdd you use for
context and when you would want to work
with spark SQL you would be using the
internal class that is spark session and
that has different methods so you could
be creating a data frame using Create
data frame so you can convert an rdd of
row to a data frame by calling create
data frame on a spark session object
looking further so if somebody asks you
explain two types of operations
supported by rdds now as I said earlier
rdds are created either when you use a
Smart context and a method of spark
context like text file parallelize whole
text files or when you do some
Transformations so there are two kind of
operations which are mainly supported by
rdds one is your Transformations and
second is your action so any or every
transformation you do it will only
result in an rdd which basically means a
logical step but there will be no
execution happening so your
Transformations are operations that are
performed on an rdd to create a new rdd
how is this rdd initially coming into
existence so if I would have said Val x
equals SC dot text file and then I pass
a file into that that would create an
rdd or if I do a c dot parallelize or if
I do SC dot whole text files or a
sequence file so that would have created
my initial rdd and then I could be doing
any Transformations on that you could
also be doing the second kind of
operation which actually leads to the
execution of your spark tag and that's
your actions so whenever you launch an
action you would have your spark
applications execution happening so when
you talk about actions it could be take
it could be collect it could be reduce
it could be first count and so on so
these are your two kinds of operations
which are supported by rdds now how do
you programmatically specify schema for
a data frame so we know that we can be
reading say CSV or text or Json or Avro
or parquet so you could be reading any
kind of data in different data format
and if you use spark sessions method
method like read or read dot format dot
load now that creates a data frame but
sometimes you may be interested in
working on a data where you would want
to specify the schema for every field
that data has for example you have a
list which has ID name and salary and
what you want to do is you want to
assign a schema to it and that can again
be done in two ways one you can be
creating a case class and then passing
in the schema to every field or you
could be using struct field so here we
are doing a DOT map we are selecting
every field and then we are using a
struct field which will basically get
the data type and apply that to every
field what is the lineage graph now when
you talk about spark as I said every
step you do in a spark application
starting from your initialization or
starting from using your spark context
method it creates a rdd and each rdd is
like a logical step in your spark
applications dag right so when you talk
about spark applications dag it has
series of steps which are which you have
coded which have either a method of
spark context or series of
transformation so this whole dag is
basically like a lineage graph now spark
does not support data replication in the
memory well we can have persistence
which can be done so if you would want
spark to benefit from a rdd graph for a
rdd lineage which was already created
then spark has an internal way of
capturing the lineage of your steps so
lineage is basically a flow so it is
also called an rdd operator graph or rdd
dependency graph now let's look at some
some spark streaming questions so one of
the question is what do you understand
by D streams in spark so when you are
working on streaming data or when you
intend to process streaming data you
would be interested in capturing the
data at various time intervals now now
your D streams or discretized streams is
basically the abstraction so what
happens is when you have a continuous
stream of data that is coming in as
input coming from some Source or you
have a process data stream by some
application this data stream or this
input stream is broken down into smaller
batches of data and these smaller
batches are called your D Stream So if
we see here we see data from time 0 to 1
1 to 2 2 3 and 3 to 4. so this is
nothing but my D streams and each these
stream is a smaller batch of data on
which you would have series of
Transformations which will be applied
based on what you have coded in your
spark applications now let's learn about
caching in spark streaming so if
somebody says what is caching in spark
streaming so we know spark does
in-memory processing so does it have
caching yes so that is your persistence
so caching is also known as persistence
or optimization technique for spark
computations so basically when when you
have your processing happening from 1D
stream to other dstream you could have
persistence implemented now that helps
you to save interim partial results so
that they can be if required reused in
subsequent stages so when we talk about
the default persistence level that is to
set to replicate the data to two nodes
for fault tolerance so when you have
your streaming and stream processing
happening we can have the Persistence of
that computation across nodes now one of
the main problems which also is seen
when you talk about spark application is
operations like joints so if you intend
to do joins across multiple rdds one of
the problem it poses is that first of
all the rdds which you are working on
should be like a pair rdd or what we
call as a key value pair rdd and if you
do something like join then in that case
in in every rdd which is nothing but a
pair RTD or you can say the data within
the rdd is in the form of key value
pairs so all the similar keys and we
know that rdds have partitions so all
the similar Keys have to be shuffled
across partitions so that similar Keys
land in the same partition now this
would be happening on other rdd also
which you would want to join so you have
rdd1 which has partitions and this rtd1
has key value pair and all the keys have
to be sorted and brought into same
partition similarly it will be on the
second rdd and then a join can happen so
this can be triggering a lot of
shuffling which would be happening when
you're doing a join kind of operation
now that could be tackled by using
broadcast variables so basically this
one allows the programmer to keep a
read-only variable cached on each
machine rather than shipping a copy of
it so you could be creating a broadcast
variable and this broadcast variable can
be used in operations like point so this
broadcast variable will then be shipped
to memory of every node so if you do a
join in two rdds one of the rdds can be
broadcasted as a broadcast variable and
when you do a join using this broadcast
variable and the other rdd it will be
faster it will avoid lot of shuffling
and then you could do your operations
more efficiently so which transformation
returns a new D stream by selecting only
those records of source D stream for
which function returns true so if we
have this question so the answer would
be filter so filter transformation will
give a new dstream by selecting only
those records of source D string for
which function returns true now does
Apache spark provide checkpoints and the
answer is yes there is a checkpointing
mechanism which can be used in streaming
so Apache spark provides an API for
adding and managing checkpoints so
checkpointing is the process of making
your streaming app applications
resilient to failures so you could be
creating a streaming context you could
set also a checkpoint path and you could
Define a d Stream So when you start your
streaming application it will not only
be capturing data at regular intervals
based on how your receiver has been set
but you could also have a checkpointing
mechanism which makes sure that every
computation which happens over a dstream
can then be using a checkpoint mechanism
if any kind of recovery is required what
do you mean by sliding window operation
no that's one more extensibility of your
spark streaming so you can not only do
streaming on at regular intervals using
your spark streaming context but then
you can also control the transmission of
data packets between multiple networks
you could be using spark streaming for
it so spark streaming Library provides
windowed computations so windowed
computations basically means a set of
intervals for which they the data was
received and you would want to do a
processing based window based operation
it will look at the last three instances
and then it gives you a window based
output so that's your windowing now what
are the different levels of persistence
in spark so spark as we know whatever
app steps you create in your application
those steps lead to an rdd whenever you
are doing some transformation on using a
method of spark context but if you are
triggering an action that basically
triggers the execution of your
application now at certain times in some
steps whatever computation was done you
may want to use the same computation
again down your application now in that
case caching can benefit so you could do
persistence by default it is memory but
then you could use all these different
options of Storage level such as disk
only so you can have the rdds or the
computations stored on the disk you
could have memory only in a serialized
way so that is storing the rdds
serialized Java objects with one byte
array per partition you have memory only
that is storing the rtds as deserialized
Java objects in the jvm and if an rdd is
or cannot fit into memory it will be
recomputed now you could have something
like off Heap so it works with memory
only serialization but stores the data
in off Heap memory you have memory and
disk and you can choose the percentage
so memory and disk basically means the
rdds which are getting created as a part
of your application those rtds are
stored as deserialized Java objects and
if in case the RTD is not able to fit in
the memory additional partitions are
stored on the disk so you could also
have memory and disk serialize so all of
these come with Storage level and this
is how you can have persistence achieved
in spark where you would want to
purchase some rdd computations now
somebody might ask you a difference
between different Transformations like
you have map and Flat map so what's the
difference whether it is spark streaming
or spark core so when you talk about
your math function it basically in terms
of spark streaming gives you a new D
stream by passing each element of the
sourcet stream through a function so
technically speaking you are applying a
function on that dstream which is
getting collected or which is getting
created now spark map function what does
it do it takes one element at a time and
based on whatever you have given in your
code it applies that function of the
data it takes every time or of the
element it takes every time when you
talk about flat map it is basically a
combination of map and flattening or it
is basically flat map does the
flattening so it is similar to map
function it applies the function to each
element of rdd so your flat map allows
returning 0 1 or more elements from the
map function so it is basically
flattening it or it is splitting your
data into individual elements now how do
you compute the total count of unique
words in spark so this is basically you
doing a word count in spark now in
layman terms you could take a file
depending on if you are doing a word
count you would want to split that file
and get individual words in the file and
then you would want to write some kind
of loop which looks into these words and
does a counting of these words if the
word serve if the words are repetitive
so you can load the file as RTD using SC
dot text file you could then apply a
function to the particular line so you
could be doing a tokenizing that is
splitting your line into individual
words then you could do a flat map so
that you can get all the words split and
exploded or extracted from the file you
could convert each word into a key value
pair because you remember we are doing a
word count so we can have a key value
pair where key is the word and the value
is say number one which is assigned to
every word then you could be doing a
reduced by key action so Reduce by key
action is basically going to reduce the
database on the keys and give you a
total okay and finally you can print the
result so this is how you can do a word
count in spark so some suppose you have
a huge text file how will you check if
particular keyword exists using smart
and that's pretty simple so you could
already be doing a if line dot find and
then give your keyword and you could be
pushing it to say minus one you could be
doing a return one or return 0 depending
on what you are trying to do so here we
are creating a function which basically
takes the lines does a map and applies a
function called is found and then what
it does is you want to search for a
particular keyboard now that could also
be done using something like starts with
or contains so there are other ways in
which also you can search for particular
keyword that exist using spark now one
of the important questions is what is
the role of accumulators in spark now
like we discussed broadcast variables
which are basically shipped into the
memory of nodes and when can be useful
when you would be using joins similarly
when you talk about accumulators these
are variables we which are used for
aggregating information across the
executors now this information can be
about the data or API diagnosis like how
many records are are corrupted or how
many times a library API was called and
you can always look for this information
in the spark UI so accumulators play an
important role when it comes to
aggregating information which can then
be used across executes let's look at
some spark ml lab questions so basically
understanding about spark ml lib or
spark ml Library which is used for
machine learning algorithms so what are
the different ml lib tools available in
spark now when you talk about ml
algorithms you have algorithms for
different kind of statistical or machine
learning problems like you have
classification regression clustering and
collaborative filtering you also have
for featurization that is for feature
extraction transformation dimensionality
action and selection of data you have
pipelines these are tools for
constructing evaluating and tuning ml
pipelines that is basically having a set
of different algorithms which can be
used you have persistence that is saving
and loading algorithms models and
pipelines so you could always be
persisting your algorithms and you have
utilities for linear algebra statistics
and handling so these are different
tools which are available in mlib in
spark what are the different data types
supported by spark mlib now this is
again a common question asked so spark
mlib supports local vectors and matrices
stored on a single machine as well as
distributed matrices so you have local
Vector which when you talk about local
Vector that's a data type which ml lib
supports so mlib supports two types of
local vectors which is dense and sparse
so if you would have Vector in this
particular form you could create a dense
format of out of it or a sparse format
and if you talk about label point which
is mainly for your labels or responses
so this is a local Vector which is
either dense or sparse and mainly
associated with label or response so in
binary classification a label could be
just 0 or 1. if you look at other data
types so you also have local Matrix and
distributed Matrix so spark ml lib
supports local vectors and matrices
stored on a single machine as well as
distributed matrices So when you say
local Matrix it has integer type row and
column indices and double type values
that is stored in a single machine so
here we are looking at a matrix of 3
into 2 size and if you look in one
dimensional array this is how it would
look if you talk about distributed
Matrix a distributed Matrix has long
type row and column indices and double
type values so it is stored in a
distributed manner in one or more RTD
and there are various types of
distributed Matrix so you have row
Matrix you have index row Matrix and
coordinate Matrix for data types you can
always go and type say spark ml lib data
types and that takes you to the spark
documentation wherein you can look at
these different data types which were
talking about like local Vector label
Point local Matrix and distributed
Matrix and that basically has your four
different types such as row indexed
coordinate and block Matrix so moving
further what is this sparse Vector now
we were talking about local Vector local
Matrix which has dense and sparse Vector
so sparse Vector is a type of local
Vector which is represented by an
indexed array and a value array so for
example if we have sparse 1 and you
create a sparse Vector so here 4 is the
size of the vector 1 comma 3 are ordered
indices of the vector and 3 and 4 are
the value so you have an indexed array
and a value array which is represented
by sparse Vector now if somebody asks
you describe how model creation works
with mlib and how the model is applied
so basically spark mlib has two main
components it has a Transformer now
that's that's what which reads a data
frame and returns a new data frame with
a specific transformation applied now
that transformation could be anything it
could be map it could be flat map it
could be filter or you could have other
Transformations when you talk about
estimator estimator is a machine
learning algorithm that takes a data
frame to train a model and Returns the
model as a Transformer so the output of
estimator would be a model which could
then be tested against our data if you
look at the model creation and if
somebody says how model creation works
with mlib and how model is applied so
spark ml lib lets you combine multiple
Transformations into a pipeline to apply
complex data Transformations now if you
look at the image on the left it says
pipeline for training a model so you
would be looking at estimator so you
have a tokenizer which will basically do
the tokenizing or splitting of data you
have hashing TF and then you are
applying a logistic regression model so
this would be your estimator now you
could have a Transformer so model
produced can then be applied to live
data so that is you have a pipeline
model so you are using this would be
called as a Transformer so you again
have tokenizing hashing TF and you're
applying a logistic regression model now
based on this pipeline where you have
estimated so you could be doing a fit
method so pipeline dot fit which will
then be working on a raw text it gives
you say tokenized output that is words
it will give you free teacher vectors
that is where you are doing
featurization and then you are solving
the problem using logistic regression
model if you talk about pipeline model
so where we are talking about
Transformer so you can say
pipelinemodel.transform and this
basically will work on Raw text gives
you words or feature vectors and finally
gives you the prediction so this is how
a model creation and application is done
in mlib now let's look at some spark SQL
questions so spark SQL is again an
important component in spark when it
comes to processing your structured data
so what are the functions of spark SQL
now spark SQL is a Apache Sparks module
for working with structured data or data
which can be easily structurized so what
are the different functions here you can
load data from a variety of structured
data sources you can then query the data
using SQL statement so you could be
having your SQL statements within a
spark program or from external tools
that connect to spark SQL through
standard database connectors such as
jdbc odbc so you could be using spark
SQL to connect to say Hive Data
Warehouse on top of Hadoop it can be
used to connect to rdbms and you can get
in your structured data or you could be
accessing the structured data which lies
on hdfs and then run your SQL queries
which would still be using Sparks in
memory processing capability your spark
SQL also provides Rich integration
between SQL and your other programming
language codes such as python Java Scala
and so on and you can also join rdds and
SQL tables and expose custom functions
in SQL so these are some of the
functions or you can say features of
Apache spark SQL component how do you
connect Hive to spark SQL so we all know
that when you work with Hive Hive would
have a hive hyphen site file which would
have different properties for spark for
Hive and this Hive hyphen side file
would also have the metadata information
or the location where Hive stores the
metadata and this particular config file
of Hive needs to be placed in the config
directory of spark now once you place
this Hive hyphen site file in the config
directory of spark if you would use
spark either spark shell or Pi spark or
even running a spark application you
could directly say spark.sql and then
give your select queries targeting your
hive table so this is how you can be
directly working with Hive using spark
SQL now one important question is what
is the role of catalyst Optimizer in
spark SQL so what does it do Catalyst
Optimizer it basically leverages
Advanced programming language features
such as colors pattern matching and
Cassie codes in a noble way to build an
extensible query Optimizer which is used
by SQL so you would have your SQL query
which is in intending to access some
data and that would have some kind of
unresolved logical plan to get to the
data now you also have metadata which is
stored in case of Hive which spark would
need to access so this unresolved
logical plan is converted into a logical
plan based on some logical optimization
you have optimized logical plan now this
plan is nothing but your execution path
so these physical plans what we are
talking about use a cost model and they
select a physical plan which will be
used to access the data which is then
used by rdds and the code is generated
so this is how Catalyst Optimizer
performs or helps you in an optimized
way of SQL query now these are some
examples here and this shows how can you
manipulate structured data using domain
specific language in spark SQL so spark
SQL as I mentioned allows you to work on
structured data now you could be
creating a data frame which is a schema
rdd so you could be using spark sessions
method which would be reading a file or
you might be interacting with directly
Hive in any of the cases you would have
a data frame and then on the data frame
you could do a select and select a field
you could be selecting multiple fields
and also do some computation you could
be doing a filter or a group by and all
of these functions work very well with
your data frames finally let's look at
some spark Graphics questions to see how
Graphics helps us in graph based
processing so what are the different
type of operators provided by Apache
Graphics library now we know that spark
Graphics will allow us to work on graph
based processing so there would be
vertices there would be edges and there
would be a property graph so when you
talk about different type of operation
creators provided by Apache Graphics you
have a property operator now this
modifies the vertex or Edge properties
using a user defined map function and
produces a new graph you also have a
structural operator now this operates on
the structure of an input graph and
produces a new graph however join
operator so join operators will
basically add data to graphs and
generate new graphs so these are three
important operators which are used in
Apache Graphics what are the analytic
programs provided in Apache spark
Graphics so there are some important
analytic algorithms provided by graphics
for your graph based processing
requirements you have page rank
algorithm you have connected components
and you have triangle counting you can
read about these more by looking into
the spark Graphics documentation where
all these algorithms and what they do is
explained in a very crisp n a
explanative way so what does the page
Rank and how one of them do and you
might have heard of page rank algorithm
which is used by Google or some other
search engines so page rank basically
measures the importance of each vertex
in a graph assuming an edge from say U
to V represents an endorsement of V's
importance by U now what we are doing
here is we are looking at two different
vertices we are looking at a
relationship between them and we are
looking at the overall graph which is
created by this u and v and how V is
endorsed based on use importance so for
example if a Twitter user is followed by
many other users that handle will be
ranked high so we are looking at a
connection where one Twitter user is
followed by many other users now
internally when you talk about page rank
algorithm you can understand this by
looking at or thinking about what Google
does so where you could have multiple
Pages which are being searched and each
page is initially assigned a rank and
based on the searches based on the
possibility of a page being found every
time the rank is incremented now that's
how page algorithm works thank you all
for watching this live session on spark
full course I hope this was useful and
informative if you have any questions
then please feel free to put them in the
comment section we'll be happy to answer
them thanks again stay safe and keep
learning